artificial intelligence or ai is one of
the most trending technologies of the
21st century hello everyone welcome to
this full course video on artificial
intelligence in this video we will cover
everything you need to know about ai our
experienced instructors with good
industry experience will take you
through this course first
you will understand the basics of
artificial intelligence from a short
animated video we will look at the
future of ai and listen to some of the
industry experts such as sundar pichai
jeff bezos and bill gates and learn what
they have to say about ai you will see
the top 10 applications of ai in 2021
then we'll understand about machine
learning and the different algorithms
used to build ai models we will get an
idea about another core component of
artificial intelligence that is deep
learning finally we learn the top 10
artificial intelligence technologies in
2021 so let's begin
picture this a machine that could
organize your cupboard just as you like
it or serve every member of the house a
customized cup of coffee makes your day
easier doesn't it these are the products
of artificial intelligence but why use
the term artificial intelligence well
these machines are artificially
incorporated with human-like
intelligence to perform tasks as we do
this intelligence is built using complex
algorithms and mathematical functions
but ai may not be as obvious as in the
previous examples in fact ai is used in
smartphones cars social media feeds
video games banking surveillance and
many other aspects of our daily life the
real question is what does an ai do at
its core here is a robot we built in our
lab which is now dropped onto a field in
spite of a variation in lighting
landscape and dimensions of the field
the ai robot must perform as expected
this ability to react appropriately to a
new situation is called generalized
learning the robot is now at a crossroad
one that is paved and the other rocky
the robot must determine which path to
take based on the circumstances this
portrays the robot's reasoning ability
after a short stroll the robot now
encounters a stream that it cannot swim
across using the plank provided as an
input the robot is able to cross this
stream so our robot uses the given input
and finds the solution for a problem
this is problem solving these three
capabilities make the robot artificially
intelligent
in short ai provides machines with the
capability to adapt reason and provide
solutions
well now that we know what ai is let's
have a look at the two broad categories
an ais classified into
weak ai also called narrow ai focuses
solely on one task
for example alphago is a maestro of the
game go but you can't expect it to be
even remotely good at chess
this makes alphago a weak ai
you might say alexa is definitely not a
weak ai since it can perform multiple
tasks well that's not really true when
you ask alexa to play despacito it picks
up the keywords play and despacito
and runs a program and is trained to
alexa cannot respond to a question it
isn't trained to answer for instance try
asking alexa the status of traffic from
work to home
alexa cannot provide you this
information as she is not trained to
and that brings us to our second
category of a.i strong ai
now this is much like the robots that
only exist in fiction as of now
ultron from avengers is an ideal example
of a strong ai
that's because it's self-aware and
eventually even develops emotions
this makes the ai's response
unpredictable
you must be wondering well how is
artificial intelligence different from
machine learning and deep learning
we saw what ai is machine learning is a
technique to achieve ai and deep
learning in turn is a subset of machine
learning
machine learning provides a machine with
the capability to learn from data and
experience through algorithms
deep learning does this learning through
ways inspired by the human brain
this means through deep learning data
and patterns can be better perceived ray
kurzweil a well-known futurist predicts
that by the year 2045 we would have
robots as smart as humans
this is called the point of singularity
well that's not all
in fact elon musk predicts that the
human mind and body will be enhanced by
ai implants which would make us partly
cyborgs
so here's a question for you which of
the below ai projects don't exist yet
a an ai robot with citizenship b a robot
with a muscular skeletal system
c ai that can read its owner's emotions
d ai that develops emotions over time
give it a thought and leave your answers
in the comment section below since the
human brain is still a mystery it's no
surprise that ai2 has a lot of
unventured domains
for now ai is built to work with humans
and make our tasks easier
however with the maturation of
technology we can only wait and watch
what the future of ai holds for us
well that is artificial intelligence for
you in short do not forget to leave your
answer to the quiz in the comment
section below
[Music]
what's interesting to me is we will use
ai as we have been to specifically
target tasks that we need or want done
in place of ourselves
that's how ai will ultimately unfold
it is a renaissance it is a golden age
we are now solving problems with machine
learning and artificial intelligence
that were you know kind of in the realm
of science fiction for the last several
decades
ai is probably the most important thing
humanities has ever worked on and i
think of it as something more profound
than electricity or fire
and anytime you work with technology
you need to learn to harness the
benefits
and while minimizing the downside
[Music]
is we're focusing on autonomous systems
and clearly one purpose of autonomous
systems is self-driving cars there are
others
and we sort of see it as the mother of
all ai projects
there's a class of things like game
plane
or speech recognition or image
recognition
that the performance levels are
phenomenal
you know if you compare human speech
recognition computer speech recognition
the computer is slightly better and
that's you know mind blowing
certainly we use ai to do
drug discovery
these biological systems are very
complicated and so the fact that we have
vaccines for tb and hiv coming that's
partly enabled by this rich data advance
in biology and machine learning
when i look at
seeing ai which is an application we
just launched for anybody with visual
impairment they can go download this app
that uses the latest cutting edge
computer vision technology in our cloud
to give anyone the ability to see and in
fact angela mills who's a colleague of
mine was just telling me about how it's
changed her life inside of microsoft she
can go into our cafeteria order food
using this app with confidence walk into
conference rooms with confidence because
she knows she's walking into the right
conference room or what we've done with
our one note and word learning tools
anyone who has dyslexia can now use ai
to be able to read better the latest
release of windows 10 has this
capability called eye gaze which is
something that we learned working with
steve gleason and the als patients
saying if you all you have is the eye
muscle
and the gaze can we help you type
yeah you have to be careful uh when
there's advances in a sense we're all
better off if the machines can make all
the food and the clothes and none of us
have to work
uh you know you think okay now we have
all the freedom if we want to stand
behind the the counter and you know
make sandwiches okay you can if you want
but there's this other way to make those
goods and services but it will be very
disruptive uh because you know say your
mid-career
in manufacturing or driving
then it's a disruption now we've had
that in a slow way for hundreds of years
you know we used to all be farmers now
very few of us are farmers i said it's
right to be concerned absolutely you
have to worry about it otherwise you're
not going to solve it right and it's
important to understand tomorrow whether
google is there or not
you know artificial intelligence is
going to progress uh you know technology
has
this nature
it's going to evolve
i think
pulling back history shows pulling back
countries which pull back don't do well
with the change we know that
20 30 years ago you educated yourself
and that carried you through for the
rest of your life
that is not going to be true for the
generation which is being born now
they have to learn continuously over
their lives we know that so we have to
transform how we do education
look i think i mean you nailed it
anything that's repetitive and done
you know on the back of you know
technology or you know is going to be
fundamentally vulnerable yeah so i think
uh technology in particular ai can in
fact bring more empowerment more
inclusiveness and at the same time we
should be clear-eyed about displacement
clear-eyed about unintended consequences
like any other technology and work both
skilling so that you know people can
find the jobs of the future
create new jobs and
lastly i think have a set of policy
decisions
that really help people
as they go through this change
the risks are
important and i think the way we solve
it is
we think ahead we worry about it
we
do things like from from be upfront
you know have ethical charters think
about ai safety from day one be very
transparent and open in how we
perceive progress there and figure out
global frameworks by which we can engage
just like paris agreement and climate
change you know using forums like this i
think we bring people together to engage
on the hard questions and i think ansys
will emerge
you know i have exposure to the very
most cutting edge
ai
and i think people should be really
concerned about it
i keep sounding the alarm bell but you
know until
people see like robots going down the
street killing people like they don't
know how to react you know because it
seems so ethereal
and
i think we should be really concerned
about ai and i think we should
this ai is a rare case where i think we
need to be proactive in regulation
instead of reactive
because i think by the time we are
reactive in ai regulation it's too late
right now we have
machine learning algorithms that can
solve an incredibly complex problem
beyond any human intelligence but
they're essentially complete idiots and
like two-year-olds and anything that's
not that problem they're dumb
they're like that you can give them this
enormous data set and they come up with
brilliant correlations and insights
but they're not going to plug into
skynet and you know like like like
threaten us anytime soon
so i'm quite optimistic
and uh i don't think
artificial intelligence is a threat i
don't think that if at fish intelligence
is something terrible
but human being are smart enough to
learn that
[Music]
hey guys welcome to this simply learn
session on ai applications in 2020 so
here's a small refresher about
artificial intelligence artificial
intelligence refers to intelligence
displayed by machines that simulates
human intelligence
basically it's the ability of a machine
or a program to think and learn now that
you're all caught up let's take a look
at how different domains are using ai
let's have a look at the current market
state of ai
according to tractica a market research
firm the global ai market is expected to
reach a revenue of 118 billion dollars
by 2025.
next according to the research firm
gartner ai usage has grown by 270
percent in the last four years a clear
indication of the growth that's yet to
come in the upcoming years
in fact 87 percent of companies that
actually have adopted ai were using it
to improve email marketing and in some
news that could be positive or negative
depending on how you look at it 75
countries are now using ai technology
for surveillance now let's have a look
at how artificial intelligence is used
in different domains
first off ai applications in e-commerce
ai offers you personalized shopping with
ai you have a recommendation engine
through which you can engage better with
your customers
these recommendations are made by taking
into consideration their usage history
their preferences and interests
by providing these recommendations what
you're doing is basically improving your
relationship with your customers you are
improving their loyalty towards your
brand and by extension causing an
increase in the number of conversions
with ai you can provide users the
ability to perform visual searches users
can upload an image of the item they
require search results are shown that
match their query so all of this can be
done without them having to type a
single word next we have ai powered
assistance assistants like virtual
shopping assistants and chat bots help
improve use experience while shopping
online for this techniques like nlp or
natural language processing are used to
make the conversation sound as human and
personal as possible did you know that
soon customer service could be handled
by chatbot on amazon.com moreover these
assistants can have real-time engagement
with your customers they can handle
multiple situations like if the customer
has some feedback the chatbot will take
it from them or if they have some basic
questions about your brand the chatbot
can help them out these assistants can
help further emphasize the point to the
users about how important they are to
your organization
next under e-commerce we have smart
purchasing customer trends are often
difficult to predict but with ai they
don't have to be ai can forecast demands
related to a particular product with
this knowledge your decisions on what
products to stock up and when it needs
to be done can be positively impacted
doing this you're meeting customer
expectations and improving their
experience with your brand
finally under e-commerce we have fraud
prevention
two of the biggest issues that
e-commerce companies have to deal with
are credit card fraud and fake reviews
by taking into consideration usage
patterns ai can help deal with reducing
the possibility of credit card frauds
taking place
talking about fake reviews did you know
that more than 80 percent of customers
decide to buy a product or service based
on their customer reviews ai can help
identify and handle fake reviews by
making sure they're handled you are
improving customer trust in your brand
and products some of the organizations
that have already started ai are amazon
alibaba.com and ebay based on research
performed by mit gps technology can
provide users with accurate timely and
detailed information to improve safety
the technology uses a combination of
conventional neural networks and graph
neural network which makes lives easier
for users by automatically determining
the number of lanes and road types
behind obstructions on the roads
next up we have ai applications in
robotics first off let's have a look at
mobility
robots that are powered by ai will use
real-time updates they would be able to
maneuver through a particular part of
travel with this path the robot can
sense obstacles in its path and then
pre-plan its journey it can be used for
carrying goods in factories warehouses
and hospitals cleaning offices and large
equipments inventory management and it
is also used for exploring environments
that are too dangerous for humans
ai can also be used in process
optimization
data obtained by sensors can be analyzed
to enhance ai intelligence with this
knowledge unnecessary breakdowns are
prevented and it can also reduce
associated costs of major issues
next up let's see how ai is applied in
the human resources domain
now this is something most people
wouldn't have expected did you know that
companies use software to ease the
hiring process
artificial intelligence helps with blind
hiring
software that uses machine learning can
be used to sift through applications
based on specific parameters ai can be
used to scan job candidates profiles and
resumes to provide recruiters an
understanding of the talent pool they
must choose from now let's have a look
at ai applications in healthcare first
off let's have a look at how ai is used
in patient care so there are these
things called prescription errors which
are basically caused due to slips lapses
or mistakes in a doctor's prescription
let's face it a dosage too high can be
the difference between life and death
audit systems that use ai can help
prevent these kinds of errors from being
handled and the diseases are properly
identified some of the popular uses are
jvon analytic and welfare
next let's see how ai is used with
medical imaging and diagnostics
ai can help with early diagnosis to
analyze chronic conditions taking into
consideration laboratory and other
medical data it is also used with
advanced medical imaging through which
you can analyze and transform images
through this you can create models for
possible scenarios next up is ai
applications in research and development
ai is really important when it comes to
the discovery of new drugs this is made
possible with the help of a combination
of historical data and medical
intelligence it also helps understand
the human gene and its components it
also helps predict the different
outcomes possible if gene editing is
performed right now there's probably
scientists racing to develop the gene
sequence for kovid 19 and towards the
creation of the vaccine now that we have
reached midwest i have a question to ask
are you guys using ai powered software
in your workplace let me know in the
live chat if you enjoy watching
informative tech videos like this one
consider subscribing to simply learn's
channel to stay up to date on the
trending technologies and hit the bell
icon to never miss an update in the
future next up let's talk about ai
applications in agriculture first off ai
helps with monitoring crop and soil
health it can help with identifying
defects and nutrient deficiency in the
soil by analyzing images of soil and
patterns in them soil defects plant
pests and diseases can be identified
next ai helps decrease pesticide usage
using technology like computer vision
robotics and machine learning using this
kind of technology it can be determined
where weeds are grown this way
herbicides can be sprayed only where the
weeds are with this herbicide usage is
limited ai also helps with agriculture
bots it can be used to reduce human
labor by harvesting crops at a faster
rate and a higher volume next let's have
a look at artificial intelligence in
gaming one of the most important things
that game companies need to handle which
is labor costs this is done to generate
levels maps textures weapons characters
etc ai can be used to create smart
human-like npcs to interact with players
it can also be used to predict human
behavior using which game design and
testing can be improved
now this example isn't a recent one but
that of a 2014 game called alien
isolation
now if you know about the movies you
know it's from the alien series of
movies so in this game the titular alien
stalks the player throughout the game
the alien uses two ais to hunt the
player a director ai that always knows
the position of the location of the
player and an alien ai which is driven
by sensors and behaviors that constantly
hunt the player the director ai only
gives the alien ai clues to the player's
location which it needs to figure out
now let's have a look at ai application
in automobiles first off we have
driverless automobiles by taking a
combination of information obtained from
the vehicles camera radar cloud services
gps and control signals that can be used
to operate the vehicle it's thanks to
all of this that the car is able to
drive itself next ai offers driver
assistance ai can be used to improve the
in-vehicle experience as well systems
like emergency braking blind spot
monitoring driver asset steering are
used next up ai and social media first
let's see how facebook is able to use ai
one of the ways ai is being used is for
analyzing pictures this can be used to
identify the people in an image ai is
also used in a tool called deep text so
with the help of ai can be used to
analyze posts that represent suicidal
thoughts
the tool can also be used to translate
posts from different languages next
let's have a look at ai used by
instagram ai takes into account your
likes and the accounts you follow to
determine what posts you are shown on
your explore tab the deep text tool has
also been used recently to identify and
remove spam messages from user accounts
ai is also used for handling
cyberbullying to check content based on
hashtags from other users next up ai and
twitter ai is used to determine fraud
propaganda and hateful content on the
platform it is also used to recommend
tweets that the users might enjoy based
on what tweets that you engage with
it is also used to filter through
inappropriate content and remote from
the platform ai is also used for
automatically cropping images based on
face recognition it is also used to
filter through inappropriate content and
remove it from the platform ai is also
used for automatically cropping images
based on face recognition and finally
let's have a look at ai applications and
marketing first off ai enables
programmatic advertising ai enables
highly targeted and personalized ads by
taking into consideration behavioral
analysis pattern recognition and much
more ai also enables you to retarget
audiences at right time to make sure
they are given appropriate results and
ensure feelings of annoyance and
distrust next up that's personalized
narratives ai can help with content
marketing in a way that matches the
brand style and voice it can also be
used to handle routine tasks like
performance campaign reports and much
more then ai helps with setting up
chatbots chatbots are powered by ai
natural language processing natural
language generation natural language
understanding that can understand what
the user's language and respond in the
ways humans do then we have personalized
ui and ux it can be used to provide
users with real-time personalization
basically these smart systems can
process information about site visitors
or app users then apply changes to the
model in ways that optimize it for
future use by continually learning and
adjusting the algorithms improves the
user's experience to offer a more
engaging personalized experience next ai
helps with localization it can help with
editing and optimizing market campaigns
to fit the needs of the local market by
automated editing of certain variables
like ctas ad copies etc the campaigns
would be able to connect better with a
local audience and there you go these
are the top applications of ai in 2020.
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1 000 plus hours of
video content for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more what do you
think is making our lives easier off
late and how do you think the world is
rapidly changing imagine getting into a
car feeding your destination as the
input and automatically getting dropped
off at your destination at the same time
you sit back and relax through the ride
without having to do anything at all
physically whoa
life has become so much simpler with all
kinds of automation taking us through
everyday life what do you think is
making all this possible artificial
intelligence thanks to numerous
advancements in technology which is
bringing about a lot of changes in our
day-to-day lives to drive innovation ai
is using machine learning taking things
one step further so what exactly do you
mean by artificial intelligence in
simple terms ai refers to simulating a
machine with human intelligence and
programming the device to think and act
like humans artificial intelligence also
called machine intelligence is far
beyond roboz as portrayed by science
fiction from google search algorithm to
amazon's alexa to apple siri to
self-driven cars ai progresses rapidly
towards a harmonious future between
technology and man bringing together the
best of both worlds
since the machines are artificially
incorporated with human-like
intelligence and perform tasks as we do
it's termed as artificial intelligence
and it was coined in 1956.
the programs that were developed after
ai was founded were simply astonishing
people could witness computers proving
theorems in geometry solving algebra
word problems and much more between the
1950s and 1970s neural networks emerged
from the 1980s until the last decade
machine learning took over the world now
is the era of deep learning the boons of
ai undoubtedly ai has changed our lives
in many ways at number one we have
safety factor there are many fields like
defense mining etc where human health is
at significant risk ai is the biggest
boon in these fields where a robo or a
drone does the work instead of a human
with the invention of self-driven cars
ai is airing at our road safety by
reducing the number of road traffic
accidents compared to those caused by
humans
speaking of language processing and
speech recognition ai helps in effective
communication by processing and
understanding the language spoken by
humans
it is also capable of comprehending the
words spoken by humans and reciprocate
in the same way all this is possible by
the voice assistant feature which the ai
bots have at number three we have daily
needs
be it alexa or apple siri we are
surrounded by various applications that
run on ai fingerprint detection face
detection gps grammarly all these run on
artificial intelligence
google maps calculate the traffic
congestion to find the best route to
your destination which works on ai
whether it is the mathematical
calculations booking a ticket buying a
product online and driving a car ai has
limited human interaction and provides
various services in all the unexpected
ways ai is helping humans in the
day-to-day needs
at number 4 we have healthcare ai is a
promising tool for supporting healthcare
administration it helps healthcare
workers and stakeholders to manage vast
amounts of data and transform them into
potentially life-saving information
in the present scenario people are
threatened by the growing health
emergency due to the spread of the
corvid 19 coronavirus a who report
released said that er is a vital part of
the response to this disease ai systems
are being developed predicting people's
temperatures and survival rates with
more than 90 accuracy one promising
approach of ai in the field of health
care is it guides vaccine design as
covet 19 began to spread globally
machine learning tools were used to
search immunogenic components of the
virus that would make good vaccine
candidates yet another field where the
ml is significantly evolving is genomics
which is the study of the complete set
of genes within an organism ai can
sequence and analyze dna much faster
cheaper and accurate than the
researchers ever will at number five we
have
one of the most amazing inventions by
humans that thinks intelligently and
acts autonomously the disinfecting
robots are playing a significant role in
these uncertain times they rove around
healthcare facilities spreading uv light
to disinfect places contaminated with
viruses
the benefits of ai robots far exceed the
apprehensions
speaking of role of technology
advancements
artificial intelligence is rapidly
advancing with a lot of computers and
robots capable of doing miracles
though the machines and robots cannot
have human feelings they can think and
act like humans
companies use techniques like machine
learning and neural networks to
accomplish artificial intelligence which
is also called machine intelligence in
the present scenario considering the
total intelligence we can conclude that
95 of it is machine intelligence and the
remaining 5 is what we call human
knowledge
speaking of ai versus human ai has a
positive as well as a negative impact on
us and society according to some recent
studies seven million existing jobs will
be replaced by ai in the uk between 2017
and 2037
but at the same time 7.2 million jobs
could be created as well
a study from mckinsey global institute
states that by 2030 automation will
replace 400 to 800 million jobs
requiring as many as 375 million people
to switch their job categories entirely
this is indeed going to cause fear and
concern to many vulnerable countries the
biggest challenge is how people would
make a living with these changes and
uncertainty
google ceo sundar pichai has claimed
that ai will be more transformative to
humanity than electricity ever will
google even launched an ai system which
bet some of the best atari 2600 game
players
also did you know that the best choice
player in the world is a machine how
would it be when the best doctor in the
world is a machine the best teacher is a
machine the best architect is a machine
and the best of many professions are
various machines and robots ais and
robos will replace fast-food joints and
radiologists in hospitals
someday ai will diagnose your cancer and
your robo will perform your surgery it
won't be long until a machine is
superior in every single professional
field warning by musk
this is extremely important
i think the danger of ai is much greater
than the the danger of nuclear warheads
by a lot
um
and nobody would suggest that we allow
anyone to just build nuclear warheads if
they want
that would be insane and mark my words
ai is far more dangerous than nukes
or
so why do we have no regulatory
oversight
this is insane
though ai is a boon to humankind in many
different ways not everyone is ready to
welcome ai with open arms some ai
experts like stephen hawking and elon
musk have warned us about the looming
dangers that ai may possess to humanity
they have even suggested that ai is
likely to be the greatest threat that
could end the human species
elon musk says that he is close to the
cutting edge in ai which scares him a
lot ai is vastly more than almost anyone
knows and the rate of improvement is
exponential he also says that ai is far
more dangerous than nuclear warheads
earlier in 2014 musk had described ai as
our biggest existential threat ai can be
harmful to us in two different ways the
idea that ai will become conscious and
responsive and seek to destroy us
also the notion that people with evil
hands can turn this ai into a critical
tool for wicked purposes
if the super intelligent ai more
intelligent than us becomes conscious we
will look at humans like how humans will
look at monkeys
people are afraid of ai by watching
movies like 2001 a space odyssey where
one of the most well-known ais turned
terrible the terminator the matrix and
few others these movies have speculated
about ai that far exceeds the
expectations of its creators and escapes
their control eventually targeting
humans for extinction
speaking of the real reasons to be
afraid of ai there are doctors engineers
accountants judges architects who seek
information from an ei system they treat
this information as it is from a trusted
colleague
this trust is what we should be afraid
of it is not because of how often ai
gets it wrong ai researchers pride
themselves on the accuracy of results it
is how bad it gets it wrong when it
makes a mistake these systems do not
fail gracefully one such incident is
when facebook had to shut down a
controversial chatbot experiment where
the two ais developed their own language
for communication a research was
conducted with two chatbots named alice
and bob focusing on how to negotiate
with each other unfortunately the
researchers found that the bots had
deviated from the actual script and had
started inventing their new phrases
without any human script as the bots
were left unsupervised they developed
their machine language which was
otherwise developed to converse with
people that's the scary part of ai
neural networks and deep learning the
developers and researchers working on
this would have no idea what it's doing
this technology can get complicated and
we have to make sure what we are doing
with it holds value we must also handle
it cautiously because ai is a direct
reflection of us people should lead and
not follow so here's the question should
we be afraid of ai
we all know that ai is a transformative
technology that we have ever seen in the
history of humankind
on the other hand we should be scared of
this so-called transformative power
it has the potential to be
transformative both for good reasons as
well as for the wrong however fear of
the unknown has always been the case
with technology
fears that ai will develop awareness and
overthrow humanity are grounded in
misconceptions of what ai is
ai is defined by the algorithms that
dictate its behavior and operate under
definite limitations
people are afraid of what happens when
ai reaches its consciousness what if an
ai machine starts to have human feelings
and emotions
well there has been no progress in
research in these areas
also we don't think that is anywhere in
our near future
pretty much any type of machine can be
used for either good or bad reasons
we as developers and researchers should
know where to stop or pause in a depth
jog peter herr says
imagine you're driving up a mountain and
it's raining very heavily as you climb
into the mountains the rain is turning
into snow and pretty soon that snow is a
white out
you cannot see the taillights of the car
in front of you you start skidding you
see some vehicle was coming to crash
into you all this wouldn't have happened
if you paused your journey as the rain
was getting worse
this is to tell you how something small
and seemingly mundane can quickly grow
into something hazardous
consider yourself driving the rain with
ai right now
that rain will turn into snow soon and
that snow could quickly become a
dangerous blizzard so we need to pause
check the conditions put in place safety
standards and ask ourselves how far we
want to go
only the healthy skepticism of these
systems is going to help keep people in
the loop
spot checking what the ai algorithms are
doing keeping people in the loop will
probably solve some of our most
significant challenges
at the moment ai isn't dangerous in
itself unless you're living in the
realms of the movies as mentioned
earlier however evolved these ar
machines are they still lack human
empathy and consciousness
so instead of running away from this
technology we should understand this
revolutionary technology and make sure
it is used in the right way to make our
lives better
and on that note if you want to master
ai and machine learning you can check
out simply learn's post graduate program
in ai and machine learning in
partnership with purdue university hello
my name is richard kirschner and today
we're going to go over what is
artificial intelligence one example of
today's artificial intelligence is a
smart home so welcome to my smart home
smart homes are run by artificial
intelligence let's have a look at some
of the key features of a smart house
home appliances are voice controlled
sensors adjust lights and air coolers
according to the climate security
systems can detect movement outside and
worn at the residence all the appliances
are interconnected to each other and can
detect vehicles in the driveway and let
the owner know home appliances can be
controlled remotely through the phone
now this is just one example in today's
world so what's in it for you today
today we're going to cover a brief
history of artificial intelligence what
is artificial intelligence types of
artificial intelligence applications of
artificial intelligence and just a quick
glimpse of the future of artificial
intelligence let us start with a brief
history of artificial intelligence let's
start with john mccarthy he was the
first one to coin the word artificial
intelligence and in 1956 had the first
artificial intelligence conference let's
jump forward to 1969 was shaky shaky was
the first general purpose mobile robot
built and although by today's standard
he was very simple he did mark a
milestone in that we were now processing
data differently he was now able to do
things with a purpose versus just a list
of instructions albeit the list included
things like turning on and off lights
and pushing boxes around the room we're
going to move forward to
1997. in 1997 the supercomputer deep
blue was designed which defeated the
world's chess champion in a game this is
the first time when we're actually
seeing the computer using logic to beat
a human doing some kind of logical uh in
this case a game so it was a huge
milestone by ibm to create this large
computer that was able to do that in a
timely fashion let's jump up to 2002
when we have our first commercially
successful robotic vacuum cleaner
nowadays you can go down to the target
and buy one but back in 2002 that was
the first model that was put out and
finally 2005 to 2018 today in the last
more than a decade we have speech
recognition rpa dancing robots smart
homes and many more to come what i want
you to notice about this brief history
of artificial intelligence is the
compression of time in 1956 it was just
an idea and more than 10 years later we
have our shaky the first one who's able
to flip light switches and then we go
all the way to 97 where we have deep
blue and there's a lot of little steps
between 69 and 97 but it's actually able
to take on a human in chess and beat
them regularly now they did have a lot
of ties so don't think that it won every
game and then we go only four years
later we have our first commercially
successful robotic vacuum cleaner and as
we go from 2005 to 2018 we go from
simple speech recognition to very
complicated able to really register with
your google voice and your siri we have
our rpa we have dancing robot smart
homes and many more things are just
coming out almost monthly in the world
of artificial intelligence so what is
artificial intelligence ai is a form of
computer science used to create
intelligent machines that can recognize
human speech objects can learn plan and
solve problems like humans and i'd like
you to focus just on that last one can
solve problems like humans as we saw
earlier we compare the computer that can
beat the chess champion it's able to the
one before that able to turn on and off
lights in the house so right now our
concept of artificial intelligence is
based primarily on our understanding of
how it interacts with humans and how we
can compare it to humans so speech
recognition that's a big one today
object detection solve problems and
learn from the given data and plan an
approach for future tasks to be done
these are all very human things that we
do to plan and solve for the future
types of artificial intelligence hi
heard you want to know the types of ai
you can imagine a little robot taking us
on a tour the first type is purely
reactive the second type is limited
memory the third type theory of mind
which is still in the process of being
invented and definitely the question of
self-awareness being the fourth which is
still not invented yet or is it let's
look at these a little closer here we
have our purely reactive he does not
have any past memory or data to work
with he takes actions reacts based on
what he sees okay it's not that tough
observes every move you can see we have
a nice game of chess going on here and
wins takes the best possible decision
purely reactive machines specialize in
one field of work only in this case we
see a chess game where they figure out
the best moves calculating all the
different moves maybe it's calculating
the next one in a row in a linear
regression model so you can figure out
the best marketing but they're very
reactionary they don't have a lot of
data they just have what's in front of
them to look at next let's look at
limited memory let's try to understand
the limited memory setup these machines
use previous data and keep adding it to
their memory so just me a good
restaurant so maybe we're looking to go
out for dinner tonight and we're not
sure what we want to eat hmm i see you
have been to kfc quite a lot in the past
week there is a kfc nearby so it goes
through the previous location data and
where they ate prior and says hmm this
is probably a good suggestion for you
tonight thanks it has enough memory or
experience to make proper decisions but
the memory is very limited this isn't
trying to guess what a new location
would be or anything like that it just
takes what it has in front of it and
goes okay this is where you've been this
is what you liked you gave it two thumbs
up one thumb down whatever and then it
goes from these suggestions this is
where i think you should go theory of
mind this kind of ai has a capacity to
understand thoughts and emotions and
interact socially a machine based on
this type is yet to be built that human
looks lonely hey human you want to be my
friend huh okay theory of mind is a
thing of the future certainly we see a
lot of the industry poking a little bit
at this as it tries to guess how you
feel about things but most of that is
still based on previous data you know
yes no two thumbs up one thumb down
theory in mind would take it one step
further in understanding the emotions
behind it and finally as we get deep
into the sci-fi futuristic we have
self-aware self-aware machines are
future generation of machines they will
be super intelligent sentient sentient
and conscious like the terminator the
good guy in the thing or ultron or
vision from avengers for right now these
are mostly movie characters or cartoon
characters but we certainly are getting
closer to seeing them in the real world
hopefully they'll be of the type of the
good guys and not the bad guys we see
also in the artificial intelligence
science adapt and respond to threats
virtual assistants siri cortana alexa
and google now use voice recognition to
follow the user's commands these are all
wonderful examples of current ais that
are in the commercial and business world
and these ones in particular have
matured over the last half a decade for
instance very few large banks in today's
world would not use banking for fraud
detection or for deciding whether it's a
good person to give a loan to or not
based on their credit scores and where
they're from and their income same thing
with cyber security detecting anomalies
or online customer support could you
imagine in say hp who has over 70 000
help pages across 17 different languages
now they have to figure out how to do
online customer support to cover new
problems that come up and track them so
they can build new pages if they had one
person doing that that would take them a
year just to do what they need to have
posted yesterday and of course our
virtual assistants i don't know about
you but i love mine kinda like having a
private secretary without having a
private secretary future of artificial
intelligence if we see where it's at now
commercially and business-wise then
where is it going of course the
imagination is a limit on this one but
you can already see the development in
the world today for automated
transportation they'll become a common
thing maybe even early as 2020 when they
have the final release from the leaders
in the industry humans will be able to
augment themselves with robots certainly
the idea of having the robot bring me my
coffee is lovely or when i'm doing
reports or something else on the
computer it does part of that work for
me so that i'm freed up to think about
other things there will be more numbers
of smart cities as vehicles phones home
appliances will be run by ai home robots
will help elderly people with the
day-to-day work japan already has a very
in-depth program where they begin to
integrate robots helping elderly even
some of the simple things like getting
that box of cereal off the top shelf or
monitoring if they fall and need to
contact the doctor an emergency to show
up robots will take over hazardous jobs
like bomb defusing welding etc for the
future of artificial intelligence you
can see here a number of robotic uses
that are already in development people
are already working on these and trying
to bring them to us in a commercial
business fashion your own imagination
can take this to the next level or a
simple google search will show you some
of the stuff that's out there now in
addition to these hello and welcome to
machine learning tutorial part one this
is part one of a machine learning series
put on by simplylearn what's in it for
you today well we'll start off with a
brief explanation of why machine
learning and what is machine learning
and then we'll get into a few of the
types of machine learning machine
learning algorithms linear regression
decision trees support vector machine
and finally we'll do a use case where
we're going to classify whether recipe
is of a cupcake or a muffin using the
svm or the support vector machine sounds
like a delicious way to explore machine
learning so why machine learning why do
we even care about having these
computers come up and be able to do all
these new things for us well because
machines can now drive your car for you
still very in the infant stage but it's
just exploding as we see with google's
waymo and then uber had their program
which unfortunately crashed they know
that this is huge this is going to be
the huge industry to change our whole
transportation infrastructure machine
learning is now used to detect over 50
eye diseases do you know how amazing
that is to have a computer that double
checks for the doctor for things they
might miss that's just huge in the
health industry pretty soon they
actually do already have that within
some areas where maybe not for eyes but
for other diseases where they're using
the camera on your phone to help
pre-diagnose before you go and see the
doctor and because the machine can now
unlock your phone with your face i mean
that's just cool having it being able to
identify your face or your voice and be
able to turn stuff on and off for you
depending on where you're at and what
you need talking about an ultimate
automation or world we live in and as we
dig in deeper we have a nice example of
facebook as you can see here they have
the facebook post with halloween comment
yes if you want it order here nobody
likes spam post on facebook that annoy
them into interacting with likes shares
comments and other actions i remember
the original ones were all if you don't
click on here you will have bad luck or
some kind of fear factor well this is a
huge thing in a social media when people
are getting spammed and so this tactic
known as engagement bait takes advantage
of facebook's news feed algorithm by
choosing engagement in order to get the
greater reach to eliminate engagement
bait the company reviewed and
categorized hundreds of thousands of
posts to train a machine learning model
that detects different types of
engagement bait so in this case we have
we're using facebook but this is of
course across all the different social
media they have different tools for
building and the facebook scroll gif
will be replaced kind of like a virus
coming in there and notices that there's
a certain setup with facebook and it's
able to replace it and they have like
vote baiting react baiting share baiting
they have all these different these are
kind of general titles but there
certainly are a lot of way of baiting
you to go in there and click on
something so they fed all this this data
was fed into the machine and then they
have the new post the new post comes up
that takes over part of the facebook
setup and that's what you're looking at
you're looking at this new post that's
replaced like a virus has replaced that
so what facebook do to eliminate this is
they start scanning for keywords and
phrases like this and checks the
click-through rate so it starts looking
for people who are clicking through it
without even looking at it or clicking
through it it's not something that
normally would be clicked through once
facebook has scanned for these keywords
and phrases it is now able to identify
the spam coming in and this makes your
life easier so you're not getting
spammed it's not like walking through an
airport and a lot of countries you have
like hundreds of people trying to sell
you timeshare come join us sign up for
this eliminates that annoyingness so now
you can just enjoy your facebook and
your cat pictures or maybe it's your
family pictures mine is family certainly
people like their cat pictures too
another good example is google's
deepmind project alphago a computer
program that plays a board game go has
defeated the world's number one go
player and i hope i say his name right
kiji the ultimate go challenge game of
three of three was on may 27 2017 so
it's just last year that this happened
and what makes this so important is that
you know go is just is a game so it's
not like you're driving a car or
something in our real world but they are
using games to learn how to get the
machine learning program to learn they
want it to learn how to learn and that
is a huge step a lot of this is still in
its infant stage as far as development
as we saw what happened with the as i
referred to earlier the uber cars they
lost their whole division because they
jumped ahead too fast so still an infant
stage but boy is this like the beginning
of just an amazing world that is
automated in ways we can't even imagine
what tomorrow's going to look like we've
looked at a lot of examples of machine
learning so let's see if we can give a
little bit more of a concrete definition
what is machine learning machine
learning is the science of making
computers learn and act like humans by
feeding data and information without
being explicitly programmed
we see here we have a nice little
diagram where we have our ordinary
system uh your computer nowadays you can
even run a lot of the stuff on a cell
phone because cell phones advance so
much and then with artificial
intelligence and machine learning it now
takes the data and it learns from what
happened before and then it predicts
what's going to come next and then
really the biggest part right now in
machine learning that's going on is it
improves on that how do we find a new
solution so we go from descriptive where
it's learning about stuff and
understanding how it fits together to
predicting what it's going to do to post
scripting coming up with a new solution
and when we're working on machine
learning there's a number of different
diagrams that people have posted for
what steps to go through a lot of it
might be very domain specific so if
you're working on
photo identification versus language
versus medical or physics some of these
are switched around a little bit or new
things are put in they're very specific
to the domain this is kind of a very
general diagram first you want to define
your objective very important to know
what it is you're wanting to predict
then you're going to be collecting the
data so once you've defined an objective
you need to collect the data that
matches
you spend a lot of time in data science
collecting data and the next step
preparing the data you got to make sure
that your data is clean going in there's
the old saying bad data in bad answer
out or bad data out and then once you've
gone through and we've cleaned all this
stuff coming in then you're going to
select the algorithm which algorithm are
you going to use you're going to train
that algorithm in this case i think
we're going to be working with svm the
support vector machine then you have to
test the model does this model work is
this a valid model for what we're doing
and then once you've tested it you want
to run your prediction you want to run
your prediction or your choice or
whatever output it's going to come up
with and then once everything is set and
you've done lots of testing then you
want to go ahead and deploy the model
remember i said domain specific this is
very general as far as the scope of
doing something a lot of models you get
halfway through and you realize that
your data is missing something and you
have to go collect new data because
you've run a test in here someplace
along the line you're saying hey i'm not
really getting the answers i need so
there's a lot of things that are domain
specific that become part of this model
this is a very general model but it's a
very good model to start with and we do
have some basic divisions of what
machine learning does that's important
to know for instance do you want to
predict a category well if you're
categorizing thing that's classification
for instance whether the stock price
will increase or decrease so in other
words i'm looking for a yes no answer is
it going up or is it going down and in
that case we'd actually say is it going
up true if it's not going up it's false
meaning it's going down this way it's a
yes no zero one do you want to predict a
quantity that's regression so remember
we just did classification now we're
looking at regression these are the two
major divisions in what data is doing
for instance predicting the age of a
person based on the height weight health
and other factors so based on these
different factors you might guess how
old a person is
and then there are a lot of domain
specific things like do you want to
detect an anomaly that's anomaly
detection this is actually very popular
right now for instance you want to
detect money withdrawal anomalies you
want to know when someone's making a
withdrawal that might not be their own
account we've actually brought this up
because this is really big right now if
you're predicting the stock whether to
buy stock or not you want to be able to
know if what's going on in the stock
market is an anomaly use a different
prediction model because something else
is going on you got to pull out new
information in there or is this just the
norm i'm going to get my normal return
on my money invested so being able to
detect anomalies is very big in data
science these days
another question that comes up which is
on what we call untrained data is do you
want to discover structure in unexplored
data and that's called clustering for
instance finding groups of customers
with similar behavior given a large
database of customer data containing
their demographics and past buying
records and in this case we might notice
that anybody who's wearing certain set
of shoes go shopping at certain stores
or whatever it is they're going to make
certain purchases by having that
information it helps us to market or
group people together so that we can now
explore that group and find out what it
is we want to market to them if you're
in the marketing world and that might
also work in just about any arena you
might want to group people together
whether they're based on their different
areas and investments and financial
background whether you're going to give
them a loan or not before you even start
looking at whether they're a valid
customer for the bank you might want to
look at all these different areas and
group them together based on unknown
data so you're not you don't know what
the data is going to tell you but you
want to cluster people together that
come together
let's take a quick detour for
quiz time oh my favorite so we're going
to have a couple questions here under
quiz time and we'll be posting the
answers in this part two of this
tutorial so let's go ahead and take a
look at these quiz times questions and
hopefully you'll get them all right
it'll get you thinking about how to
process data and what's going on can you
tell what's happening in the following
cases of course you're sitting there
with your cup of coffee and you have
your checkbox and your pen trying to
figure out what's your next step in your
data science analysis
so the first one is grouping documents
into different categories based on the
topic and content of each document very
big these days
you know you have legal documents you
have maybe it's a sports group documents
maybe you're analyzing newspaper
postings
but certainly having that automated is a
huge thing in today's world
b identifying handwritten digits in
images correctly
so we want to know whether they're
writing an a or capital a b c
what are they writing out in their hand
digit their handwriting c behavior of a
website indicating that the site is not
working as designed
d predicting salary of an individual
based on his or her years of experience
hr hiring
set up there so stay tuned for part two
we'll go ahead and answer these
questions when we get to the part two of
this tutorial or you can just simply
write at the bottom and send a note to
simply learn and they'll follow up with
you on it
back to our regular content
now these last few bring us into the
next topic which is another way of
dividing our types of machine learning
and that is with supervised
unsupervised
and reinforcement learning supervised
learning is a method used to enable
machines to classify predict objects
problems or situations based on labeled
data fed to the machine and in here you
see we have a jungle of data with
circles triangles and squares and then
we label them we have what's a circle
what's a triangle what's a square we
have our model training and it trains it
so we know the answer very important
when you're doing supervised learning
you already know the answer to a lot of
your information coming in so you have a
huge group of data coming in and then
you have a new data coming in so we've
trained our model the model now knows
the difference between a circle a square
a triangle and now that we've trained it
we can send in in this case a square and
a circle goes in and it predicts that
the top one's a square and the next
one's a circle and you can see that this
is uh being able to predict whether
someone's going to default on a loan
because i was talking about banks
earlier supervised learning on stock
market whether you're going to make
money or not that's always important and
if you are looking to make a fortune in
the stock market keep in mind it is very
difficult to get all the data correct on
the stock market it is very it
fluctuates in ways you really hard to
predict so it's quite a roller coaster
ride if you're running machine learning
on the stock market you start realizing
you really have to dig for new data so
we have supervised learning and if you
have supervised we should need
unsupervised learning in unsupervised
learning machine learning model finds
the hidden pattern in an unlabeled data
so in this case instead of telling it
what the circle is and what a triangle
is and what a square is it goes in there
looks at them and says for whatever
reason it groups them together maybe
they'll group it by the number of
corners and it notices that a number of
them all have three corners a number of
them all have four corners and a number
of them all have no corners and it's
able to filter those through and group
them together we talked about that
earlier with looking at a group of
people who are out shopping we want to
group them together to find out what
they have in common and of course once
you understand what people have in
common maybe you have one of them who's
a customer at your store or you have
five of them our customer your store and
they have a lot in common with five
others who are not customers at your
store how do you market to those five
who aren't customers at your store yet
they fit the demographics of who's going
to shop there and you'd like them to
shop at your store not the one next door
of course this is a simplified version
you can see very easily the difference
between a triangle and a circle which
might not be so easy in marketing
reinforcement learning reinforcement
learning is an important type of machine
learning where an agent learns how to
behave in an environment by performing
actions and seeing the result we have
here where the in this case a baby it's
actually great that they used an infant
for this slide because the reinforcement
learning is very much in its infant
stages but it's also probably the
biggest machine learning demand out
there right now or in the future it's
going to be coming up over the next few
years is reinforcement learning and how
to make that work for us
and you can see here where we have our
action in the action on this one it goes
into the fire hopefully the baby didn't
it was just a little candle not a giant
fire pit like it looks like here when
the baby comes out and the new state is
the baby is sad and crying because he
got burned on the fire and then maybe
they take another action the baby's
called the agent because it's the one
taking the actions and in this case they
didn't go into the fire they went a
different direction and now the baby's
happy and laughing and playing
reinforcement learning is very easy to
understand because that's how as humans
that's one of the ways we learn we learn
whether it is you burn yourself on the
stove don't do that anymore don't touch
the stove in the big picture being able
to have a machine learning program or an
ai be able to do this is huge because
now we're starting to learn how to learn
that's a big jump in the world of
computer and machine learning and we're
going to go back and just kind of go
back over supervised versus unsupervised
learning understanding this is huge
because this is going to come up in any
project you're working on
we have in supervised learning we have
labeled data we have direct feedback so
someone's already gone in there and said
yes it's a triangle no that's not a
triangle and then you predict an outcome
so you have a nice prediction this is
this this new set of data is coming in
and we know what it's going to be and
then with unsupervised training it's not
labeled so we really don't know what it
is there's no feedback so we're not
telling it whether it's right or wrong
we're not telling it whether it's a
triangle or a square we're not telling
it to go left or right all we do is
we're finding hidden structure in the
data grouping the data together to find
out what connects to each other and then
you can use these together so imagine
you have an image and you're not sure
what you're looking for so you go in and
you have the unstructured data find all
these things that are connected together
and then somebody looks at those and
labels them now you can take that label
data and program something to predict
what's in the picture so you can see how
they go back and forth and you can start
connecting all these different tools
together to make a bigger picture there
are many interesting machine learning
algorithms let's have a look at a few of
them hopefully this gives you a little
flavor what's out there and these are
some of the most important ones that are
currently being used we'll take a look
at linear regression decision tree and
the support vector machine
let's start with a closer look at linear
regression
linear regression is perhaps one of the
most well-known and well-understood
algorithms in statistics and machine
learning linear regression is a linear
model for example a model that assumes a
linear relationship between the input
variables x and the single output
variable y
and you'll see this if you remember from
your algebra classes y equals mx plus c
imagine we are predicting distance
traveled y from speed x our linear
regression model representation for this
problem would be y equals m times x plus
c or
distance equals m times speed plus c
where m is the coefficient and c is the
y-intercept and we're going to look at
two different variations of this first
we're going to start with time is
constant and you can see we have a
bicyclist he's got a safety gear on
thank goodness
speed equals 10 meters per second and so
over a certain amount of time his
distance equals 36 kilometers we have a
second bicyclist who's going twice the
speed or 20 meters per second and you
can guess if he's going twice the speed
and time is a constant then he's going
to go twice the distance and that's easy
to compute 36 times 2 you get 72
kilometers and so if you had the
question of
how fast would somebody is going three
times that speed or 30 meters per second
is you can easily compute the distance
in our head we can do that without
needing a computer but we want to do
this for more complicated data so it's
kind of nice to compare the two but
let's just take a look at that and what
that looks like in a graph
so in a linear regression model we have
our distance to the speed and we have
our m equals the ve slope of the line
and we'll notice that the line has a
plus slope and as the speed increases
distance also increases hence the
variables have a positive relationship
and so your speed of the person which
equals y equals mx plus c distance
traveled in a fixed interval of time and
we could very easily compute either
following the line or just knowing it's
3 times 10 meters per second that this
is roughly 102 kilometers distance that
this third bicyclist has traveled one of
the key
definitions on here is positive
relationship so the slope of the line is
positive as distance increase so does
speed increase let's take a look at our
second example where we put distance is
a constant so we have speed equals 10
meters per second they have a certain
distance to go and it takes him 100
seconds to travel that distance and we
have our second bicyclist who's still
doing 20 meters per second since he's
going twice the speed we can guess that
he'll cover the distance in about half
the time 50 seconds and of course you
could probably guess on the third one
100 divided by 30 since he's going three
times the speed you can easily guess
that this is 33.333
seconds time we put that into a linear
regression model or graph if the
distance is assumed to be constant let's
see the relationship between speed and
time and as time goes up the amount of
speed to go that same distance goes down
so now your m equals a minus ve slope of
the line as the speed increases time
decreases hence the variable has a
negative relationship again there's our
definition positive relationship and
negative relationship dependent on the
slope of the line and with a simple
formula like this
and even a significant amount of data
let's see with the mathematical
implementation of linear regression and
we'll take this data so suppose we have
this data set where we have x y x equals
1 2 3 4 5 standard series and the y
value is 3 2 2 4 3. when we take that
and we go ahead and plot these points on
a graph you can see there's kind of a
nice scattering and you could probably
eyeball a line through the middle of it
but we're going to calculate that exact
line for linear regression and the first
thing we do is we come up here we have
the mean of x i and remember mean is
basically the average so we added five
plus four plus three plus two plus one
and divide by five and that simply comes
out as three and then we'll do the same
for y we'll go ahead and add up all
those numbers and divide by 5 and we end
up with the mean value of y of i equals
2.8 where the x i references it's an
average or means value and the y i also
equals a means value of y and when we
plot that you'll see that we can put in
the y equals 2.8 and the x equals 3 in
there on our graph we kind of give it a
little different color so you can sort
it out with the dashed lines on it and
it's important to note that when we do
the linear regression the linear
regression model should go through that
dot
now let's find our regression equation
to find the best fit line remember we go
ahead and take our y equals mx plus c so
we're looking for m and c so to find
this equation for our data we need to
find our slope of m and our coefficient
of c
and we have y equals mx plus c
where m equals the sum of x minus x
average times y minus y average or y
means and x means over the sum of x
minus x means squared that's how we get
the slope of the value of the line and
we can easily do that by creating some
columns here we have x y computers are
really good about iterating through data
and so we can easily compute this and
fill in a graph of data and in our graph
you can easily see that if we have our x
value of 1 and if you remember the x i
or the means value is 3 1 minus 3 equals
a negative 2 and 2 minus 3 equals a
negative 1 so on and so forth and we can
easily fill in the column of x minus x i
y minus y i and then from those we can
compute x minus x i squared and x minus
x i times y minus y i and you can guess
it that the next step is to go ahead and
sum the different columns for the
answers we need so we get a total of 10
for our x minus x i squared and a total
of 2 for x minus x i times y minus y i
and we plug those in we get 2 10 which
equals 0.2 so now we know the slope of
our line equals 0.2 so we can calculate
the value of c that'd be the next step
is we need to know where it crosses the
y-axis and if you remember i mentioned
earlier that the linear regression line
has to pass through
the means value the one that we showed
earlier we can just flip back up there
to that graph and you can see right here
there's our means value which is 3
x equals 3 and y equals 2.8 and since we
know that value we can simply plug that
into our formula y equals 0.2 x plus c
so we plug that in we get 2.8 equals 0.2
times 3 plus c and you can just solve
for c so now we know that our
coefficient equals 2.2 and once we have
all that we can go ahead and plot our
regression line y equals 0.2 times x
plus 2.2 and then from this equation we
can compute new values so let's predict
the values of y using x equals 1 2 3 4 5
and plot the points remember the 1 2
three four five was our original x
values so now we're going to see what y
thinks they are not what they actually
are and we plug those in we get y of
designated with y of p you can see that
x equals 1 equals 2.4 x equals 2 equals
2.6 and so on and so on so we have our y
predicted values of what we think it's
going to be when we plug those numbers
in and when we plot the predicted values
along with the axial values we can see
the difference and this is one of the
things that's very important with linear
aggression in any of these models is to
understand the error and so we can
calculate the error on all of our
different values and you can see over
here we plotted x and y and y predict
and we've drawn a little line so you can
sort of see what the arrow looks like
there between the different points so
our goal is to reduce this error we want
to minimize that error value on our
linear regression model minimizing the
distance there are lots of ways to
minimize the distance between the line
and the data points like sum of squared
errors sum of absolute errors root mean
square error etc we keep moving this
line through the data points to make
sure the best fit line has the least
square distance between the data points
and the regression line so to recap with
a very simple linear regression model we
first figure out the formula of our line
through the middle and then we slowly
adjust the line to minimize the error
keep in mind this is a very simple
formula the math gets even though the
math is very much the same it gets much
more complex as we add in different
dimensions so this is only two
dimensions y equals mx plus c but you
can take that out to x
z i j q all the different features in
there and they can plot a linear
regression model on all of those using
the different formulas to minimize the
error let's go ahead and take a look at
decision trees a very different way to
solve problems in the linear regression
model decision tree is a tree-shaped
algorithm used to determine a course of
action each branch of a tree represents
a possible decision occurrence or
reaction we have data which tells us if
it is a good day to play golf and if we
were to open this data up in a general
spreadsheet you can see we have the
outlook whether it's a rainy overcast
sunny temperature
hot mild cool humidity windy and did i
like to play golf that day yes or no so
we're taking a census and certainly i
wouldn't want a computer telling me when
i should go play golf or not but you can
imagine if you got up in the night
before you're trying to plan your day
and it comes up and says tomorrow would
be a good day for golf for you in the
morning and not a good day in the
afternoon or something like that this
becomes very beneficial and we see this
in a lot of applications coming out now
where it gives you suggestions and lets
you know what would be fit the match for
you for the next day or the next
purchase or the next whatever you know
next mail out in this case is tomorrow a
good day for playing golf based on the
weather coming in and so we come up and
let's determine if you should play golf
when the day is sunny and windy so we
found out the forecast tomorrow is going
to be sunny and windy and suppose we
draw our tree like this we're going to
have our humidity and then we have our
normal which is if it's if you have a
normal humidity you're going to go play
golf and if the humidity is really high
then we look at the outlook and if the
outlook is sunny overcast or rainy it's
going to change what you choose to do so
if you know that it's a very high
humidity and it's sunny you're probably
not going to play golf because you're
going to be out there miserable fighting
off the mosquitoes that are out joining
you to play golf with you maybe if it's
raining you probably don't want to play
in the rain but if it's slightly
overcast you get just the right
shadow that's a good day to play golf
and be outside out on the green now in
this example you can probably make your
own tree pretty easily because it's a
very simple set of data going in but the
question is how do you know what to
split where do you split your data what
if this is much more complicated data
where it's not something that you would
particularly understand like studying
cancer they take about 36 measurements
of the cancerous cells and then each one
of those measurements represents how
bulbous it is how extended it is how
sharp the edges are something that as a
human we would have no understanding of
so how do we decide how to split that
data up and is that the right decision
tree but so it's a question is going to
come up is this the right decision tree
for that we should calculate entropy and
information gain two important
vocabulary words there are the entropy
and the information gain entropy entropy
is a measure of randomness or impurity
in the data set entropy should be low so
we want the chaos to be as low as
possible we don't want to look at it and
be confused by the images or what's
going on there with mixed data and the
information gain it is a measure of
decrease in entropy after the data set
is split also known as entropy reduction
information gain should be high so we
want our information that we get out of
the split to be as high as possible
let's take a look at entropy from the
mathematical side in this case we're
going to denote entropy as i of p of n n
where p is the probability that you're
going to play a game of golf and n is
the probability where you're not going
to play the game of golf now you don't
really have to memorize these formulas
there's a few of them out there
depending on what you're working with
but it's important to note that this is
where this formula is coming from so
when you see it you're not lost when
you're running your programming unless
you're building your own decision tree
code in the back and we simply have a
log squared of p over p plus n minus n
over p plus n times the log squared of n
of p plus n but let's break that down
and see what actually looks like when
we're computing that from the computer
script side entropy of a target class of
the data set is the whole entropy so we
have entropy play golf and we look at
this if we go back to the data you can
simply count how many yeses and no in
our complete data set for playing golf
days in our complete set we find we have
five days we did play golf and nine days
we did not play golf and so our i equals
if you add those together 9 plus 5 is
14. and so our i equals 5 over 14 and 9
over 14. that's our p and n values that
we plug into that formula and you can go
to 5 over 14 equals 0.36 9 over 14
equals 0.64 and when you do the whole
equation you get the minus 0.36 log root
squared of 0.36 minus 0.64 log squared
root of 0.64 and we get a set value we
get
0.94
so we now have a full entropy value for
the whole set of data that we're working
with and we want to make that entropy go
down and just like we calculated the
entropy out for the whole set we can
also calculate entropy for playing golf
and the outlook is it going to be
overcast or rainy or sunny and so we
look at the entropy we have p of sunny
times e of 3 of 2 and that just comes
out how many sunny days yes and how many
sunny days no
over the total which is five don't
forget to put the we'll divide that five
out later on equals p overcast equals
four comma zero plus rainy equals two
comma three and then when you do the
whole setup we have 5 over 14 remember i
said there was a total of 5 5 over 14
times the i of 3 of 2 plus 4 over 14
times the 4 comma 0 and 514 over i of 2
3. and so we can now compute the entropy
of just the part it has to do with the
forecast and we get 0.693
similarly we can calculate the entropy
of other predictors like temperature
humidity and wind and so we look at the
gain outlook how much are we going to
gain from this entropy play golf minus
entropy play golf outlook and we can
take the original 0.94 for the whole set
minus the entropy of just the
rainy day and temperature and we end up
with a gain of 0.247
so this is our information gain remember
we define entropy and we define an
information gain the higher the
information gain the lower the entropy
the better the information gain of the
other three attributes can be calculated
in the same way so we have our gain for
temperature equals
0.029 we have our gain for humidity
equals 0.152 and our gain for a windy
day equals 0.048 and if you do a quick
comparison you'll see the 0.247
is the greatest gain of information so
that's the split we want
now let's build the decision tree so we
have the outlook is it going to be sunny
overcast or rainy that's our first split
because that gives us the most
information gain and we can continue to
go down the tree using the different
information gains with the largest
information we can continue down the
nodes of the tree where we choose the
attribute with the largest information
gain as the root node and then continue
to split each sub node with the largest
information gain that we can compute and
although it's a little bit of a tongue
twister to say all that you can see
that's a very easy to view visual model
we have our outlook we split it three
different directions if the outlook is
overcast we're going to play and then we
can split those further down if we want
so if the outlook is sunny but then it's
also windy if it's windy we're not going
to play if it's not windy we'll play so
we can easily build a nice decision tree
to guess what we would like to do
tomorrow and give us a nice
recommendation for the day so we want to
know if it's a good day to play golf
when it's sunny and windy remember the
original question that came out
tomorrow's weather report is sunny and
windy you can see by going down the tree
we go outlook sunny outlook windy we're
not going to play golf tomorrow so our
little smart watch pops up and says i'm
sorry tomorrow's not a good day for golf
it's going to be sunny and windy and if
you're a huge golf fan you might go
it's not a good day to play golf we can
go in and watch a golf game at home so
we'll sit in front of the tv instead of
being out playing golf in the wind
multiple linear regression let's take a
brief look at what happens when you have
multiple inputs so in multiple linear
regression we have uh well we'll start
with the simple linear regression where
we had y equals m plus x plus c and
we're trying to find the value of y now
with multiple linear regression we have
multiple variables coming in so instead
of having just x we have x1 x2 x3 and
instead of having just one slope each
variable has its own slope attached to
it as you can see here we have m1 m2 m3
and we still just have the single
coefficient so when you're dealing with
multiple linear regression you basically
take your single linear regression and
you spread it out so you have y equals
m1 times x1 plus m2 times x2
so on all the way to m to the nth x to
the nth and then you add your
coefficient on there implementation of
linear regression now we get into my
favorite part let's understand how
multiple linear regression works by
implementing it in python if you
remember before we were looking at a
company and just based on its r d trying
to figure out its profit we're going to
start looking at the expenditure of the
company we're going to go back to that
we're going to predict his profit but
instead of predicting it just on the r d
we're going to look at other factors
like administration costs marketing
costs and so on and from there we're
going to see if we can figure out what
the profit of that company is going to
be to start our coding we're going to
begin by importing some basic libraries
and we're going to be looking through
the data before we do any kind of linear
regression we're going to take a look at
the data to see what we're playing with
then we'll go ahead and format the data
to the format we need to be able to run
it in the linear regression model and
then from there we'll go ahead and solve
it and just see how valid our solution
is so let's start with importing the
basic libraries now i'm going to be
doing this in anaconda jupiter notebook
a very popular ide i enjoy it's such a
visual to look at and so easy to use um
just any id for python will work just
fine for this so break out your favorite
python ide so here we are in our jupyter
notebook let me go ahead and paste our
first piece of code in there and let's
walk through what libraries we're
importing first we're going to import
numpy as np and then i want you to skip
one line and look at import pandas as pd
these are very common tools that you
need with most of your linear regression
the numpy which stands for number python
is usually denoted as np and you have to
almost have that for your sk learn
toolbox you always import that right off
the beginning pandas although you don't
have to have it for your sklearn
libraries it does such a wonderful job
of importing data setting it up into a
data frame so we can manipulate it
rather easily and it has a lot of tools
also in addition to that so we usually
like to use the pandas when we can and
i'll show you what that looks like the
other three lines are for us to get a
visual of this data and take a look at
it so we're going to import matplot
matplotlibrary.pipelot as plt and then
seaborn as sns seaborn works with the
matplot library so you have to always
import matplot library and then seaborn
sits on top of it and we'll take a look
at what that looks like you could use
any of your own plotting libraries you
want there's all kinds of ways to look
at the data these are just very common
ones and the seaborne is so easy to use
it just looks beautiful it's a nice
representation that you can actually
take and show somebody and the final
line is the amber scion map plot library
inline that is only because i'm doing an
inline ide my interface in the anaconda
jupiter notebook requires i put that in
there or you're not going to see the
graph when it comes up let's go ahead
and run this it's not going to be that
interesting so we're just setting up
variables in fact it's not going to do
anything that we can see but it is
importing these different libraries and
setup the next step is load the data set
and extract independent and dependent
variables now here in the slide you'll
see companies equals pd.read csv and it
has a long line there with the file at
the end 1000 companies dot csv you're
going to have to change this to fit
whatever setup you have and the file
itself you can request just go down to
the commentary below this video and put
a note in there and simply learn we'll
try to get in contact with you and
supply you with that file so you can try
this coding yourself so we're going to
add this code in here and we're going to
see that i have companies equals
pd.reader underscore csv and i've
changed this path to match my computer c
colon slash simply learn slash 1000
underscore companies dot csv and then
below there we're going to set the x
equals to companies under the i location
and because this is companies as a pd
data set i can use this nice notation
that says take every row that's what the
colon the first colon is comma except
for the last column that's what the
second part is where we have a colon
minus one and we want the values set
into there so x is no longer a data set
a pandas data set but we can easily
extract the data from our pandas data
set with this notation and then y we're
going to set equal to the last row well
the question is going to be what are we
actually looking at so let's go ahead
and take a look at that and we're going
to look at the companies dot head which
lists the first five rows of data and
i'll open up the file in just a second
so you can see where that's coming from
but let's look at the data in here as
far as the way the panda sees it when i
hit run you'll see it breaks it out into
a nice setup this is what panda is one
of the things pandas is really good
about is it looks just like an excel
spreadsheet you have your rows and
remember when we're programming we
always start with zero we don't start
with one so it shows the first five rows
zero one two three four and then it
shows your different columns r d spend
administration marketing spend state
profit it even notes that the top are
column names it was never told that but
pandas is able to recognize a lot of
things that they're not the same as the
data rows why don't we go ahead and open
this file up in a csv so you can
actually see the raw data so here i've
opened it up as a text editor and you
can see at the top we have rnd spend
comma administration comma marketing
spin comma state comma profit carriage
return i don't know about you but i go
crazy trying to read files like this
that's why we use the pandas you could
also open this up in an excel and it
would separate it since it is a comma
separated variable file but we don't
want to look at this one we want to look
at something we can read rather easily
so let's flip back and take a look at
that top part the first five row now as
nice as this format is where i can see
the data to me it doesn't mean a whole
lot maybe you're an expert in business
and investments and you understand what
uh 165 349.20
compared to the administration cost of a
hundred and thirty six thousand eight
hundred ninety seven dollars and eighty
cents so on so on it helps to create the
profit of 192 261 and 83 cents that
makes no sense to me whatsoever no pun
intended so let's flip back here and
take a look at our next set of code
where we're going to graph it so we can
get a better understanding of our data
and what it means so at this point we're
going to use a single line of code to
get a lot of information so we can see
where we're going with this let's go
ahead and paste that into our
notebook and see what we got going and
so we have the visualization and again
we're using sns which is pandas as you
can see we imported the map plot library
dot pi plot as plt which then the
seaborn uses and we imported the seaborn
as sns and then that final line of code
helps us show this in our inline coding
without this it wouldn't display and you
could display it to a file and other
means and that's the matplot library in
line with the amber sign at the
beginning so here we come down to the
single line of code seaborn is great
because it actually recognizes the panda
data frame so i can just take the
companies dot core for coordinates and i
can put that right into the seabourn and
when we run this we get this beautiful
plot and let's just take a look at what
this plot means if you look at this plot
on mine the colors are probably a little
bit more purplish and blue than the
original one we have the columns and the
rows we have r and d spending we have
administration we have marketing
spending and profit and if you cross
index any two of these since we're
interested in profit if you cross index
profit with profit it's going to show up
if you look at the scale on the right
way up in the dark why because those are
the same data they have an exact
correspondence so r d spending is going
to be the same as r d spending and the
same thing with administration costs
right down the middle you get this dark
row or dark diagonal row that shows that
this is the highest corresponding data
that's exactly the same and as it
becomes lighter there's less connections
between the data so we can see with
profit obviously profit is the same as
profit and next it has a very high
correlation with r d spending which we
looked at earlier and it has a slightly
less connection to marketing spending
and even less to how much money we put
into the administration so now that we
have a nice look at the data let's go
ahead and dig in and create some actual
useful linear regression models so that
we can predict values and have a better
profit now that we've taken a look at
the visualization of this data we're
going to move on to the next step
instead of just having a pretty picture
we need to generate some hard data some
hard values so let's see what that looks
like we're going to set up our linear
regression model in two steps the first
one is we need to prepare some of our
data so it fits correctly and let's go
ahead and paste this code into our
jupiter notebook and what we're bringing
in is we're going to bring in the
sklearn pre-processing where we're going
to import the label encoder and the one
hot encoder to use the label encoder
we're going to create a variable called
label encoder and set it equal to
capital l label capital e encoder this
creates a class that we can reuse for
transferring the labels back and forth
now about now you should ask what labels
are we talking about let's go take a
look at the data we processed before
and see what i'm talking about here if
you remember when we did the companies
dot head and we printed the top five
rows of data we have our columns going
across we have column zero which is r
and d spending column one which is
administration column two which is
marketing spending and column three is
state
and you'll see under state we have new
york california florida now to do a
linear regression model it doesn't know
how to process new york it knows how to
process a number so the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to
change that new york california and
florida and we're going to change those
to numbers that's what this line of code
does here x equals and then it has the
colon comma 3 in brackets the first part
the colon comma means that we're going
to look at all the different rows so
we're going to keep them all together
but the only row we're going to edit is
the third row and in there we're going
to take the label coder and we're going
to fit and transform the x also the
third row so we're going to take that
third row we're going to set it equal to
a transformation and that transformation
basically tells it that instead of
having a
new york it has a zero or a one or a two
and then finally we need to do a one hot
encoder which equals one hot inc or
categorical features equals three and
then we take the x and we go ahead and
do that equal to one hot encoder fit
transform x to array this final
transformation preps our data force so
it's completely set the way we need it
is just a row of numbers even though
it's not in here let's go ahead and
print x and just take a look what this
data is doing you'll see you have an
array of arrays and then each array is a
row of numbers and if i go ahead and
just do row 0 you'll see i have a nice
organized row of numbers that the
computer now understands we'll go ahead
and take this out there because it
doesn't mean a whole lot to us it's just
a row of numbers
next on setting up our data we have
avoiding dummy variable trap this is
very important why because the computer
has automatically transformed our header
into the setup and it's automatically
transferred all these different
variables so when we did the encoder the
encoder created two columns and what we
need to do is just have the one because
it has both the variable and the name
that's what this piece of code does here
let's go ahead and paste this in here
and we have x equals x colon comma one
colon all this is doing is removing that
one extra column we put in there when we
did our one hot encoder and our label
encoding let's go ahead and run that and
now we get to create our linear
regression model and let's see what that
looks like here and we're going to do
that in two steps the first step is
going to be in splitting the data
now whenever we create a predictive
model of data we always want to split it
up so we have a training set and we have
a testing set that's very important
otherwise we'd be very unethical without
testing it to see how good our fit is
and then we'll go ahead and create our
multiple linear regression model and
train it and set it up let's go ahead
and paste this next piece of code in
here and i'll go ahead and shrink it
down a size or two so it all fits on one
line so from the sklearn module
selection we're going to import train
test split and you'll see that we've
created four completely different
variables we have capital x train
capital x test
smaller case y train smaller case y test
that is the standard way that they
usually reference these when we're doing
different models you usually see that a
capital x and you see the train and the
test and the lower case y what this is
is x is our data going in that's our r
and d span our administration our
marketing and then y which we're
training is the answer that's the profit
because we want to know the profit of an
unknown entity that's what we're going
to shoot for in this tutorial the next
part train test split we take x and we
take y we've already created those x has
the columns with the data in it and y
has a column with profit in it and then
we're going gonna set the test size
equals point two that basically means
twenty percent
so twenty percent of the rows are going
to be tested we're gonna put them off to
the side so since we're using a thousand
lines of data that means that 200 of
those lines we're going to hold off to
the side to test for later and then the
random state equals 0. we're going to
randomize which ones it picks to hold
off to the side we'll go ahead and run
this it's not overly exciting so setting
up our variables but the next step is
the next step we actually create our
linear regression model now that we got
to the linear regression model we get
that next piece of the puzzle let's go
ahead and put that code in there and
walk through it so here we go we're
going to paste it in there and let's go
ahead and since this is a shorter line
of code let's zoom up there so we can
get a good look and we have from the
sklearn the linear underscore model
we're going to import linear regression
now i don't know if you recall from
earlier when we were doing all the math
let's go ahead and flip back there and
take a look at that do you remember this
where we had this long formula on the
bottom and we were doing all this
summarization and then we also looked at
uh setting it up with the different
lines and then we also looked all the
way down to multiple linear regression
where we're adding all those formulas
together all of that is wrapped up in
this one section so what's going on here
is i'm going to create a variable called
regressor and the regressor equals the
linear regression that's a linear
regression model that has all that math
built in so we don't have to have it all
memorized or have to compute it
individually and then we do the
regressor dot fit in this case we do x
train and y train because we're using
the training data x being the data in
and y being profit what we're looking at
and this does all that math for us so
within one click and one line we've
created the whole linear regression
model and we fit the data to the linear
regression model and you can see that
when i run the regressor it gives an
output linear regression it says copy x
equals true fit intercept equals true in
jobs equal one normalize equals false
it's just giving you some general
information on what's going on with that
regressor model now that we've created
our linear regression model let's go
ahead and use it and if you remember we
kept a bunch of data aside so we're
going to do a y predict variable and
we're going to put in the x test and
let's see what that looks like scroll up
a little bit paste that in here
predicting the test set results so here
we have y predict equals regressor dot
predict x test going in and this gives
us y predict now because i'm in jupiter
inline i can just put the variable up
there and when i hit the run button
it'll print that array out i could have
just as easily done print why predict so
if you're in a different ide that's not
an inline setup like the jupiter
notebook you can do it this way print y
predict and you'll see that for the 200
different test variables we kept off to
the side it's going to produce 200
answers this is what it says the profit
are for those 200 predictions but let's
don't stop there let's keep going and
take a couple look we're going to take
just a short detail here and calculating
the coefficients and the intercepts this
gives us a quick flash at what's going
on behind the line we're going to take a
short detour here and we're going to be
calculating the coefficient and
intercepts so you can see what those
look like what's really nice about our
regressor we created is it already has a
coefficients for us we can simply just
print regressor dot coefficient
underscore when i run this you'll see
our coefficients here and if we can do
the regressor coefficient we can also do
the regressor intercept and let's run
that and take a look at that this all
came from the multiple regression model
and we'll flip over so you can remember
where this is going into where it's
coming from you can see the formula down
here where y equals m1 times x1 plus m2
times x2 and so on and so on plus c the
coefficient so these variables fit right
into this formula y equals slope one
times column one variable plus slope two
times column two variable all the way to
the m into the n and x to the n plus c
the coefficient or in this case you have
minus 8.89 to the power of 2 etc etc
times the first column and the second
column and the third column and then our
intercept is the minus
zero nine 103009 boy it gets kind of
complicated when you look at it this is
why we don't do this by hand anymore
this is why we have the computer to make
these calculations easy to understand
and calculate now i told you that was a
short detour and we're coming towards
the end of our script as you remember
from the beginning i said if we're going
to divide this information we have to
make sure it's a valid model that this
model works and understand how good it
works so calculating the r squared value
that's what we're going to use to
predict how good our prediction is and
let's take a look what that looks like
in code and so we're going to use this
from
sklearn.metrics we're going to import r2
score that's the r squared value we're
looking at the error so in the r2 score
we take our y test versus our y predict
y test is the actual values we're
testing that was the one that was given
to us that we know are true the y
predict of those 200 values is what we
think it was true and when we go ahead
and run this
we see we get a 0.9352
that's the r2 score now it's not exactly
a straight percentage so it's not saying
it's 93 correct but you do want that in
the upper 90s oh and higher shows that
this is a very valid prediction based on
the r2 score and if r squared value of
0.91 or 9 2 as we got on our model
remember it does have a random
generation involved this proves the
model is a good model which means
success yay we successfully trained our
model with certain predictors and
estimated the profit of the companies
using linear regression use case loan
repayment prediction let's get into my
favorite part and open up some python
and see what the programming code in the
scripting looks like in here we're going
to want to do a prediction and we start
with this individual here who's
requesting to find out how good his
customers are going to be whether
they're going to be pay their loan or
not for his bank and from that we want
to generate a problem statement to
predict if a customer will repay loan
amount or not and then we're going to be
using the decision tree algorithm in
python let's see what that looks like
and let's dive into the code in our
first few steps of implementation we're
going to start by importing the
necessary packages that we need from
python and we're going to load up our
data and take a look at what the data
looks like so the first thing i need is
i need something to edit my python and
run it in so let's flip on over and here
i'm using the anaconda
jupiter notebook now you can use any
python ide you like to run it in but i
find the jupyter notebook's really nice
for doing things on the fly and let's go
ahead and just paste that code in the
beginning and before we start let's talk
a little bit about what we're bringing
in and then we're going to do a couple
things in here we have to make a couple
changes as we go through this first part
of the import the first thing we bring
in is numpy as np that's very standard
when we're dealing with mathematics
especially with very complicated machine
learning tools you almost always see the
numpy come in for your num your number
it's called number python it has your
mathematics in there in this case we
actually could take it out but generally
you'll need it for most of your
different things you work with and then
we're going to use pandas as pd that's
also a standard the pandas is a data
frame setup and you can liken this to
taking your basic data and storing it in
a way that looks like an excel
spreadsheet so as we come back to this
when you see np or pd those are very
standard uses you'll know that that's
the pandas and i'll show you a little
bit more we explore the data in just a
minute then we're going to need to split
the data so i'm going to bring in our
train test and split and this is coming
from the
learn package cross validation in just a
minute we're going to change that and
we'll go over that too and then there's
also the sk.tree import decision tree
classifier that's the actual tool we're
using remember i told you don't be
afraid of the mathematics it's going to
be done for you well the decision tree
classifier has all that mathematics in
there for you so you don't have to
figure it back out again and then we
have sklearn.metrics
for accuracy score we need to score our
setup that's the whole reason we're
splitting it between the training and
testing data and finally we still need
the sklearn import tree and that's just
the basic tree function is needed for
the decision tree classifier and finally
we're going to load our data down here
and i'm going to run this and we're
going to get two things on here one
we're going to get an error and two
we're going to get a warning let's see
what that looks like so the first thing
we had is we have an error why is this
error here well it's looking at this it
says i need to read a file and when this
was written
the person who wrote it
this is their path where they stored the
file
so let's go ahead and fix that
and i'm going to put in here my file
path i'm just going to call it full file
name and you'll see it's on my c drive
and this is very lengthy setup on here
where i stored the data2.csv file
don't worry too much about the full path
because on your computer will be
different
the data.2 csv file was generated by
simplylearn
if you want a copy of that you can
comment down below and request it here
in the youtube
and then if i'm going to give it a name
full file name
i'm going to go ahead and change it here
to full
file name so let's go ahead and run it
now and see what happens
and we get a warning
when you're coding
understanding these different warnings
and these different errors that come up
is probably the hardest lesson to learn
so let's just go ahead and take a look
at this and use this as a opportunity to
understand what's going on here
if you read the warning it says the
cross validation is depreciated so it's
a warning on it's being removed
and it's going to be moved in favor of
the model selection
so if we go up here we have sklearn dot
cross validation and if you research
this and go to the sklearn site you'll
find out that you can actually just swap
it right in there with
model selection
and so when i come in here and i run it
again
that removes a warning
what they've done is they've had two
different developers develop it in two
different branches
and then they decided to keep one of
those and eventually get rid of the
other one that's all that is and very
easy and quick to fix
before we go any further i went ahead
and opened up the data
from this file remember the the data
file we just loaded on here the data
underscore 2.csv
let's talk a little bit more about that
and see what that looks like both as a
text file because it's a comma separated
variable file and in a spreadsheet
this is what it looks like as a basic
text file you can see at the top they've
created a header and it's got one two
three four five columns and each column
has data in it and let me flip this over
because we're also going to look at this
uh in an actual spreadsheet so you can
see what that looks like and here i've
opened it up in the open office calc
which is pretty much the same as excel
and zoomed in and you can see we've got
our columns and our rows of data a
little easier to read in here we have a
result yes yes no we have initial
payment last payment credit score
house number
if we scroll way down
we'll see that this occupies a thousand
and one lines of code or lines of data
with the first one being a column and
then one thousand lines of data
now as a programmer
if you're looking at a small amount of
data i usually start by pulling it up in
different sources so i can see what i'm
working with
but in larger data you won't have that
option it would just be too too large so
you need to either bring in a small
amount that you can look at it like
we're doing right now or we can start
looking at it through the python code so
let's go ahead and move on and take the
next couple steps to explore the data
using python let's go ahead and see what
it looks like in python to print the
length and the shape of the data so
let's start by printing the length of
the database we can use a simple lin
function from python
and when i run this
you'll see that it's a thousand long and
that's what we expected there's a
thousand lines of data in there if you
subtract the column head
this is one of the nice things when we
did the
balance data from the panda read csv
you'll see that the header is row 0 so
it automatically removes a row
and then shows the data separate it does
a good job sorting that data out for us
and then we can use a different function
and let's take a look at that
and again we're going to utilize the
tools in panda
and since the balance underscored data
was loaded as a panda data frame
we can do a shape on it and let's go
ahead and run the shape and see what
that looks like
what's nice about this shape is not only
does it give me the length of the data
we have a thousand lines it also tells
me there's five columns so we were
looking at the data we had five columns
of data and then let's take one more
step to explore the data using python
and now that we've taken a look at the
length and the shape let's go ahead and
use the pandas module for head another
beautiful thing in the data set that we
can utilize so let's put that on our
sheet here and we have print data set
and balance data dot head and this is a
pandas print statement of its own so it
has its own print feature in there and
then we went ahead and gave a label for
a print job here of dataset just a
simple print statement
and we run that
and let's just take a closer look at
that let me zoom in here
there we go
pandas do such a wonderful job of making
this a very clean
readable data set so you can look at the
data you can look at the column headers
you can have it when you put it as the
head
it prints the first five lines of the
data
and we always start with zero so we have
five lines we have zero one two three
four instead of one two three four five
that's a standard scripting and
programming set as you wanna start with
the zero position and that is what the
data head does it pulls the first five
rows of data puts in a nice format that
you can look at and view very powerful
tool to view the data so instead of
having to flip and open up an excel
spreadsheet or open office cal or trying
to look at a
word doc where it's all scrunched
together and hard to read you can now
get a nice open view of what you're
working with we're working with a shape
of a thousand long five wide so we have
five columns and we do the full date
ahead you can actually see what this
data looks like the initial payment last
payment credit scores house number so
let's take this now that we've explored
the data and let's start digging into
the decision tree so in our next step
we're going to train and build our data
tree and to do that we need to first
separate the data out we're going to
separate into two groups so that we have
something to actually train the data
with and then we have some data on the
side to test it to see how good our
model is remember with any of the
machine learning you always want to have
some kind of test set to to weigh it
against so you know how good your model
is when you distribute it let's go ahead
and break this code down and look at it
in pieces
so first we have our x and y
where do x and y come from well x is
going to be our data
and y is going to be the answer or the
target you can look at its source and
target
in this case we're using x and y to
denote the data in and the data that
we're actually trying to guess what the
answer is going to be and so to separate
it we can simply put in x equals the
balance of the data.values the first
brackets
means that we're going to select all the
lines
in the database so it's all the data
and the second one says we're only going
to look at columns one through five
remember we always start with zero zero
is a yes or no
and that's whether the loan went default
or not so we want to start with one if
we go back up here that's the initial
payment and it goes all the way through
the house number
well if we want to look at 1 through 5
we can do the same thing for y which is
the answers and we're going to set that
just equal to the zero row so it's just
the zero row and then it's all rows
going in there so now we've divided this
into two different data sets
one of them with the
data going in and one with the answers
next we need to split the data
and here you'll see that we have it
split into four different parts
the first one is your x training your x
test your y train your y test
simply put we have x going in where
we're going to train it and we have to
know the answer to train it with
and then we have x test where we're
going to test that data
and we have to know in the end what the
y was supposed to be
and that's where this train test split
comes in that we loaded earlier in the
modules this does it all for us and you
can see they set the test size equal to
0.3 so it's roughly 30 percent will be
used in the test and then we use a
random state so it's completely random
which rows it takes out of there and
then finally we get to actually build
our decision tree and they've called it
here clf underscore entropy that's the
actual decision tree or decision tree
classifier and in here they've added a
couple variables which we'll explore in
just a minute and then finally we need
to fit the data to that so we take our
clf entropy that we created and we fit
the x train and since we know the
answers for x-trade or the y-train we go
ahead and put those in and let's go
ahead and run this and what most of
these sklearn modules do is when you set
up the variable in this case we set the
clf entropy equal decision tree
classifier it automatically prints out
what's in that decision tree there's a
lot of variables you can play within
here and it's quite beyond the scope of
this
tutorial to go through all of these and
how they work but we're working on
entropy that's one of the options we've
added that it's completely a random
state of 100 so 100 percent and we have
a max depth of three now the max depth
if you remember above when we were doing
the different graphs of animals means
it's only going to go down three layers
before it stops and then we have minimal
samples of leaves is five so it's going
to have at least five leaves at the end
so i'll have at least three splits i'll
have no more than three layers and at
least five end leaves with the final
result at the bottom now that we've
created our decision tree classifier not
only created it but trained it let's go
ahead and apply it and see what that
looks like so let's go ahead and make a
prediction and see what that looks like
we're going to paste our predict code in
here
and before we run it let's just take a
quick look at what's it's doing here
we have a variable y predict that we're
going to do
and we're going to use our
variable clf entropy that we created
and then you'll see dot predict and it's
very common in the sk learn modules
that their different tools have to
predict when you're actually running a
prediction
in this case we're going to put our x
test data in here
now if you delivered this for use and
actual commercial use and distributed it
this would be the new loans you're
putting in here to guess
whether the person's going to be pay
them back or not
in this case so we need to test out the
data and just see how good our sample is
how good of our tree does at predicting
the loan payments and finally since
anaconda jupiter notebook works as a
command line for python we can simply
put the y predict e in to print it i
could just as easily put the print
and put brackets around y predict en to
print it out we'll go ahead and do that
it doesn't matter which way you do it
and you'll see right here that runs a
prediction this is roughly 300 in here
remember it's 30 percent of a thousand
so you should have about 300 answers in
here
and this tells you which each one of
those lines of our test went in there
and this is what our y predict came out
so let's move on to the next step we're
going to take this data and try to
figure out just how good a model we have
so here we go since sklearn does all the
heavy lifting for you and all the math
we have a simple line of code to let us
know what the accuracy is and let's go
ahead and go through that and see what
that means and what that looks like
let's go ahead and paste this in and let
me zoom in a little bit
there we go
so you have a nice full picture
and we'll see here we're just going to
do a print accuracy is and then we do
the accuracy score
and this was something we imported
earlier if you remember at the very
beginning let me just scroll up there
real quick so you can see where that's
coming from
that's coming from here down here from
sklearn.metrics
import accuracy score
and you could probably run a script make
your own script to do this very easily
how accurate is it how many out of 300
do we get right and so we put in our y
test that's the one we ran the predict
on and then we put in our y predict e n
that's the answers we got
and we're just going to multiply that by
a hundred because this is just going to
give us an answer as a decimal and we
want to see it as a percentage
and let's run that and see what it looks
like
and if you see here we got an accuracy
of 93.66667
so when we look at the number of loans
and we look at how good our model fit we
can tell people it has about a 93.6
fitting to it so just a quick recap on
that we now have accuracy set up on here
and so we have created a model that uses
the decision tree algorithm to predict
whether a customer will repay the loan
or not the accuracy of the model is
about 94.6 percent the bank can now use
this model to decide whether it should
approve the loan request from a
particular customer or not and so this
information is really powerful we may
not be able to as individuals understand
all these numbers because they have
thousands of numbers that come in but
you can see that this is a smart
decision for the bank to use a tool like
this to help them to predict how good
their profits going to be off of the
loan balances and how many are going to
default or not
what's in it for you we're going to
cover clustering what is clustering k
means clustering which is one of the
most common use clustering tools out
there including a flow chart to
understand k-means clustering and how it
functions and then we'll do an actual
python live demo on clustering of cars
based on brands
then we're going to cover logistic
regression what is logistic regression
logistic regression curve and sigmoid
function and then we'll do another
python code demo to classify a tumor as
malignant or benign based on features
and let's start with clustering suppose
we have a pile of books of different
genres now we divide them into different
groups like fiction horror education and
as we can see from this young lady she
definitely is into heavy horror you can
just tell by those eyes and the maple
canadian leaf on her shirt but we have
fiction horror and education and we want
to go ahead and divide our books up well
organizing objects into groups based on
similarity is clustering and in this
case as we're looking at the books we're
talking about clustering things with
known categories but you can also use it
to explore data so you might not know
the categories you just know that you
need to divide it up in some way to
conquer the data and to organize it
better but in this case we're going to
be looking at clustering in specific
categories and let's just take a deeper
look at that we're going to use k means
clustering k means clustering is
probably the most commonly used
clustering tool in the machine learning
library k-means clustering is an example
of unsupervised learning if you remember
from our previous thing it is used when
you have unlabeled data so we don't know
the answer yet we have a bunch of data
that we want to cluster to different
groups define clusters in the data based
on feature similarity so we've
introduced a couple terms here we've
already talked about unsupervised
learning and unlabeled data so we don't
know the answer yet we're just going to
group stuff together and see if we can
find an answer of how things connect
we've also introduced feature similarity
features being different features of the
data now with books we can easily see
fiction and
horror and history books but a lot of
times with data some of that information
isn't so easy to see right when we first
look at it and so k-means is one of
those tools where we can start finding
things that connect that match with each
other suppose we have these data points
and want to assign them into a cluster
now when i look at these data points i
would probably group them into two
clusters just by looking at them i'd say
two of these group of data kind of come
together
but in k-means we pick k clusters and
assign random centroids to clusters
where the k clusters represents two
different clusters we pick k clusters
and cyrano centroids to the clusters
then we compute distance from objects to
the centroids now we form new clusters
based on minimum distances
and calculate the centroids so we figure
out what the best distance is for the
centroid then we move the centroid and
recalculate those distances repeat
previous two steps iteratively till the
cluster centroid stopped changing their
positions and become static
repeat previous two steps iteratively
till the cluster centroid stopped
changing and the positions become static
once the clusters become static then k
means clustering algorithm is said to be
converged and there's another term we
see throughout machine learning is
converged that means whatever math we're
using to figure out the answer has come
to a solution or it's converged on an
answer shall we see the flowchart to
understand make a little bit more sense
by putting it into a nice easy step by
step so we start we choose k we'll look
at the elbow method in just a moment we
assign random centroids to clusters and
sometimes you pick the centroids because
you might look at the data in a graph
and say oh these are probably the
central points then we compute the
distance from the objects to the
centroids
we take that and we form new clusters
based on minimum distance and calculate
their centroids then we compute the
distance from objects to the new
centroids and then we go back and repeat
those last two steps we calculate the
distances so as we're doing it brings
into the new centroid and then we move
the centroid around and we figure out
what the best which objects are closest
to each centroid so the objects can
switch from one centroid to the other
the centroids are moved around and we
continue that until it is converged
let's see an example of this suppose we
have this data set of seven individuals
and their score on two topics a and b so
here's our subject
in this case referring to the person
taking the test
and then we have subject a where we see
what they've scored on their first
subject and we have subject b and we can
see what they score on the second
subject now let's take two farthest
apart points as initials cluster
centroids remember we talked about
selecting them randomly or we can also
just put them in different points and
pick the furthest one apart so they move
together either one works okay depending
on what kind of data you're working on
and what you know about it
so we took the two furthest points one
and one and five and seven and now let's
take the two farthest apart points as
initial cluster centroids each point is
then assigned to the closest cluster
with respect to the distance from the
centroids so we take each one of these
points in there we measure that distance
and you can see that if we measure each
of those distances and you use the the
pythagorean theorem for a triangle in
this case because you know the x and the
y and you can figure out the diagonal
line from that or you just take a ruler
and put it on your monitor that'd be
kind of silly but it would work if
you're just eyeballing it you can see
how they naturally come together in
certain areas now we again calculate the
centroids of each cluster so cluster one
and then cluster two and we look at each
individual dot there's one two three
we're in one cluster the centroid then
moves over it becomes 1.8 comma 2.3 so
remember it was that one and one well
the very center of the data we're
looking at would put it at the one point
roughly 2 2 but 1.8 and 2.3 and the
second one if we wanted to make the
overall mean vector the average vector
of all the different distances to that
centroid we come up with 4 comma 1 and 5
4. so we've now moved the centroids we
compare each individual's distance to
its own cluster mean and to that of the
opposite cluster and we find
build a nice chart on here that the as
we move the centroid around we now have
a new different kind of clustering of
groups and using euclidean distance
between the points and the mean we get
the same formula you see these new
formulas coming up so we have our
individual dots distance to the mean
centroid of the cluster and distance to
the mean centroid of the cluster
only individual three is nearer to the
mean of the opposite cluster cluster two
then its own cluster one and you can see
here in the diagram where we've kind of
circled that one in the middle so when
we've moved the cluster the centroids of
the clusters over one of the points
shifted to the other cluster because
it's closer to that group of individuals
thus individual three is relocated to
cluster 2 resulting in a new partition
and we regenerate all those numbers of
how close they are to the different
clusters
for the new clusters we will find the
actual cluster centroids so now we move
the centroids over and you can see that
we've now formed two very distinct
clusters on here on comparing the
distance of each individual's distance
to its own cluster mean and to that of
the opposite cluster we find that the
data points are stable hence we have our
final clusters now if you remember i
brought up a concept earlier
caming on the k-means algorithm choosing
the right value of k will help in less
number of iterations and to find the
appropriate number of clusters in a data
set we use the elbow method and within
sum of squares wss is defined as the sum
of the squared distance between each
member of the cluster in its centroid
and so you see we've done here is we
have the number of clusters and as you
do
the same k-means algorithm over the
different clusters and you calculate
what that centroid looks like and you
find the optimal you can actually find
the optimal number of clusters using the
elbow the graph is called as the elbow
method and on this we guessed it two
just by looking at the data but as you
can see
the slope you actually just look for
right there where the elbow is in the
slope and you have a clear answer that
we want two different to start with k
means equals two a lot of times people
end up computing k-means equals two
three four five until they find the
value which fits on the elbow joint
sometimes you can just look at the data
and if you're really good with that
specific domain remember domain i
mentioned that last time you'll know
that where to pick those numbers or
where to start guessing at what that k
value is
so let's take this and we're going to
use a use case using k-means clustering
to cluster cars into brands using
parameters such as horsepower cubic
inches make year etc so we're going to
use the dataset cars data having
information about three brands of cars
toyota honda and nissan we'll go back to
my favorite tool the anaconda navigator
with the jupiter notebook and let's go
ahead and flip over to our jupiter
notebook and in our jupiter notebook i'm
going to go ahead and just paste the
basic
code that we usually start a lot of
these off with we're not going to go too
much into this code because we've
already discussed numpy we've already
discussed matplot library and pandas
that'll be being the number array pandas
being the pandas data frame and map plot
for the graphing and don't forget since
if you're using the jupiter notebook you
do need the matplot library inline so
that it plots everything on the screen
if you're using a different python
editor then you probably don't need that
because it'll have a pop-up window on
your computer and we'll go ahead and run
this just to load our libraries and our
setup into here the next step is of
course to look at our data which i've
already opened up in a spreadsheet and
you can see here we have the miles per
gallon cylinders cubic inches horsepower
weight pounds how heavy it is time it
takes to get to 60
my card is probably on this one at about
80 or 90. what year it is so this is you
can actually see this is kind of older
cars and then the brand toyota honda
nissan so the different cars are coming
from all the way from 1971 if we scroll
down to the 80s we have between the 70s
and 80s the number of cars that they've
put out
and let's uh when we come back here
we're going to importing the data so
we'll go ahead and do data set equals
and we'll use pandas to read this in and
it's uh from a csv file remember you can
always post this in the comments and
request the data files for these either
in the comments here on the youtube
video or go to simplylearn.com and
request that the car csv i put it in the
same folder as the code that i've stored
so my python code is stored in the same
folder so i don't have to put the full
path if you store them in different
folders you do have to change this and
double check your name variables and
we'll go ahead and run this and we've
chosen data set arbitrarily because you
know it's a data set we're importing and
we've now imported our car csv into the
data set
as you know you have to prep the data so
we're going to create the x data this is
the one that we're going to try to
figure out what's going on with and then
there's a number of ways to do this but
we'll do it in a simple loop so you can
actually see what's going on so we'll do
four i
and x dot columns so we're going to go
through each of the columns
and a lot of times it's important
i'll make lists of the columns and do
this because i might remove certain
columns or there might be columns that i
want to be processed differently but for
this we can go ahead and take x of i
and we want to go fill in a and that's a
pandas command but the question is what
are we going to fill the missing data
with we definitely don't want to just
put in a number that doesn't actually
mean something and so one of the tricks
you can do with this
is we can take x of i
and in addition to that we want to go
ahead and turn this into
an integer because a lot of these are
integers so we'll go ahead and keep it
integers and let me add the bracket here
a lot of editors will do this they'll
think that you're closing one bracket
make sure you get that second bracket in
there if it's a double bracket that's
always something that happens regularly
so once we have our integer of x of y
this is going to fill in any missing
data with the average
and i was so busy closing one set of
brackets i forgot that the mean is also
has brackets in there for the pandas so
we can see here we're going to fill in
all the data with the average value for
that column so if there's missing data
it's in the average of the data it does
have then once we've done that we'll go
ahead and loop through it again
and just check and see
to make sure everything is filled in
correctly and we'll print and then we
take x
is null and this returns a set of the
null value or the how many lines are
null and we'll just sum that up to see
what that looks like and so when i run
this
and so with the x what we want to do is
we want to remove the last column
because that had the models that's what
we're trying to see if we can cluster
these things and figure out the models
there is so many different ways to sort
the x out for one we could take the x
and we could go data set our variable
we're using and use the i location one
of the features that's in pandas
and we could take that and then take all
the rows
and all but the last column of the data
set
and at this time we could do values we
just converted to values so that's one
way to do this and if i let me just put
this down here and print
x
it's a capital x we chose and i run this
you can see it's just the values we
could also take out the values and
it's not going to return anything
because there's no values connected to
it what i like to do with this
is instead of doing the eye location
which does integers more common is to
come in here and we have our data set
and we're going to do data set
dot or data set dot columns and remember
that lists all the columns so if i come
in here
let me just mark that as red
and i print
data set dot columns
you can see that i have my index here i
have my mpg cylinders everything
including the brand which we don't want
so the way to get rid of the brand would
be to do data columns of everything but
the last one minus one so now if i print
this you'll see the brand disappears and
so i can actually just take
data set columns minus one
and i'll put it right in here for the
columns we're going to look at
and let's un mark this
and unmarked this
and now if i do an x dot head
i have a new data frame and you can see
right here we have all the different
columns except for the brand at the end
of the year
and it turns out when you start playing
with the data set you're going to get an
error later on and it'll say cannot
convert string to float value and that's
because if for some reason these things
the way they recorded them must been
recorded as strings so we have a neat
feature in here on pandas to convert
and it is simply convert objects
and for this we're going to do convert
oops convert underscore
numeric numeric
equals true and yes i did have to go
look that up i don't have it memorized
the convert numeric in there if i'm
working with a lot of these things i
remember them but
depending on where i'm at what i'm doing
i usually have to look it up and we run
that oops i must have missed something
in here let me double check my spelling
and when i double check my spilling
you'll see i missed the first underscore
in the convert objects when i run this
it now has everything converted
into a numeric value because that's what
we're going to be working with is
numeric values down here
and the next part is that we need to go
through the data and eliminate null
values
most people when they're doing small
amounts working with small data pools
discover afterwards that they have a
null value and they have to go back and
do this
so you know be aware
whenever we're formatting this data
things are going to pop up and sometimes
you go backwards to fix it
and that's fine that's just part of
exploring the data and understanding
what you have
and i should have done this earlier but
let me go ahead and increase the size of
my window one notch
there we go easier to see
so we'll do 4i in
working with x dot columns we'll page
through all the columns and we want to
take
x of i and we're going to change that
we're going to alter it
and so
with this we want to go ahead and fill
in
x of i pandas has the fill in a
and that just fills in any non-existent
missing data
then we'll put my brackets up and
there's a lot of different ways to fill
this data
if you have a really large data set some
people just void out that data because
and then look at it later in a separate
exploration of data
one of the tricks we can do is we can
take our column
and we can find the means
and the means is in other are quotation
marks
so we take the columns we're going to
fill in the non-existing one with the
means the problem is that returns a
decimal float so some of these aren't
decimals
certainly let me be a little careful of
doing this but for this example we're
just going to fill it in with the
integer version of this keeps it on par
with the other data that isn't a decimal
point
and then what we also want to do is we
want to double check
a lot of times you do this first part
first to double check then you do the
fill and then you do it again just to
make sure you did it right so we're
going to go through and test
for missing data
and one of the ways you can do that is
simply go in here
and take our x of i
column so it's going to go through the x
of y column it says is null so it's
going to return any any place there's a
null value it actually goes through all
the rows of each column is null and then
we want to go ahead and sum that so we
take that and we add the sum value and
these are all pandas so is null is a
panda command and so is sum and if we go
through that we go ahead and run it
and we go ahead and take and run that
you'll see that all the columns have
zero null values so we've now tested and
double checked and our data is nice and
clean we have no null values everything
is now a number value we turned it into
numeric
and we've removed the last column in our
data
and at this point we're actually going
to
start using the elbow method to find the
optimal number of clusters so we're now
actually getting into the sk learn part
the k means clustering on here
i guess we'll go ahead and zoom it up
one more knot so you can see what i'm
typing in here
and then from
sk learn we're going to our sklearn
cluster
we're going to import
k
means
i always forget to capitalize the k and
the m when i do this so it's capital k
capital m k means
and we'll go and create a um
ray w c s s equals let me get an empty
array if you remember
from the elbow method from our slide
within the sums of squares wss is
defined as the sum of square distance
between each member of the cluster and
its centroid so we're looking at that
change in differences as far as a
squared distance and we're going to run
this over a number of k-mean values
in fact let's go for i in range we'll do
11 of them
rain 0 11
and the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to create the actual
blue all lower case
and so we're going to create this object
from the k-means that we just imported
and the variable that we want to put
into this is in
clusters
we're going to set that equals to i
that's the most important one because
we're looking at how increasing the
number of clusters
changes our answer there are a lot of
settings to the k-means
our guys in the back did a great job
just kind of playing with some of them
the most common ones that you see in a
lot of stuff is how you admit your
k-means so we have k-means plus
plus
this is just a tool to let the model
itself be smart how it picks the
centroids to start with its initial
incentroids we only want to iterate no
more than 300 times we have a max
iteration we put in there
we have the infinite the random state
equals zero you really don't need to
worry too much about these when you're
first learning this as you start digging
in deeper you start finding that these
are shortcuts that will speed up the
process
as far as the setup but the big one that
we're working with is the in clusters
equals i so we're going to literally
train our k means 11 times we're going
to do this process 11 times
and if you're working with big data you
know the first thing you do is you run a
small sample of the data so you can test
all your stuff on it and you can already
see the problem that if i'm going to
iterate through a terabyte of data 11
times and then the k-means itself is
iterating through the data multiple
times that's a heck of a process
so you got to be a little careful with
this a lot of times though you can find
your elbow using the elbow method find
your optimal number on a sample of data
especially if you're working with larger
data sources
so we want to go ahead and take our
k-means and we're just going to fit it
if you're looking at any of the sk learn
very common that you fit your model if
you remember correctly our variable
we're using is the capital x
and once we fit this value we go back to
the array we made and we want to go and
just depend that value on the end
and it's not the actual fit we're
pinning in there it's when it generates
it it generates the value you're looking
for is inertia so k means dot inertia
will pull that specific value out that
we need
and let's get a visual on this we'll do
our plt plot
and what we're plotting here
is first the x axis which is range 0
11 so that will generate a nice little
plot there and the wcss for our y y-axis
it's always nice to give our plot a
title
and let's see we'll just give it the
elbow method for the title and let's get
some labels so let's go ahead and do plt
x label
and we'll do a number of clusters for
that
and plt y label
and for that we can do oops there we go
wcss since that's what we're doing on
the plot on there and finally we want to
go ahead and display our graph which is
simply plt dot oops
dot show there we go and because we have
it set to inline it'll appear in line
hopefully i didn't make a type error on
there
and you can see we get a very nice graph
you can see a very nice elbow joint
there at
two and again right around three and
four and then after that there's not
very much
now as a data scientist if i was looking
at this
i would do either three or four and i'd
actually try both of them to see what
the
output look like and they've already
tried this in the back so we're just
going to use three as a setup on here
and let's go ahead and see what that
looks like when we actually use this
to show the different kinds of cars
and so let's go ahead and apply the
k-means to the cars data set
and basically we're going to copy the
code that we loop through up above
where k means equals k means number of
clusters and we're just going to set the
number of clusters to 3.
since that's what we're going to look
for and you can do 3 and 4 on this and
graph them just to see how they come up
differently be kind of curious to look
at that but for this we're just going to
set it to 3. go ahead and create our own
variable y
k means for our answers
and we're going to set that equal to
whoops a double equal there 2k means
but we're not going to do a fit we're
going to do a fit predict is the setup
you want to use and when you're using
untrained models you'll see a slightly
different usually you see fit and then
you see just the predict but we want to
both fit and predict the k-means on this
and that's fit underscore predict and
then our capital x is the data we're
working with
and before we plot this data we're going
to do a little pandas trick we're going
to take our x value and we're going to
set x as matrix
so we're converting this into a nice
rows and columns kind of set up but we
want the we're going to have columns
equals none so it's just going to be a
matrix of data in here
and let's go ahead and run that
a little warning you'll see these
warnings pop up because things are
always being updated so there's like
minor changes in the versions and future
versions
instead of matrix now that it's more
common to set it dot values instead of
doing as matrix but math matrix works
just fine for right now and you'll want
to update that later on but let's go
ahead and dive in and plot this and see
what that looks like
and before we dive into plotting this
data i always like to take a look and
see what i am plotting so let's take a
look at y
k means i'm just going to print that out
down here
and we see we have an array of answers
we have 2 1 0 2 1 2. so it's clustering
these different
rows of data
based on the three different spaces it
thinks it's going to be
and then let's go ahead and print x and
see what we have for x and we'll see
that x is an array it's a matrix
so we have our different values in the
array and what we're going to do it's
very hard to plot all the different
values in the array so we're only going
to be looking at the first two or
positions 0 and 1. and if you were doing
a full presentation in front of the
board meeting
you might actually do a little different
than and dig a little deeper into the
different aspects because this is all
the different columns we looked at but
when we look at columns 1 and 2 for this
to make it easy
so let's go ahead and clear this data
out of here and let's bring up our plot
and we're going to do a scatter plot
here so plt scatter
and
this looks a little complicated so let's
explain what's going on with this we're
going to take the x values
and we're only interested in y of k
means equals 0 the first cluster okay
and then we're going to take value 0 for
the x-axis and then we're going to do
the same thing here
we're only interested in
k means equals 0 but we're going to take
this second column so we're looking at
the first two columns in our answer or
in the data
and then the guys in the back played
with this a little bit to make it pretty
and they discovered that it looks good
with as the size equals 100 that's the
size of the dots
we're going to use red for this one and
when they were looking at the data and
what came out it was definitely the
toyota on this we're just going to go
ahead and label it toyota again that's
something you really have to explore in
here as far as playing with those
numbers and see what looks good we'll go
ahead and hit enter in there and i'm
just going to paste in the next
two lines which is the next two cars
and this is our nissa and honda
and you'll see with our scatter plot
we're now looking at where y underscore
k means equals one and we want the zero
column and y k means equals two again
we're looking at just the first two
columns zero and one
and each of these rows then corresponds
to nissan and honda
and i'll go ahead and hit enter on there
and finally let's take a look and put
the centroids on there
again we're going to do a scatter plot
and on the centroids you can just pull
that from our k-means the model we
created
dot cluster centers
and we're going to just do
all of them in the first number and all
of them and the second number which is 0
1 because you always start with 0 and 1.
and then they were playing with the size
and everything to make it look good
we'll do a size of 300 we're going to
make the color yellow and we'll label
them it's always good to have some good
labels centroids
and then we do want to do a title plt
title
and pop up there
plt title cause you always make wanna
make your graphs look pretty and we'll
call it clusters of car make
and one of the features of the
plot library is you can add a
legend it'll automatically bring in
since we've already labeled the
different aspects of the legend with
toyota nissan and honda
and finally we want to go ahead and show
so we can actually see it and remember
it's in line
so if you're using a different editor
that's not the jupiter notebook you'll
get a pop-up of this
and you should have a nice set of
clusters here so we can look at this we
have a clusters of honda and green
toyota and red
nissan and purple and you can see where
they put the centroids to separate them
now when we're looking at this we can
also plot a lot of other different data
on here as far because we only looked at
the first two columns this is just
column one and two or zero one as you
label them in computer scripting but you
can see here we have nice clusters of
car make and we were able to pull out
the data and you can see how just these
two columns form very distinct clusters
of data
so if you were exploring new data you
might take a look and say well what
makes these different
almost going in reverse you start
looking at the data and pulling apart
the columns to find out
why is the first group set up the way it
is maybe you're doing loans and you want
to go well why is this group not
defaulting on their loans and why is the
last group defaulting on their loans and
why is the middle group 50 percent
defaulting on their
bank loans and you start finding ways to
manipulate the data and pull out the
answers you want
so now that you've seen how to use
k-mean for clustering
let's move on to the next topic
now let's look into logistic regression
the logistic regression algorithm is the
simplest classification algorithm used
for binary or multi-classification
problems and we can see we have our
little girl from canada who's into
horror books is back that's actually
really scary when you think about that
with those big eyes in the previous
tutorial we learned about linear
regression dependent and independent
variables so to brush up y equals mx
plus c
very basic algebraic function of
y and x the dependent variable is the
target class variable we are going to
predict
the independent variables x1 all the way
up to xn are the features or attributes
we are going to use to predict the
target class we know what a linear
regression looks like but using the
graph we cannot divide the outcome into
categories
it's really hard to categorize 1.5 3.6
9.8
for example a linear regression graph
can tell us that with increase in number
of hours studied the marks of a student
will increase but it will not tell us
whether the student will pass or not in
such cases where we need the output as
categorical value we will use logistic
regression and for that we're going to
use the sigmoid function so you can see
here we have our marks 0 to 100 number
of hours studied that's going to be what
they're comparing it to in this example
and we usually form a line that says y
equals mx plus c and when we use the
sigmoid function we have p equals 1 over
1 plus e to the minus y
it generates a sigmoid curve and so you
can see right here when you take the ln
which is the natural logarithm i always
thought it should be nl not ln that's
just the inverse of
e your e to the minus y and so we do
this we get ln of p over 1 minus p
equals m times x plus c that's the
sigmoid curve function we're looking for
now we can zoom in on the function and
you'll see that the function as it
derives goes to 1 or to 0 depending on
what your x value is and the probability
if it's greater than 0.5 the value is
automatically rounded off to 1
indicating that the student will pass so
if they're doing a certain amount of
studying they will probably pass then
you have a threshold value at the 0.5 it
automatically puts that right in the
middle usually and your probability if
it's less than 0.5 the value rendered
off to zero indicating the student will
fail so if they're not studying very
hard they're probably going to fail this
of course is ignoring the outliers or
that one student is just a natural
genius and doesn't need any studying to
memorize everything that's not me
unfortunately i have to study hard to
learn new stuff
problem statement to classify whether a
tumor is malignant or benign and this is
actually one of my favorite data sets to
play with because it has so many
features and when you look at them you
really are hard to understand you can't
just look at them and know the answer so
it gives you a chance to kind of dive
into what data looks like when you
aren't able to understand the specific
domain of the data but i also want you
to remind you that in the domain of
medicine if i told you that my
probability
was really good it classified things
that say 90 or 95
and i'm classifying whether you're going
to have a malignant or a b9 tumor i'm
guessing that you're going to go get it
tested anyways so you got to remember
the domain we're working with so why
would you want to do that if you know
you're just going to go get a biopsy
because you know it's that serious this
is like an all or nothing just
referencing the domain it's important it
might help the doctor know where to look
just by understanding what kind of tumor
it is so it might help them or aid them
in something they missed from before so
let's go ahead and dive into the code
and i'll come back to the domain part of
it in just a minute so use case and
we're going to do our normal imports
here we're importing numpy
pandas seaborn the matplot library and
we're going to do matplot library inline
since i'm going to switch over to
anaconda so let's go ahead and flip over
there and get this started
so i've opened up a new window in my
anaconda jupiter notebook
and by the way jupiter notebook you
don't have to use anaconda for the
jupiter notebook i just love the
interface and all the tools and anaconda
brings so we got our import numpy as in
p for our numpy number array we have our
pandas pd we're going to bring in
seaborn to help us with our graphs as
sns
so many really nice tools in both
seaboard and matplot library and we'll
do our
matplotlibrary.piplot as plt and then of
course we want to let it know to do it
in line and let's go and just run that
so it's all set up
and we're just going to call our data
data
not creative today
equals pd and this happens to be in a
csv file
so we'll use the pd.read underscore csv
and i happen to name the file i renamed
it
dataforp2.csv you can of course write in
the comments below the youtube and
request for the dataset itself or go to
the simplylearn website and we'll be
happy to supply that for you
and let's just open up the data before
we go any further and let's just see
what it looks like in a spreadsheet
so when i pop it open in a local
spreadsheet this is just a csv file
comma separated variables we have an id
so i guess the
categorizes for reference or what id
which test was done the diagnosis m for
malignant b for b9 so there's two
different options on there and that's
what we're going to try to predict is
the m and b and test it and then we have
like the radius
mean or average the texture average
perimeter mean area mean smoothness i
don't know about you but unless you're a
doctor in the field most of stuff i mean
you can guess what concave means just by
the term concave but i really wouldn't
know what that means in the measurements
they're taking so they have all kinds of
stuff like how smooth it is
uh the symmetry and these are all float
values let me just page through them
real quick and you'll see there's i
believe 36 if i remember correctly in
this one
so there's a lot of different values
they take and all these measurements
they take when they go in there and they
take a look at the different growth the
tumorous growth
so back in our data and i put this in
the same folder as a code so i saved
this code in that folder obviously if
you have it in a different location you
want to put the full path in there and
we'll just do
pandas
first five lines of data with the data
dot head
when we run that we can see that we have
pretty much what we just looked at we
have an id we have a diagnosis
if we go all the way across you'll see
all the different columns coming across
displayed nicely
for our data
and while we're exploring the data our
seaborn which we referenced as sns
makes it very easy to go in here and do
a joint plot you'll notice that
very similar to because it is sitting on
top of the
plot library so the joint plot does a
lot of work for us and we're just going
to look at the first two
columns that we're interested in the
radius mean and the texture mean we'll
just look at those two columns
and data equals data so that tells it
which two columns we're plotting and
that we're going to use the data that we
pulled in let's just run that
and it generates a really nice graph on
here
and there's all kinds of cool things on
this graph to look at i mean we have the
texture mean and the radius mean
obviously the axes you can also see
and one of the cool things on here is
you can also see the histogram they show
that for the radius mean whereas the
most commonest radius mean come up and
where the most common texture is so
we're looking at the tech the
on each growth its average texture and
on each radius its average uh radius on
there it's a little confusing because
we're talking about the individual
objects average and then we can also
look over here and see the the histogram
showing us the median or how common each
measurement is
and that's only two columns so let's dig
a little deeper into seaborn they also
have a heat map and if you're not
familiar with heat maps a heat map just
means it's in color that's all that
means heat map i guess the original ones
we're plotting heat density on something
and so ever since then it's just called
a heat map and we're going to take our
data
and get our corresponding numbers to put
that into the heat map and that's simply
data.corr
for that that's a pandas expression
let's remember we're working in a pandas
data frame so that's one of the cool
tools in pandas for our data and this is
pull that information into a heat map
and see what that looks like
and you'll see that we're now looking at
all the different features we have our
id we have our texture we have our area
our compactness concave points
and if you look down the middle of this
chart diagonal going from the upper left
to bottom right
it's all white that's because when you
compare texture to texture they're
identical so they're a hundred percent
or in this case a perfect one in their
correspondence
and you'll see that when you look at say
area or right below it it has almost a
black on there when you compare it to
texture so these have almost no
corresponding data they don't really
form a linear graph or something that
you can look at and say how connected
they are they're very scattered data
this is really just a really nice graph
to get a quick look at your data doesn't
so much change what you do but it
changes verifying so when you get an
answer or something like that or you
start looking at some of these
individual pieces you might go hey that
doesn't match according to showing our
heat map this should not correlate with
each other and if it is you're going to
have to start asking well why what's
going on what else is coming in there
but it does show some really cool
information on here and we can see from
the id
there's no real one feature that just
says if you go across the top line that
lights up there's no one feature that
says hey if the area is a certain size
then it's going to be b9 or malignant it
says there's some that sort of add up
and that's a big hint in the data that
we're trying to id this whether it's
malignant or b9 that's a big hint to us
as data scientists to go okay
we can't solve this with any one feature
it's going to be something that includes
all the features or many of the
different features to come up with the
solution for it and while we're
exploring the data let's explore one
more area and let's look at data dot is
null we want to check for null values in
our data if you remember from earlier in
this tutorial we did it a little
differently where we added stuff up and
sum them up you can actually with pandas
do it really quickly data dot is null
and summit and it's going to go across
all the columns so when i run this
you're going to see all the columns come
up with no null
data we've just just to re hash these
last few steps
we've done a lot of exploration we have
looked at the first two columns
and seen how they plot with the seaborn
with a joint plot which shows both the
histogram and the data plotted on the xy
coordinates
and obviously you can do that more in
detail
with different columns and see how they
plot together
and then we took and did the seaborne
heat map the sns
dot heat map of the data and you can see
right here where it did a nice job
showing us some bright spots where stuff
correlates with each other and forms a
very nice combination or points of
scattering points and you can also see
areas that don't
and then finally we went ahead and
checked the data is the data null value
do we have any missing data in there
very important step because it'll crash
later on
if you forget to do this step it will
remind you when you get that nice error
code that says no values okay
so not a big deal if you miss it but
it's no fun having to go back when
you're you're in a huge process and
you've missed this step and now you're
10 steps later and you've got to
remember where you were pulling the data
in
so we need to go ahead and pull out our
x
and our y
let me just put that down here and we'll
set the x equal to
and there's a lot of different options
here certainly we could do x equals all
the columns except for the first two
because if you remember the first two is
the id and the diagnosis
so that certainly would be an option
but we're going to do is we're actually
going to focus on the worst the worst
radius the worst texture parameter area
smoothness compactness and so on one of
the reasons to start dividing your data
up when you're looking at this
information
is
sometimes the data will be the same data
coming in so if i have two measurements
coming in to my model it might overweigh
them it might overpower the other
measurements because it's measuring it's
basically taking that information in
twice
that's a little bit past the scope of
this tutorial
i want you to take away from this though
is that we are dividing the date up into
pieces and our team in the back went
ahead and said hey let's just look at
the worst so i'm going to create a an
array
and you'll see this array radius worst
texture worse perimeter worst we've just
taken the worst of the worst and i'm
just going to put that in my x so this x
is still a pandas data frame but it's
just those columns and our y if you
remember correctly is going to be oops
hold on one second it's not x it's data
there we go so x equals data and then
it's a list of the different columns the
worst of the worst and if we're going to
take that then we have to have our
answer for our y for the stuff we know
and if you remember correctly we're just
going to be looking at
the diagnosis that's all we care about
is what is it diagnosed is it b9 or
malignant
and since it's a single column we can
just do diagnosis i forgot to put the
brackets or there we go okay so it's
just diagnosis on there and we can also
real quickly do like x dot head if you
want to see what that looks like
and y dot head
and run this
and you'll see
it only does the last one i forgot about
that if you don't do print you can see
that the the y dot head is just mmm
because the first ones are all malignant
and if i run this the x dot head is just
the first five values of radius worst
texture worse parameter worst area worst
and so on
i'll go ahead and take that out
so moving down
to the next step we've built our two
data sets our answer and then the
features we want to look at
in data science it's very important to
test your
model
so we do that by splitting the data
and from sklearn model selection we're
going to import train test split so
we're going to split it into two groups
there are so many ways to do this i
noticed in one of the more modern ways
to actually split it into three groups
and then you model each group and test
it against the other groups so you have
all kinds and there's reasons for that
which is pass the scope of this and for
this particular example isn't necessary
for this we're just going to split it
into two groups one to train our data
and one to test our data and the sklearn
dot model selection we have train test
split you could write your own quick
code to do this we just randomly divide
the data up into two groups but they do
it for us nicely
and we actually can almost we can
actually do it in one statement with
this where we're going to generate four
variables
capital x train capital x test so we
have our training data we're going to
use to fit the model and then we need
something to test it and then we have
our y train so we're going to train the
answer and then we have our test so this
is the stuff we want to see how good it
did on our model
and we'll go ahead and take our train
test split that we just imported
and we're going to do x and our y are
two different data that's going in for
our split
and then the guys in the back came up
and wanted us to go ahead and use a test
size equals 0.3 that's test underscore
size random state it's always nice to
kind of switch your random state around
but not that important
what this means is that the test size is
we're going to take 30 of the data and
we're going to put that into our test
variables our y test and our x test and
we're going to do 70 into the x train
and the y train so we're going to use 70
of the data to train our model and 30 to
test it
let's go ahead and run that and load
those up
so now we have all our stuff split up
and all our data ready to go
now we get to the actual logistics part
we're actually going to do our create
our model
so let's go ahead and bring that in from
sklearn we're going to bring in our
linear model and we're going to import
logistic regression that's the actual
model we're using and this will call it
log model
stereo model and let's just set this
equal to our logistic regression that we
just imported
so now we have a variable log model set
to that class for us to use
and with most the
models in the sk learn we just need to
go ahead and fix it fit
do a fit on there and we use our x train
that we separated out with our y
train and let's go ahead and run this so
once we've run this we'll have a model
that fits this data that 70 of our
training data
and of course it prints this out that
tells us all the different variables
that you can set on there there's a lot
of different choices you can make but
for word though we're just going to let
all the defaults sit we don't really
need to mess with those on this
particular example and there's nothing
in here that really stands out as super
important until you start
fine tuning it but for what we're doing
the basics will work just fine
and then let's we need to go ahead and
test out our model is it working so
let's create a variable y predict and
this is going to be equal to
our log model
and we want to do a predict again very
standard format for the sk learn library
is taking your model and doing a predict
on it and we're going to test why
predict against the y test so we want to
know what the model thinks it's going to
be that's what our y predict is and with
that we want the capital x x
test
so we have our train set and our test
set and now we're going to do our y
predict and let's go ahead and run that
and if we print
y
predict
let me go ahead and run that
you'll see it comes up and it presents
and i prints a nice array of
b and m for b9 and malignant
for all the different test data we put
in there
so that's pretty good we're not sure
exactly how good it does but we can see
that it actually works and is functional
was very easy to create you'll always
discover with our data science that as
you explore this
you spend a significant amount of time
prepping your data
and making sure your data coming in is
good
there's a saying
good data in good answers out bad data
in
bad answers out that's only half the
thing that's only half of it
selecting your models becomes the next
part as far as how good your models are
and then of course fine-tuning it
depending on what model you're using
so we come in here we want to know how
good this came out so we have our y
predict here log model dot predict x
test
so for deciding how good our model is
we're going to go from the
sklearn.metrics we're going to import
classification report
and that just reports how good our model
is doing and then we're going to feed it
the model data let's just print this out
and we'll take our classification report
and we're going to put into there
our test our actual
data so this is what we actually know is
true
and our prediction what our model
predicted for that data on the test side
and let's run that and see what that
does
so we pull that up you'll see that we
have
a precision for b9 and malignant b and m
and we have a precision of 93 at 91 a
total of 92 so it's kind of the average
between these two 92
there's all kinds of different
information on here your f1 score
your recall your support coming through
on this
and for this i'll go ahead and just flip
back to our slides that they put
together for describing it and so here
we're going to look at the precision
using the classification report and you
see this is the same printout i had up
above some of the numbers might be
different because it does randomly pick
out which data we're using so this model
is able to predict the type of tumor
with 91 percent accuracy
so we look back here that's you'll see
where we have uh b9 and it actually is
92 coming up here but we're looking
about a 92 91 precision and remember i
reminded you about domains and we're
talking about the domain of a medical
domain with a very catastrophic outcome
you know at 91 or 92 percent precision
you're still going to go in there and
have somebody do a biopsy on it very
different than if you're investing money
and there's a 92 chance you're going to
earn 10
and 8 chance you're going to lose 8
you're probably going to bet the money
because at that odds it's pretty good
that you'll make some money and in the
long run you do that enough you
definitely will make money and also with
this domain i've actually seen them use
this to identify different forms of
cancer that's one of the things that
they're starting to use these models for
because then it helps the doctor know
what to investigate so that wraps up
this section we're going to cover the k
nearest neighbors like referred to as k
n n and k n is really a fundamental
place to start in the machine learning
it's the basis of a lot of other things
and just the logic behind it is easy to
understand and incorporated in other
forms of machine learning so today
what's in it for you why do we need k n
n
what is k n
how do we choose the factor k
when do we use k n n
how does k n algorithm work
and then we'll dive in to my favorite
part the use case predict whether a
person will have diabetes or not that is
a very common and popular used data set
as far as testing out models and
learning how to use the different models
in machine learning by now we all know
machine learning models make predictions
by learning from the past data available
so we have our input values our machine
learning model builds on those inputs of
what we already know and then we use
that to create a predicted output
is that a dog little kid looking over
there watching the black cat cross their
path no dear you can differentiate
between a cat and a dog based on their
characteristics
cats
cats have sharp claws uses to climb
smaller length of ears meows and purrs
doesn't love to play around dogs they
have dull claws bigger length of ears
barks loves to run around you usually
don't see a cat running around people
although i do have a cat that does that
where dogs do and we can look at these
we can say we can evaluate the sharpness
of the claws how sharp are their claws
and we can evaluate the length of the
ears and we can usually sort out cats
from dogs based on even those two
characteristics
now tell me if it is a cat or a dog not
a question usually little kids know cats
and dogs by now unless they live a place
where there's not many cats or dogs so
if we look at the sharpness of the claws
the length of the ears and we can see
that the cat has smaller ears and
sharper claws than the other animals its
features are more like cats it must be a
cat
sharp claws length of ears and it goes
in the cat group because knn is based on
feature similarity we can do
classification using knn classifier so
we have our input value the picture of
the black cat it goes into our trained
model and it predicts that this is a cat
coming out so what is knn what is the k
n algorithm
k nearest neighbors is what that stands
for is one of the simplest supervised
machine learning algorithms mostly used
for classification so we want to know is
this a dog or is not a dog is it a cat
or not a cat it classifies a data point
based on how its neighbors are
classified knn stores all available
cases and classifies new cases based on
a similarity measure and here we've gone
from cats and dogs right into wine
another favorite of mine k n stores all
available cases and classifies new cases
based on a similarity measure and here
you see we have a measurement of sulfur
dioxide versus the chloride level and
then the different wines they've tested
and where they fall on that graph based
on how much sulfur dioxide and how much
chloride k and knn is a perimeter that
refers to the number of nearest
neighbors to include in the majority of
the voting process and so if we add a
new glass of wine there red or white we
want to know what the neighbors are in
this case we're going to put k equals 5
we'll talk about k in just a minute a
data point is classified by the majority
of votes from its five nearest neighbors
here the unknown point would be
classified as red since four out of five
neighbors are red
so how do we choose k
how do we know k equals five i mean
that's what's the value we put in there
so we're going to talk about it how do
we choose a factor k k n algorithm is
based on feature similarity choosing the
right value of k
is a process called parameter tuning and
is important for better accuracy so at k
equals 3 we can classify we have a
question mark in the middle as either a
as a square or not is it a square or is
it in this case a triangle and so if we
set k equals to 3 we're going to look at
the three nearest neighbors we're going
to say this is a square and if we put k
equals to 7 we classify as a triangle
depending on what the other data is
around and you can see as the k changes
depending on where that point is that
drastically changes your answer and we
jump here we go how do we choose the
factor of k you'll find this in all
machine learning choosing these factors
that's the face you get it's like oh my
gosh did i choose the right k did i set
it right my values in whatever machine
learning tool you're looking at so that
you don't have a huge bias in one
direction or the other and in terms of k
n n the number of k if you choose it too
low the bias is based on it's just two
noises it's it's right next to a couple
things and it's going to pick those
things and you might get a skewed answer
and if your k is too big then it's going
to take forever to process so you're
going to run into processing issues and
resource issues so what we do the most
common use and there's other options for
choosing k is to use the square root of
n so it is a total number of values you
have you take the square root of it in
most cases you also if it's an even
number so if you're using uh like this
case squares and triangles if it's even
you want to make your k value odd that
helps it select better so in other words
you're not going to have a balance
between two different factors that are
equal so usually take the square root of
n and if it's even you add one to it or
subtract one from it and that's where
you get the k value from that is the
most common use and it's pretty solid it
works very well when do we use knn we
can use knn when data is labeled so you
need a label on it we know we have a
group of pictures with dogs dogs cats
cats data is noise free and so you can
see here when we have a class and we
have like underweight 140 23 hello kitty
normal that's pretty confusing we have a
high variety of data coming in so it's
very noisy and that would cause an issue
data set is small so we're usually
working with smaller data sets where you
might get into a gig of data if it's
really clean doesn't have a lot of noise
because k n is a lazy learner i.e it
doesn't learn a discriminative function
from the training set so it's very lazy
so if you have very complicated data and
you have a large amount of it you're not
going to use the knn but it's really
great to get a place to start even with
large data you can sort out a small
sample and get an idea of what that
looks like using the knn and also just
using for smaller data sets k n works
really good how does a k n algorithm
work consider a data set having two
variables height in centimeters and
weight in kilograms and each point is
classified as normal or underweight so
we see right here we have two variables
you know true false they're either
normal or they're not they're
underweight on the basis of the given
data we have to classify the below set
as normal or underweight using knn so if
we have new data coming in this says 57
kilograms and 177 centimeters is that
going to be normal or underweight to
find the nearest neighbors we'll
calculate the euclidean distance
according to the euclidean distance
formula the distance between two points
in the plane with the coordinates x y
and a b is given by distance d equals
the square root of x minus a squared
plus y minus b squared and you can
remember that from the two edges of a
triangle we're computing the third edge
since we know
the x side and the y side let's
calculate it to understand clearly so we
have our unknown point and we placed it
there in red and we have our other
points where the data is scattered
around the distance d1 is the square
root of 170 minus 167 squared plus 57
minus 51 squared which is about 6.7 and
distance 2 is about 13. and distance 3
is about 13.4 similarly we will
calculate the euclidean distance of
unknown data point from all the points
in the data set and because we're
dealing with small amount of data that's
not that hard to do it's actually pretty
quick for a computer and it's not a
really complicated mass you can just see
how close is the data based on the
euclidean distance hence we have
calculated the euclidean distance of
unknown data point from all the points
as shown where x1 and y1 equal 57 and
170 whose class we have to classify so
now we're looking at that we're saying
well here's the euclidean distance who's
going to be their closest neighbors now
let's calculate the nearest neighbor at
k equals three and we can see the three
closest neighbors puts them at normal
and that's pretty self-evident when you
look at this graph it's pretty easy to
say okay what you know we're just voting
normal normal normal three votes for
normal this is going to be a normal
weight so majority of neighbors are
pointing towards normal hence as per k n
algorithm the class of 57 170 should be
normal so a recap of knn positive
integer k is specified along with a new
sample we select the k entries in our
database which are closest to the new
sample we find the most common
classification of these entries this is
the classification we give to the new
sample so as you can see it's pretty
straightforward we're just looking for
the closest things that match what we
got so let's take a look and see what
that looks like in a use case in python
so let's dive into the predict diabetes
use case so use case predict diabetes
the objective predict whether a person
will be diagnosed with diabetes or not
we have a data set of 768 people who
were or were not diagnosed with diabetes
and let's go ahead and open that file
and just take a look at that data and
this is in a simple spreadsheet format
the data itself is comma separated very
common set of data and it's also a very
common way to get the data and you can
see here we have columns a through i
that's what one two three four five six
seven eight
eight columns with a particular
attribute and then the ninth column
which is the outcome is whether they
have diabetes as a data scientist the
first thing you should be looking at is
insulin well you know if someone has
insulin they have diabetes because
that's why they're taking it and that
could cause issue in some of the machine
learning packages but for a very basic
setup this works fine for doing the k n
and the next thing you notice is it
didn't take very much to open it up i
can scroll down to the bottom of the
data there's 768.
it's pretty much a small data set you
know at 769 i can easily fit this into
my ram on my computer i can look at it i
can manipulate it and it's not going to
really tax just a regular desktop
computer you don't even need an
enterprise version to run a lot of this
so let's start with importing all the
tools we need and before that of course
we need to discuss what ide i'm using
certainly can use any particular editor
for python but i like to use for doing
uh very basic visual stuff the anaconda
which is great for doing demos with the
jupiter notebook and just a quick view
of the anaconda navigator which is the
new release out there which is really
nice you can see under home i can choose
my application we're going to be using
python36 i have a couple different
versions on this particular machine if i
go under environments i can create a
unique environment for each one which is
nice and there's even a little button
there where i can install different
packages so if i click on that button
and open the terminal i can use a simple
pip install to install different
packages i'm working with let's go ahead
and go back under home and we're going
to launch our notebook and i've already
you know kind of like
the old cooking shows i've already
prepared a lot of my stuff so we don't
have to wait for it to launch because it
takes a few minutes for it to open up a
browser window in this case it's going
to open up chrome because that's my
default that i use and since the script
is pre-done you'll see have a number of
windows open up at the top the one we're
working in and uh since we're working on
the k n predict whether a person will
have diabetes or not let's go and put
that title in there and i'm also going
to go up here and click on cell actually
we want to go ahead and first insert a
cell below and then i'm going to go back
up to the top cell and i'm going to
change the cell type to markdown that
means this is not going to run as python
it's a markdown language so if i run
this first one it comes up in nice big
letters which is kind of nice remind us
what we're working on and by now you
should be familiar with doing all of our
imports we're going to import the pandas
as pd import numpy is np pandas is the
pandas data frame a numpy is a number
array very powerful tools to use in here
so we have our imports so we've brought
in our pandas our numpy our two general
python tools and then you can see over
here we have our train test split by now
you should be familiar with splitting
the data we want to split part of it for
training our thing and then training our
particular model and then we want to go
ahead and test the remaining data to see
how good it is pre-processing a standard
scalar preprocessor so we don't have a
bias of really large numbers remember in
the data we had like number of
pregnancies isn't going to get very
large where the amount of insulin they
take and get up to 256 so 256 versus 6
that will skew results so we want to go
ahead and change that so they're all
uniform between minus one and one and
then the actual tool this is the k
neighbors classifier we're gonna use
and finally the last three are three
tools to test all about testing our
model how good is it we just put down
test on there and we have our confusion
matrix our f1 score and our accuracy so
we have our two general python modules
we're importing and then we have our six
modules specific from the sklearn setup
and then we do need to go ahead and run
this so these are actually imported
there we go and then move on to the next
step and so in this set we're going to
go ahead and load the database we're
going to use pandas remember pandas is
pd and we'll take a look at the data in
python we looked at it in a simple
spreadsheet but usually i like to also
pull it up so we can see what we're
doing so here's our data set equals
pd.read csv that's a pandas command and
the diabetes folder i just put in the
same folder where my ipython script is
if you put in a different folder you
need the full length on there we can
also do a quick length of uh the data
set that is a simple python command len
for length we might even let's go ahead
and print that we'll go print and if you
do it on its own line link that data set
in the jupyter notebook it'll
automatically print it but when you're
in most of your different setups you
want to do the print in front of there
and then we want to take a look at the
actual data set and since we're in
pandas we can simply do data set head
and again let's go ahead and add the
print in there
if you put a bunch of these in a row you
know the data set 1 head data set 2 head
it only prints out the last one so i
usually always like to keep the print
statement in there but because most
projects only use one data frame panda's
data frame doing it this way doesn't
really matter the other way works just
fine and you can see when we hit the run
button we have the 768 lines which we
knew and we have our pregnancies it's
automatically given a label on the left
remember the head only shows the first
five lines so we have zero through four
and just a quick look at the data you
can see it matches what we looked at
before we have pregnancy glucose blood
pressure all the way to age and then the
outcome on the end and we're going to do
a couple things in this next step we're
going to create a list of columns where
we can't have 0. there's no such thing
as zero skin thickness or zero blood
pressure zero glucose uh any of those
you'd be dead so not a really good
factor if they don't if they have a zero
in there because they didn't have the
data and we'll take a look at that
because we're going to start replacing
that information with a couple of
different things let's see what that
looks like so first we create a nice
list as you can see we have the values
talked about glucose blood pressure skin
thickness
and this is a nice way when you're
working with columns is to list the
columns you need to do some kind of
transformation on a very common thing to
do and then for this particular setup we
certainly could use the there's some
panda tools that will do a lot of this
where we can replace the n a but we're
going to go ahead and do it as a data
set column equals dataset column.replace
this is this is still pandas you can do
a direct there's also one that's that
you look for your nan a lot of different
options in here but the nan
numpy nan is what that stands for is
none it doesn't exist so the first thing
we're doing here is we're replacing the
zero with a numpy none there's no data
there that's what that says that's what
this is saying right here so put the
zero in and we're going to place zeroes
with no data so if it's a zero that
means the person's well hopefully not
dead hope they just didn't get the data
the next thing we want to do is we're
going to create the mean which is the
integer from the data set from the
column dot mean where we skip n a's we
can do that that is a pandas command
there the skip n a so we're going to
figure out the mean of that data set and
then we're going to take that data set
column and we're going to replace all
the n p n a n with the means why did we
do that and we could have actually just
uh taken this step and gone right down
here and just replaced zero and skip
anything where except you could actually
there's a way to skip zeros and then
just replace all the zeros but in this
case we want to go ahead and do it this
way so you could see that we're
switching this to a non-existent value
then we're going to create the mean well
this is the average
person so if we don't know what it is if
they did not get the data and the data
is missing one of the tricks is you
replace it with the average what is the
most common
data for that this way you can still use
the rest of those values to do your
computation and it kind of just brings
that particular value of those missing
values out of the equation let's go
ahead and take this and we'll go ahead
and run it it doesn't actually do
anything so we're still preparing our
data if you want to see what that looks
like we don't have anything in the first
few lines just not going to show up but
we certainly could look at a row let's
do that let's go into our data set with
printed data set and let's pick in this
case let's just do
glucose and if i run this this is going
to print all the different glucose
levels going down and we thankfully
don't see anything in here that looks
like missing data at least on the ones
it shows you can see it skipped a bunch
in the middle that's what it does if you
have too many lines in jupiter notebook
it'll skip a few and go on to the next
in a data set let me go and remove this
and we'll just zero out that and of
course before we do any processing
before proceeding any further we need to
split the data set into our train and
testing data that way we have something
to train it with and something to test
it on and you're going to notice we did
a little something here with the pandas
database code there we go my drawing
tool we've added in this right here
off the data set and what this says is
that the first one in pandas this is
from the pd pandas it's going to say
within the data set we want to look at
the eye location and it is all rows
that's what that says so we're going to
keep all the rows but we're only looking
at zero column zero to eight remember
column nine here it is right up here we
printed it in here is outcome well
that's not part of the training data
that's part of the answer yes column
nine but it's listed as 8 number 8 so 0
to 8 is 9 columns so 8 is the value and
when you see it in here 0 this is
actually 0 to 7 it doesn't include the
last one and then we go down here to y
which is our answer and we want just the
last one just column eight and you can
do it this way with this particular
notation and then if you remember we
imported the train test split that's
part of the sklearn right there and we
simply put in our x and our y we're
gonna do random state equals zero you
don't have to necessarily seat it that's
a seed number i think the default is one
when you seed it i'd have to look that
up and then the test size test size is
0.2 that simply means we're going to
take 20 percent of the data and put it
aside so that we can test it later
that's all that is and again we're going
to run it not very exciting so far we
haven't had any printout other than to
look at the data but that is a lot of
this is prepping this data once you prep
it the actual lines of code are quick
and easy and we're almost there with the
actual writing of our knn we need to go
ahead and do a scale the data if you
remember correctly we're fitting the
data in a standard scalar which means
instead of the data being from you know
5 to 303 in one column and the next
column is one to six we're going to set
that all so that all the data is between
minus one and one that's what that
standard scalar does keeps it
standardized and we only want to fit the
scalar with the training set but we want
to make sure the testing set is the x
test going in is also transformed so
it's processing it the same so here we
go with our standard scalar we're going
to call it sc underscore x for the
scalar and we're going to import the
standard scalar into this variable and
then our x train equals sc underscore x
dot fit transform so we're creating the
scalar on the x train variable and then
our x test we're also going to transform
it so
we've trained and transformed the x
train and then the x test
isn't part of that training it isn't
part of that of training the transformer
it just gets transformed that's all it
does and again we're going to run this
and if you look at this we've now gone
through these steps all three of them
we've taken care of replacing our zeros
for key
columns that shouldn't be zero and we
replace that with the means
of those columns that way that they fit
right in with our data models we've come
down here we split the data so now we
have our test data and our training data
and then we've taken and we've scaled
the data so all of our data going in no
no we don't tr we don't train the y part
the y train and y test that never has to
be trained it's only the data going in
that's what we want to train in there
then define the model using k neighbors
classifier and fit the train data in the
model so we do all that data prep and
you can see down here we're only going
to have a couple lines of code where
we're actually building our model and
training it that's one of the cool
things about python and how far we've
come it's such an exciting time to be in
machine learning because there's so many
automated tools let's see before we do
this let's do a quick length of and
let's do y we want let's just do length
of y
and we get 768 and if we import
math we do math dot square root
let's do y
train there we go it's actually supposed
to be x train
before we do this let's go ahead and do
import math and do math square root
length of y test and when i run that we
get 12.409
i want to show you where this number
comes from we're about to use 12 is an
even number so if you know if you're
ever voting on things remember the
neighbors all vote don't want to have an
even number of neighbors voting so we
want to do something odd and let's just
take one away we'll make it 11. let me
delete this out of here this one the
reasons i love jupiter notebook is you
can flip around and do all kinds of
things on the fly so we'll go ahead and
put in our classifier we're creating our
classifier now and it's going to be the
k neighbors classifier end neighbors
equal 11. remember we did 12 minus 1 for
11 so we have an odd number of neighbors
p equals 2 because we're looking for is
it are they diabetic or not and we're
using the euclidean metric there are
other means of measuring the distance
you could do like square square means
values all kinds of measure this but the
euclidean is the most common one and it
works quite well it's important to
evaluate the model let's use the
confusion matrix to do that and we're
going to use the confusion matrix
wonderful tool and then we'll jump into
the f1 score
and finally accuracy score which is
probably the most commonly used quoted
number when you go into a meeting or
something like that so let's go ahead
and paste that in there and we'll set
the cm equal to confusion matrix why
test y predict so those are the two
values we're going to put in there and
let me go ahead and run that and print
it out and the way you interpret this is
you have the y predicted which would be
your title up here you could do let's
just do p-r-e-d
predicted across the top
and actual going down actual
it's always hard to write in here actual
that means that this column here down
the middle that's the important column
and it means that our prediction said 94
and prediction in the actual agreed on
94 and 32 this number here
the 13
and the 15 those are what was wrong so
you could have like three different if
you're looking at this across three
different variables instead of just two
you'd end up with the third row down
here in the column going down the middle
so in the first case we have the the and
i believe the zero has a 94 people who
don't have diabetes the prediction said
that 13 of those people did have
diabetes and were at high risk and the
32 that had diabetes it had correct
but our prediction said another 15 out
of that 15 it classified as incorrect so
you can see where that classification
comes in and how that works on the
confusion matrix then we're going to go
ahead and print the f1 score let me just
run that
and you see we get a 0.69 in our f1
score
the f1 takes into account both sides of
the balance of false positives where if
we go ahead and just do the accuracy
account and that's what most people
think of is it looks at just how many we
got right out of how many we got wrong
so a lot of people when you're a data
scientist and you're talking to other
data scientists they're going to ask you
what the f1 score the f score is if
you're talking to
the general public or the decision
makers in the business they're going to
ask what the accuracy is and the
accuracy is always better than the f1
score but the f1 score is more telling
it lets us know that there's more false
positives than we would like on here but
82 percent not too bad for a quick flash
look at people's different statistics
and running an sk learn and running the
k n n the k nearest neighbor on it so we
have created a model using knn which can
predict whether a person will have
diabetes or not or at the very least
whether they should go get a checkup and
have their glucose checked regularly or
not the print accuracy score we got the
0.818 was pretty close to what we got
and we can pretty much round that off
and just say we have an accuracy of 80
percent tells us it is a pretty fair fit
in the model we're going to cover
mathematics for machine learning so
today's agenda is going to cover data
and its types and we're going to dive
into linear algebra and its concepts
calculus statistics for machine learning
probability for machine learning
hands-on demos
and of course thrown in there in the
middle is going to be your matrixes and
a few other things to go along with all
this
data and as types
data denotes the individual pieces of
factual information collected from
various sources it is stored processed
and later used for analysis
and so we see here uh just a huge
grouping of information a lot of tech
stuff money dollar signs numbers
uh and then you have your performing
analytics to drive insights and
hopefully you have a nice share your
shareholders gather it at the meeting
and you're able to explain it in
something they can understand
so we talk about data types of data
we have in our types of data we have a
qualitative categorical
you think nominal or ordinal and then
you have your quantitative or numerical
which is discrete or continuous
and let's look a little closer at those
data type vocabulary always people's
favorite is the vocabulary words okay
not mine
uh but let's dive into this what we mean
by nominal nominal they are used to
label various uh
label our variables without providing
any measurable value
country gender race hair color etc it's
something that you either mark true or
false this is a label it's on or off
either they have a red hat on or they do
not
so a lot of times when you're thinking
nominal data
labels
think of it as a true false kind of
setup and we look at ordinal this is
categorical data with a set order or a
scale to it
and you can think of salary range as a
great one
movie ratings etc you can see here the
salary rates if you have 10 000 to 20
000
number of employees earning that rate is
150 20 000 to 30 100 and so forth some
of the terms you'll hear is bucket uh
this is where you have 10 different
buckets and you want to separate it into
something that makes sense into those 10
buckets
and so when we start talking about
ordinal a lot of times when you get down
to the brass bones again we're talking
true false
so if you're a member of the 10 to 20 k
rains
so forth those would each be either part
of that group or you're not
but now we're talking about buckets so
we want to count how many people are in
that bucket
quantitative numerical data
falls into two classes discrete or
continuous and so data with a final set
of values which can be categorized class
strength questions answered correctly
and runs hit and cricket
a lot of times when you see this you can
think integer
and a very restricted integer i.e
you can only have 100 questions um on a
test so you can it's very discreet i
only have a hundred different values
that it can attain
so think usually you're talking about
integers but within a very small range
they don't have an open in or anything
like that
so discrete is very solid
simple to count
set number
continuous on the other hand continuous
data can take any numerical value within
a range so water pressure weight of a
person etc usually we start thinking
about float values where they can get
phenomenally small in their in what
they're worth
and there's a whole series of values
that falls right between discrete and
continuous
you can think of the stock market you
have dollar amounts it's still discrete
but it starts to get complicated enough
when you have like you know jump in the
stock market from 525.33
to
580
there's a lot of point values in there
it'd still be called discrete but you
start looking at it as almost continuous
because it does have such a variance in
it now uh we talk about no we did we
went over nominal and ordinal uh almost
true false charts and we looked at
quantitative and numerical data which
were starting to get into numbers
discrete you can usually a lot of times
discrete will be put into it could be
put into true false but usually it's not
so we want to address this stuff and the
first thing you want to look at is the
very basic which is your algebra so
we're going to take a look at linear
algebra you can remember back when your
euclidean geometry we have a line well
let's go through this we have a linear
algebra is the domain of mathematics
concerning linear equations
and the representations in vector spaces
and through matrixes i told you we're
going to talk about matrix is
so a linear equation is simply
2x plus 4y minus 3z equals 10. very
linear 10x plus 12.4y equals z and now
you can actually solve these two
equations by combining them
and this we're talking about a linear
equation
in the vectors we have a plus b equals c
now we're starting to look at a
direction
and these values usually think of an x y
z plot
so each one is a direction and the
actual
distance of like a triangle a b is c
and then your matrix can describe all
kinds of things
i find matrixes
confuse a lot of people
not because they're particularly
difficult but because of the magnitude
and the different things they're used
for
and a matrix is a chart or a
you know think of a spreadsheet but you
have your rows and your columns
and you'll see here we have a times b
equals c
very important to know your counts
so depending on how the math is being
done what you're using it for making
sure you have the same rows and number
of columns or a single number there's
all kinds of things that play in that
that can make matrixes confusing
but really it has a lot more to do with
what domain you're working in are you
adding in
multiple polynomials where you have like
uh
a x squared plus b y plus you know you
start to see that can be very confusing
versus a very straightforward matrix
and let's just go a little deeper into
these because these are such primary
this is what we're here to talk about is
these different math
mathematical computations that come up
so we're looking at linear equations
let's dig deeper into that one an
equation having a maximum order of 1 is
called a linear equation
so it's linear because when you look at
this we have uh ax plus b equals c which
is a one variable
we have two variable ax plus b y equals
c a x plus b y plus z c z equals d
and so forth but all of these
are to the power of one you don't see x
squared you don't see x cubed so we're
talking about linear equations that's
what we're talking about in their
addition if you have already dived into
say neural networks you should recognize
this ax plus by plus cz
setup plus the intercept
which is basically your your neural
network each node adding up all the
different inputs
and we can drill down into that most
common formula is your y equals mx plus
c
so you have your y
equals the m which is your slope
your x value plus c
which is your
y-intercept you kind of labeled it wrong
here
threw me for a loop but the the c would
be your y-intercept so when you set x
equal to zero y equals c and that's
that's your y-intercept right there
and that's they just had a reverse value
of y when x equals zero equals the
y-intercept which is c and your slow
gradient line which is your m so you get
your y equals two x plus three
and there's lots of easy ways to compute
this this way this is why we always
start with the most basic one when we're
solving one of these problems and then
of course the
one of the most important takeaways is
the slope gradient of the line
so the slope is very important that m
value
in this case we went ahead and solved
this
if you have y equals 2x plus 3 you can
see how it has a nice line graph here on
the right
so matrixes a matrix refers to a
rectangular representation of an array
of numbers arranged in columns and rows
so we're talking m rows by n columns
here a11 is denotes the element of the
first row in the first column similarly
a12 and it's really pronounced a11 in
this particular setup so it's a row one
column one a 12 is a
row one column two
first row and second column and so on
and there's a lot of ways to denote this
i've seen these as like a capital letter
a smaller case a for the top row or i
mean you can see where they can go all
kinds of different directions as far as
the value
you just take a moment to realize
there's need to be some designation as
far as what row it's in and what column
it's in
and we have our basic operations we have
addition so when you think about
addition you have
two matrixes of two by two and you just
add each individual
number in that matrix and then when you
get to the bottom you have in this case
the solution is 12 10 plus 2 is 12 5
plus 3 is 8 and so on
and the same thing with subtraction
now again you're counting matrixes you
want to check your
dimensions of the matrix
the shape you'll see shape come up a lot
in programming so we're talking about
dimensions we're talking about the shape
if the two shapes are equal
this is what happens when you add them
together or subtract them
and we have multiplication when you look
at the multiplication you end up with a
very a slightly different setup going
now
if we look at our last one where
we're like why
this always gets to me when we get to
matrixes they don't really say why you
multiply matrixes
you know my first thought is 1 times 2 4
times 3 but if you look at this we get 1
times 2 plus four times three
one times three plus four times five
six times two plus three times three six
times three plus three times five if
you're looking at these matrixes uh
think of this more as an equation
and so we have if you remember we move
back up here for our multiple line
equations let's just go back up a couple
slides where we were looking at a two
variable so this is a two variable
equation ax plus b y equals c
and this is a way to make it very quick
to solve these variables and that's why
you have the matrix and that's why you
do
the multiplication the way they do
and this is the dot product of 1 times
two
plus four times three
one times three plus four times five
uh six times two plus three times three
six times three plus three times 5 and
it gives us a nice little
14 23 21 and 33 over here which then can
be used and reduced down to a sample
formula as far as solving the variables
as you have enough inputs
and then in matrix operations when
you're dealing with a lot of matrixes
now keep in mind multiplying matrixes is
different than finding the product of
two matrixes okay so we're talking about
multiplication we're talking about
solving
for equations when you're finding the
product you are just finding 1 times 2.
keep that in mind because that does come
up i've had that come up a number of
times where i'm altering data and i get
confused as to what i'm doing with it
transpose flipping the matrix over is
diagonal comes up all the time where you
have you still have 12 but instead of it
being a 12 8 it's now 12 14
8 21 you're just flipping the columns
and the rows
and then of course you can do an
inverse changing the signs of the values
across this main diagonal and you can
see here we have the inverse a to the
minus 1 and ends up with
instead of 12 8 14 12 is now minus 22
minus 12.
vectors
vector just means we have
a value and a direction
and we have down four numbers here on
our vector
in mathematics a one-dimensional matrix
is called a vector
so
if you have your x plot and you have a
single value that values along the x
axis and it's a single dimension
if you have two dimensions you can think
about putting them on a graph you might
have x and you might have y and each
value denotes a direction and then of
course the actual distance is going to
be the hypothesis of that triangle
and you can do that with three
dimensionals x y and z
and you can do it all the way to nth
dimensions so when they talk about the k
means
for categorizing and how close data is
together they will compute that based on
the pythagorean theorem so you would
take
the square of each value add them all
together and find the square root and
that gives you a distance as far as
where that point is where that vector
exists or an actual point value and then
you can compare that point value
to another one it makes a very easy
comparison versus comparing 50 or 60
different numbers
and that brings us up to i gene vectors
and i gene values
i gene vectors the vectors that don't
change their span while transformation
and gene values the scalar values that
are associated to the vectors
conceptually
you can think of the vector as your
picture you have a picture it's uh
two dimensions x and y
and so when you do those two dimensions
and those two values or whatever that
value is
um
that is that point but the values change
when you skew it and so
if we take and we have a vector a
and that's a set value uh b is
your is your you have a and b which is
your hygiene vector two is the i gene
value so we're altering
all the values by two that means we're
maybe we're stretching it out one
direction making it tall if you're doing
picture editing
that's one of the places this comes in
but you can see when you're transforming
your different information how you
transform it is then your hygiene value
and you can see here vector after line
transit transition
we have 3a a is the hygiene vector 3 is
the iogene value
so a doesn't change that's whatever we
started with that's your original
picture
and three
is skewing it one direction and maybe
a b is being skewed another direction
and so you have a nice tilted picture
because you altered it by those by the
hygiene values
so let's go ahead and pull up a demo on
linear algebra and to do this i'm going
to go through my trusted anaconda into
my jupiter notebook
and we'll create a new notebook called
linear algebra since we are working in
python we're going to use our numpy i
always import that as np or numpy array
probably the most popular
module for doing matrixes and things in
given that this is part of a series i'm
not going to go too much into numpy we
are going to go ahead and create two
different variables a for a numpy array
10 15 and b 29
we'll go ahead and run this and you can
see there's our two arrays 10 15 29 and
then went and added a space there in
between
so it's easier to read
and since it's the last line we don't
have to put the print statement on it
unless you want we can simply but we can
simply do a plus b so when i run this
uh we have 10 15 29 and we get 30 24
which is what you expect 10 plus 20 15
plus 9.
you could almost look at this addition
as being
just adding up the columns on here
coming down and if we wanted to do it a
different way we could also do a dot t
plus b dot t
remember that t flips them and so if we
do that we now get them
we now have 30 24 going the other way
we could also do something kind of fun
there's a lot of different ways to do
this
as far as a plus b i can also do a plus
b
dot t
and you're going to see that that will
come out the same the 30 24 whether i
transpose a and b or transpose them both
at the end
and likewise we can very easily subtract
two vectors i can go a minus b
and we run that and we get minus 10 6.
now remember this is the last line in
this particular section that's why i
don't have to put the print around it
and just like we did before
we can transpose either the individual
or we can transpose the main set up and
then we get a minus 10 6 going the other
way
now we didn't mention this in our notes
but you can also do a scalar
multiplication
and just put down scalar so you can
remember that
uh what we're talking about here is i
have
this
array here u and if i go a
times u
we'll take the value 2 we'll multiply it
by every value in here so 2 times 30 is
60 2 times 15
and just like we did before
this happens a lot because when you're
doing matrixes you do need to flip them
you get 60 30 coming this way
so in numpy uh we have what they call
dot
product
and uh with this this in a two
dimensional vectors it is the equivalent
of two matrix multiplication remember we
were talking about matrix multiplication
uh where it is the
well let's walk through it
we'll go ahead and start by defining two
numpy arrays we'll have uh 10 20 25 6 or
our u and our v
and then we're going to go ahead and do
if we take
the values
and if you remember correctly
an array like this would be 10 times 25
plus 20 times 6.
we'll go ahead and
print that
there we go
and then we'll go ahead and do the np
dot dot
of u comma
v
and we'll find when we do this we go and
run this
we're going to get
370 370.
so this is a strain multiplication where
they use it to solve
linear algebra when you have multiple
numbers going across and so this could
be very complicated we could have a
whole string of different variables
going in here but for this we get a nice
value for our dot multiplication
and we did
addition earlier which is just your
basic addition
and of course the matrix you can get
very complicated on these or
in this case we'll go ahead and do
let's create two
complex matrixes
this one is a matrix of um you know 12
10 4 6 4 31. we'll just print out a so
you can see what that looks like here's
print
a
we print a out you can see that we have
a
two by three
layer matrix for a
and we can also put together
always kind of fun when you're playing
with print values we could do something
like this we could go in here
there we go
we could print a we have it end with
equals a
run
and this kind of gives it a nice look
here's your matrix that's all this is
comma n means it just tags it on the end
that's all all that is doing on there
and then we can simply add in what is a
plus b and you should already guess
because this is the same as what we did
before there's no difference
we do a simple vector addition we have
12 plus 2 is 14 10 plus 8 is 18 and so
on
and just like we did the
matrix addition we can also do a minus b
and do our matrix subtraction
and we look at this we have what 12
minus 2 is 10 10 minus 8 um where are we
oh there we go 8 minus
confusing what i'm looking at i should
have reprinted out the original numbers
but we can see here 12 minus 2 is of
course 10 10 minus 8 is 2
4 minus 46 is minus 42 and so forth so
same as the subtraction as before we
just call it matrix subtraction it's
identical
now if you remember up here we had a
scalar addition we're adding just one
number
to a matrix you can also do scalar
multiplication
and so simply if you have a single value
a and you have b which is your array we
can also do a times b
when we run that
you can see here we have 2 times 4 is 8.
5 times 4 is 20 and so forth you're just
multiplying the 4 across each one of
these values
and this is an interesting one that
comes up
a little bit of a brain teaser is matrix
and vector multiplication
and so we're looking at this
uh we are
just doing regular arrays it doesn't
necessarily have to be a numpy array
we have a
which has our
array of arrays and b which is a single
array and so we can from here
do the dot
a b
and this is going to return two values
and the first value is that is you could
say it's like uh
we're doing the
this array b array
first with a and then with a second one
and so it splits it up so you have a
matrix of vector multiplication and you
can mix and match
when you get into really complicated
back end stuff this becomes more common
because you're now you've got layers
upon layers of data and so you you'll
end up with a matrix and a set of bolt
vector matrices do you want to multiply
now keep in mind that if you're doing
data science a lot of times you're not
looking at this this is what's going on
behind the scenes so if you're in
the scikit looking at sk learn where
you're doing linear regression models
this is some of the math that's hidden
behind the scenes that's going on
other times you might find yourself
having to do part of this and manipulate
the data around so it fits right and
then you go back in and you run it
through the scikit and if we can do
up appear where we did a
matrix and vector multiplication we can
also do matrix two matrix multiplication
and if we run this we have the two
matrixes
you can see a very complicated array
that of course comes out on there for
our dot and just to reiterate it we have
our transpose a matrix which is your dot
t
and so if we create a matrix a and we do
transpose it you can see how it flips it
from
5 10 15 20 25 30 2 5 15 25 10 20 30
rows and columns
and certainly with the math this comes
up a lot
it also comes up a lot with x y plotting
when you put into pi plot you have one
format where they're looking at pairs
and numbers and then they want all of
x's and all y's
so you know the transpose is an
important tool both for your math and
for plotting and all kinds of things
another tool that we didn't discuss uh
is your identity matrix
uh and this one is more definition
uh the identity matrix um we have here
one where we just did
two
so it comes down as one zero zero one
one zero zero zero one zero it creates a
diagonal of one and what that is is when
you're doing your identities you could
be comparing
all your different features to the
different features and how they
correlate
and of course when you have feature one
compared to feature one to itself it is
always
one
where
usually it's between zero one depending
on how well correlates so when we're
talking about identity matrix that's
what we're talking about right here is
that you create this preset matrix and
then you might adjust these numbers
depending on what you're working with
and what the domain is
and then another thing we can do
to kind of wrap this up we'll hit you
with the most complicated uh
piece of this
puzzle here is an inverse
a matrix
and let's just go ahead and put the um
it's a lengthy description
let's go and put the description this is
straight out of the uh
the website for
numpy
so given a square matrix a here's our
square matrix a which is 2 1 0 0 1 0 1 2
1. keep in mind 3 by 3 is square it's
got to be equal it's going to return the
matrix a inverse satisfying dot a
a inverse so here's our
matrix multiplication
and then of course it equals the dot
yeah a inverse of a
with an identity shape of
a dot shaped 0. this is just reshaping
the identity
that's a little complicated there uh so
we're going to have our here's our array
uh we'll go ahead and run this
and you can see what we end up with
is we end up with uh an array 0.5 minus
0.5 and so forth with our two one one
going down two one zero zero one zero
one two one
uh
getting into a little deep on the math
understanding
when you need this is probably really is
is what's really important when you're
doing data science
versus
handwriting this out and looking up the
math and handwriting all the pieces out
you do need to know about the linear
algorithm inverse of a
so if it comes up you can easily pull it
up or at least remember where to look it
up we took a look at the algebra side of
it let's go ahead and take a look at the
calculus side of what's going on here
with the machine learning so
calculus oh my goodness and differential
equations you got to throw that in there
because that's all part of the
bag of tricks especially when you're
doing large neural networks but also
comes up in many other areas the good
news is most of it's already done for
you in the back end
so when it comes up you really do need
to understand from the data science not
data analytics data analytics means
you're digging deep into
actually solving these math equations
and a neural network is just a giant
differential equation
uh so we talk about calculus
we're going to go ahead
and understand it by talking about cars
versus time and speed
uh so it helps to calculate the
spontaneous rate of change
uh so suppose we plot a graph of the
speed of a car with respect to time so
as you can see here
going down the highway probably merged
into the highway from an on-ramp so i
had to accelerate so my speed went way
up
stuck in traffic merged into the traffic
traffic opens up and i accelerate again
up to the speed limit
and
maybe peter's off up there so you can
look at this is as
the speed versus time i'm getting faster
and faster because i'm continually
accelerating and if i hit the breaks you
go the other way
so the rate of change of speed with
respect of time is nothing but
acceleration how fast are we
accelerating
the acceleration is the area between the
star point of x and the endpoint of
delta x so we can calculate a simple
if you had x and delta x we could put a
line there and that slope of the line is
our acceleration
now that's pretty easy when you're doing
linear algebra but i don't want to know
it just for that line in those two
points i want to know what across the
whole of what i'm working with
that's where we get into calculus
so we talk about the distance between x
and delta x it has to be the smallest
possible near to zero in order to
approximate the acceleration
so the idea is instead of i mean if you
ever did took a basic calculus class
they would draw bars down here and you
would divide this area up
let's go back up the screen you divide
this area of this time period up into
maybe 10 sections and you use that and
you can calculate the acceleration
between each one of those 10 sections
kind of thing
and then we just keep making that space
smaller and smaller until delta x is
almost
infinitesimally small
and so we get a function of a
equals a limit as h goes to 0 of a
function of a plus h minus a function of
a over h and that is you're computing
the slope of the line
we're just computing that slope under
smaller and smaller and smaller samples
and that's what calculus is calculus is
the integral you can see down here we
have our nice uh integral sign looks
like a giant s
and that's what that means is that we've
taken this down to as small as we can
for that sampling
so we're talking about calculus we're
finding the area under the slope is the
main process in the integration
similar small intervals are made of the
smallest possible length of x plus delta
x where delta x approaches almost an
infinitismy small space
and then it helps to find the overall
acceleration by summing up all the links
together
so we're summing up all the
accelerations from the beginning to the
end
and so here's our integral we sum of a
of x times d of x equals a plus c
that is our basic calculus here
so when we talk about multivariate
calculus
multivariate calculus deals with
functions that have multiple variables
and you can see here we start getting
into some very complicated equations
uh change in w over change of time
equals change of w over change of z
the differential of z to dx differential
of x to dt
it gets pretty complicated uh it really
translates into the multivariate
integration using double integrals and
so you have the the sum of the sum of f
of x y of d of a equals
the sum from c to d and a to b of f of x
y d x d y equals
uh the sum of a to b sum of c to d of f
x of y d y d x
understanding the very specifics of
everything going on in here and actually
doing the math
is usually calculus 1 calculus 2 and
differential equations
so you're talking about three full
length courses to dig into
and solve these math equations
what we want to take from here is we're
talking about calculus
we're talking about summing of all these
different slopes and so we're still
solving a linear
expression we're still solving y equals
m x plus b but we're doing this for
infinitely small x's and then we want to
sum them up that's what this integral
sign means
the sum of a of x d of x equals a plus c
and when you see these very complicated
uh multivariate differentiation using
the chain rule
when we come in here and we have the
change of w to the change of t equals
the change of w dz
and so forth that's what's going on here
that's what these means we're basically
looking for the area under the curve
which really comes to
how is the change changing speeds going
up how is that changing and then you end
up with a multiple layer so if i have
three layers of neural networks how is
the third layer changing based on the
second layer changing which is based on
the first layer changing and you get the
picture here that now we have a very
complicated
multivariate integration
with integrals
the good news is we can solve this uh
mathematically and that's what we do
when you do neural networks and reverse
propagation
uh so the nice thing is that you don't
have to solve this on paper unless
you're a data analysis and you're
working on the back end of integrating
these formulas and building the script
to actually build them so we talk about
applications of calculus it provides us
the tools to build an accurate
predictive model
so it's really behind the scenes we want
to guess at what the change of the
change of the change is
that's a little goofy i i know i just
threw that out there it's kind of a meta
term but if you can guess how things are
going to change then you can guess what
the new numbers are
multivariate calculus explains the
change in our target variable in
relation to the rate of change in the
input variables
so there's our multiple variables going
in there if one variable is changing how
does it affect the other variable
and then in gradient descent calculus is
used to find the local and global maxima
and this is really big uh we're going to
actually going to have a whole section
here on gradient descent because it is
really i mean i talked about neural
networks and how you can see how the
different layers go in there but
gradient descent is one of the most key
things for trying to guess the best
answer to something
so let's take a look at the code behind
gradient descent
and before we open up the code let's
just do real quick
gradient descent
let's say we have a curve like this and
most common
is that this is going to represent your
error oops
error there we go error
ah hard to read there and i want to make
the error as low as possible
and so what i'm looking at it is i want
to find this line here
which is the minimum value so we're
looking for the minimum
and it does that by
sampling there
and then based on this it guesses it
might be someplace here and it goes hey
this is still going down
it goes here and then goes back over
here and then goes a little bit closer
and it's just playing a high low until
it gets to that spot that bottom spot
and so we want to minimize the error
and
on the flip note you could also want to
be maximizing something you want to get
the best output of it
that's simply
minus the value
so if you're looking for where the peak
is
this is the same as a negative for where
the valley is i'm looking for that
valley
that's all that is this is a way of
finding it so
the cool thing is all the heavy
lifting's done
i actually
ended up putting together one of these a
while back is when i didn't know about
sidekick and i was just starting
boys a long while back
and uh
is playing high low how do you play high
low not get stuck in the valleys uh
figure out these curves and things like
that well you do that and the back end
is all the calculus and differential
equations to calculate this out
the good news is you don't have to do
those
so instead we're going to put together
the code and let's go ahead
and see what we can do with that
so guys in the back put together a nice
little piece of code here which is kind
of fun
uh some things we're going to note and
this is this is really important stuff
because when you start doing your data
science and digging into your machine
learning models
you're going to find
these things are stumbling blocks the
first one is current x where do we start
at
keep in mind
your model that you're working with is
very generic so whatever you use to
minimize it the first question is where
do we start
and we started at this because the
algorithm starts at x equals three
so we arbitrarily picked five learning
rate is uh how many bars to skip going
one way or the other i'm in fact i'm
going to separate that a little bit
because these two are really important
if we're dealing with something like
this where we're talking about
well here's our here's the function
we're going to use our
gradient of our function
2 times x plus 5 keep it simple so
that's a function we're going to work
with so if i'm dealing with increments
of a thousand point one is going to be a
very long time and if i'm dealing with
increments of 0.001
0.1 is going to skip over my answer so i
won't get a very good answer
and then we look at precision this tells
us when to stop the algorithm so again
very specific to what you're working on
if you're working with money
and
you don't convert it into a float value
uh you might be dealing with 0.01 which
is a penny that might be your precision
you're working with
and then of course the previous step
size max iterations we want something to
cut out at a certain point usually
that's built into a lot of minimization
functions
and then here's our actual
formula we're going to be working with
and then we come in we go while previous
step size is greater than precision and
it errors is less than maximum max iters
let's say that 10 times fast um
we're just saying if it's uh if we're if
we're still greater than our precision
level we still got to keep digging
deeper
and then we also don't want to go past a
thou or whatever this is a million or
ten thousand uh running that's actually
pretty high i almost never do max
iterations more than like a hundred or
two hundred
rare occasions you might go up to four
or five hundred if it's depending on the
problem you're working with uh so we
have our previous equals our current
that way we can track time wise
uh the current now equals the current
minus the rate times the formula of our
previous x
so now we've generated our new version
uh previous step size equals the
absolute current previous
so we're looking for the change in x
errors equals iterations plus one that's
so we know to stop if we get too far
and then we're just going to print the
local minimum occurs at
x on here and if we go ahead and run
this
you can see right here it gets down to
this point and it says hey
local minimum is minus
3.3222 for this particular series we
created
this is created off of our formula here
lambda x2 times x plus 5.
now
when i'm running this stuff
you'll see this come up a lot
in
with the sk learn kit
and one of the nice reasons of breaking
this down the way we did is i could go
over those top pieces
those top pieces are everything when you
start looking at these minimization tool
kits in built-in code
and so from
we'll just do it's actually
docs
dot scipy.org
and we're looking at
the psi kit
there we go
optimize minimize
you can only minimize one value
you have the function that's going in
this function can be very complicated uh
so we used a very simple function up
here
it could be
there's all kinds of things that could
be on there and there's a number of
methods to solve this as far as how they
shrink down
and your ex not there's your there's
your start value so your function your
start value
there's all kinds of things that come in
here that you can look at which we're
not going to
optimization automatically creates
constraints bounds
some of this it does automatically but
you really the big thing i want to point
out here is you need to have a starting
point you want to start with something
that you already know is mostly the
answer
if you don't then it's going to have a
heck of a time trying to calculate it
out
or you can write your own little script
that does this and does a high low
guessing and tries to find the max value
that brings us to statistics what this
is kind of all about is figuring things
out a lot of vocabulary and statistics
ah so statistics well i guess it's all
relative it's definitely not an edel
class
uh so a bunch of stuff going on
statistics statistics concerns with the
collection organization analysis
interpretation
and
presentation of data
that is a mouthful
so we have from end to end
where does it come from is it valid what
does it mean how do we organize it
how do we analyze it then you gotta take
those analysis and interpret it into
something that people can use kind of
reduce it to understandable
and nowadays you have to be able to
present it if you can't present it then
no one else is gonna understand what the
heck you did
so we look at the terminologies
there is a lot of terminologies
depending on what domain you're working
in
so clearly if you're working in
a domain that deals with
viruses and t cells and and
how does you know where does that come
from you're studying the different
people then you can have a population
if you are working with um
mechanical gear
you know a little bit different if
you're looking for the wobbling
statistics to know when to replace a
rotor on a machine or something like
that that can be a big deal you know we
have these huge fans that turn
in our sewage processing systems and so
those fans they start to wobble and hum
and do different things that the sensors
pick up at one point do you replace them
instead of waiting for it to break in
which case it costs a lot of money
instead of replacing a bushing you're
replacing the whole fan unit
an interesting project that came up for
our city a while back
so population all objects are
measurements whose properties are being
observed
so that's your population all the
objects it's easy to see it with people
because we have our population enlarged
but in the case of the sewer fans we're
talking about the fan units that's the
population of fans that we're working
with
have a parameter a matrix that is used
to represent a population or
characteristic
you have your sample a subset of the
population studied you don't want to do
them all because then you don't have a
if you come up with a conclusion for
everyone you don't have a way of testing
it so you take a sample
sometimes you don't have a choice you
can only take a sample of what's going
on you can't
study the whole population
and a variable a metric of interest for
each person or object in a population
types of sampling
we have a probabilistic approach
selecting samples from a larger
population using a method based on the
theory of probability
and we'll go into a little bit more
deeper on these we have random
systematic stratified and then you have
a non-probabilistic approach selecting
samples based on the subjective judgment
of the researcher rather than random
selection
it has to do with convenience trying to
reach a quota um or snowball
uh and they're very biased that's one of
the reasons you'll see this big stamp
bond that says biased so you gotta be
very careful on that
so probabilistic sampling when we talk
about a random sampling we select random
size samples from each group or category
so it's as random as you can get we talk
about systematic sampling
we're selecting random size samples from
each group or category with a fixed
periodic interval
so we kind of split it up this would be
like a time set up or different
categories
and you might ask your question what is
a category or a group
if you look at i'm going to go back a
window let's say we're studying um
economics of different of an area
we know pretty much that based on their
culture where they came from
they might need to be separated and so
uh and when i say separated i don't mean
separated from their place where they
live i mean as far as the analysis we
want to look at the different groups and
make sure they're all represented
so if we had like an 80 percent uh of a
group that is uh say hispanic and or
indian and also in that same area we
have twenty percent twenty percent who
are uh let's call our expatriates they
left america and they're nice and uh
your caucasian group we might want to
sample a group that is representative of
both
so we're talking about stratified
sampling and we're talking about groups
those are the groups we're talking about
and that brings us to stratified
sampling selecting approximately equal
size samples from each group or category
this way we can actually separate the
categories
and give us an insight into the
different cultures and how that might
affect them in that area
so you can see these are very very
different kind of
depends on what you're working with
as far as your data and what you're
studying and so we can see here just a
little bit more we'd have selecting 25
employees from a company of 250
employees randomly don't care anything
about them what groups are in which
office they're in nothing
and we might be selecting one employee
from every 50 unique employees in a
company of 250 employees
and then we have selecting one employee
from every branch in the company office
so we have all the different branches
there's our group or categories by the
branch and the category could depend on
what you're studying so it has a lot of
variation on there
you see this kind of grouping and
categorizing is also used to generate a
lot of misinformation
so if you only study one group and you
say this is what it is
then everybody assumes that's what it is
for everybody and so you gotta be very
careful of that and it's very unethical
thing to kind of do
so types of statistics uh we talk about
statistics
we're going to talk about descriptive
and inferential statistics
there are so many different terms and
statistics to break it up uh so we so
we're talking about a particular
setup
so we're talking about descriptive of
inferential uh statistics
the base of the word describe
is pretty solid you're describing the
data what does it look like with
inferential statistics we're going to
take that from the small population to a
large population so if you're working
with a drug company you might look at
the data and say these people were
helped by this drug
they did 80 better as far as their
health or 80 percent better survival
rate than the people
um
who did not have the drug so we can
infer that that drug will work in the
greater populace and will help people so
that's where you get your inferential so
we are predicting how it's going to
affect the greater population
so descriptive statistics it is used to
describe the basic features of data and
form the basis of quantitative analysis
of data
so we have a measure of central
tendencies we have your mean median and
mode
and then we have a measure of spread
like your range your interquartile range
your variance and your standard
deviation
and we're going to look at all these a
little deeper here in a second but one
of them you can think of is
how the data difference
differences you know what's the max min
range all that stuff is your spread and
anything that's just a single number is
usually your central
tendencies measure of central tendencies
so we talk about the mean it is the
average of the set of values considered
what is the average outcome of whatever
is going on
and then your median
separates the higher half and the lower
half of data
so where's the center point of all your
different data points so your mean might
have some a couple really big numbers
that skew it
so that the average is much higher than
if you took those outliers out
where the median would by separating the
high from the low might give you a much
lower number you might look at and say
oh that's that's odd why is the average
so much higher than the median well it's
because you have some outliers or why is
it so much lower
and then the mode is the most frequent
appearing value
this is really interesting if you're
studying economics and how people are
doing you might find that the most
common
income like in the u.s was uh 1.24 000 a
year
where the average was closer to 80 000
and it's like wow what a difference well
there's some people have a lot of money
and so that skews that way up so the
average person is not making that kind
of money and then you look at the median
income and you're like well the median
income is a little bit closer to the
average so it does create a very
interesting way of looking at the data
again these are all
central tendencies single numbers you
can look at for the whole spread of the
data
and we look at the measure of central
tendencies the mean is the average marks
of a students in a classroom so here we
have the mean sum of the marks of the
students total number of students and as
we talked about the median uh if we have
0 through 10
and we take half the numbers and put
them on one side of the line half the
numbers on the other side of the line
we end up with 5 in the middle and then
the mode what mark was scored by most of
the students in a test
in a simple case where most people
scored like an 82 percent and got
certain problems wrong easy to figure
out
not so easy when you have different
areas where like you have like the um oh
let's go back to economy a little bit
more difficult to calculate if you have
a large group that scores that makes 30
000
and a slightly bigger group that makes
26 000. so what do you put down for the
mode
certainly there's a number of ways to
calculate that and there's actually a
different variations depending on what
you're doing
so now we're looking at a measure of
spread uh range what's the difference
between the highest and the lowest value
first thing you want to look at you know
it's we had everybody in the test score
between 60 and 100 percent somebody got
100 or maybe 60 to
90 percent it was so hard that a lot of
people could not get a hundred percent
um you have your
inter-quartile range quartiles divide a
rank ordered data set into four equal
parts
very common thing to do as part of all
the basic packages whether you're
working in
data frames with pandas whether you're
working in scala whether you're working
in r
you'll see this come up where they have
range your min your max and then it'll
have your interquartile range how does
it look like in each quarter of data
variance measures how far each number in
the set is from the mean and therefore
from every other number in the set
so you have like a how much turbulence
is going on in this data
and then the standard deviation
it is to measure the variance or the
dispersion of a set of values from the
mean and you'll usually see if i'm doing
a graph i might have the value graphed
and then based on the the error i might
graph graph the standard deviation in
the error on the graph as a background
so you can see how far off it is
so standard deviation is used a lot
so measurement of spread marks of a
student out of a hundred we have here
from 50 to 63 or 50 to 90.
so the range maximum marks minimum marks
we have 90 to 45 and the spread of that
is 45 90 minus 45. and then we have the
interquartile range using the same marks
over there you can see here where the
median is and then there's the first
quarter the second quarter and the third
quarter based on splitting it apart by
those values
and to understand the variance and
standard deviation we first need to find
out the mean
so here's our you know calculating the
average there we end up at approximately
66 for the average and then we look at
that the variance once we know the means
we can do equals the marks minus the
mean squared
why is it squared uh because one you
want to make sure it's you don't have
like if you if you're
putting all this stuff together you end
up with an error as far as one's
negative one's positive one's a little
higher one's a little lower
so you always see
the squared value and over the total
observations
and so the standard deviation equals the
square root of the variance which is
approximately 16.
and if you were looking at
a predictable model you would be looking
at the deviation based on the error how
much error does it have
and that's again
really important to know if your if your
prediction is predicting something
what's the chance of it being way off or
just a little bit off
now that we've looked at the
tools as far as some of the basics for
doing your statistics and what we're
talking about
let's go ahead and pull up a little demo
and show you what that looks like in
python code
so you can get some little hands-on here
for that let's go in back into our
jupyter notebook and python now almost
all of this you can do in numpy last
time we worked in numpy this time we're
going to go ahead and use pandas and if
you remember from pandas on here
this is basically a data frame rows
columns let's just go ahead and do a
print
df.head
and run that
and you can see we have the name jane
michael william rosie hanna sat and
their salaries on here and of course
instead of having to do all those hand
calculations and add everything together
and divide by the total we can do
something very simple on this like
use the command mean in pandas and so if
i go and do this print df
pick our column salary because we want
to find the means of that calorie
we want to find the means of that column
and we go and print this out and you can
see that the
average income on here is 71 000.
and let's just go ahead and do this
we'll go ahead and put in
means
and if we're going to do that we also
might want to find the median
and the median is
very similar
except it actually is just median we're
used to means in average it's kind of
interesting that those are they use the
two different words
uh there can be in some computation
slight differences but for the most part
the means is the average uh and then the
median
oops just put a
median here
do you have salary that way it displays
a little better we can see the median is
54
000. so the halfway mark is
significantly below the average why
because we have somebody in here who
makes 189 000.
darn you rosie for throwing off our
numbers
but that's something you'd want to
notice this is this is the difference
between these is huge and so is what is
the meaning behind that when you're
studying a populist and looking at
the different data coming in and of
course we also want to find out hey
what's the most uh common
income that people make
in this little tiny sample and so we'll
go ahead and do the mode
and you can see here with the mode uh
it's at 50 000.
so this is this is very telling that
most people are making 50 000
the middle point is at 54 000 so half
the people are making more than that
what that tells me is that if the most
common income is below the median
then
there's a few there's a scale there's a
lot of high salaries going up but
there's some really low salaries in
there
and so this trend which is very common
in statistic and when you're analyzing
the economy and different people's
income is pretty common and the bigger
difference between these is also very
important when we're studying statistics
and when you hear someone just say hey
the average income was you might start
asking questions at that point why
aren't you talking about the median
income why aren't you talking about the
mode the most common income
what are you hiding
and if you're doing these analysis you
should be looking at these saying hey
why are these discrepancies why are
these so different and of course with
any analysis it's important to find out
the minimum
and the maximum so we'll go ahead it's
just simply uh
dot min
it'll pull up your minimum and then dot
max pulls up the maximum
pretty straightforward on as far as
translating it and knowing what you're
you know what the
lowest value which your highest value is
here
which you'll use to generate like a
spread later on and real quick on no
mode note that it puts mode 0. like i
said there's a couple different ways you
can compute the mode
um although the standard one is pretty
good we can of course do the range
which is your max minus your min so now
we have a range of 149 000 between the
upper end and the lower end and you
might want to be looking at the
individual values on all of these but it
turns out there is a describe
feature in pandas
and so in pandas we can actually do df
salary describe and if we do this you
can see we have that there's seven uh
setups here's our mean
our standard deviation which we didn't
compute yet which would just be a dot
std
and you gotta be a little careful
because when it computes it it looks for
axes and things like that
we have our minimum value and here's our
quartiles
our maximum value and then of course the
name salary
so these are these are the basic
statistics you can pull them up and like
just describe
this is a dictionary so i could actually
do something like
in here i could actually go
count
and run
and now it just prints the count
uh so because this is a dictionary you
can pull any one of these values out of
here it's kind of a quick and dirty way
to pull all the different information
and then split it up and depending on
what you need
now if i just walked in and gave you
this information um in a meeting
at some point you would just kind of
fall asleep
that's what i would do anyway
um so we want to go ahead and see about
graphing it here and we'll go ahead and
put it into a histogram and plot that
graph on it
of the salaries and let's just go ahead
and put that in here so
we do our matplot inline remember that's
a jupiter's notebook thing a lot of the
new version of the matplot library does
it automatically
but just in case i always put it in
there import map plot library piplot is
plt that's my plotting
and then we have our data frame i don't
i guess i really don't need to respell
the data frame maybe we could just
remind ourselves what's in it so we'll
go ahead and just
print
df
that way we still have it
and then we have our salary df salary
salary.plot history title salary
distribution color gray
plot ax v line salary the mean value so
we're going to take the mean value
color violet
line style dash this is just all making
it pretty
what color dashed line
line width of 2 that kind of thing
and the median and let's go ahead and
run this just so you can see what we're
talking about
and so up here we are taking on our plot
so here's the data here's our our data
frame print it out so you can see it
with the salaries we'll look at the
salary distribution and just look at
this the way the salary is distributed
um
you have our
in this case we did
let's see we had red for the median
we have violet
for our average or mean
and you can just see how it really
i mean here's our outlier here's our
person who makes a lot of money here's
the average and here's the median
and so as you look at this you can say
wow
based on the average it really doesn't
tell you much about what people are
really taking home all it does is tell
you
how much money is in this you know what
the average salary is
so
some of the things you want to take away
in addition to this is that it's very
easy to plot
an ax v line
these are these up and down lines for
your markers
um
and as you just display the data i mean
you can add all kinds of things to this
and get really complicated keeping it
simple is pretty straightforward i look
at this and i can see we have a major
outlier out here we can definitely do a
histogram and stuff like that
but you know pictures worth a thousand
words what you really want to make sure
you take away is that we can do a basic
describe
which pulls all this information out and
we can print any of the individual
information from the describe because
this is a dictionary
and so if we want to go ahead and look
up
the mean value we can also do describe
mean so if you're doing a lot of
statistics
being able to
it doesn't have the print on there so
it's only going to print the last one
which happens to be the mean
uh you can very easily reference any one
of these and then you can also if you're
doing something a little bit more
complicated and you don't need just the
basics you can come through and pull any
one of the individual
references from the from the pandas on
here so now we've had a chance to
describe our data
let's get into inferential statistics
inferential statistics allows you to
make predictions or inferences from data
and you can see here we have a nice
little picture movie ratings and
if we took this group of people and said
hey how many people like the movie
dislike it can't say and then you ask
just a random person who comes out of
the movie who hasn't been in this study
uh you can infer that 55 chance of
saying liked
35 chance of saying disliked or a 10 or
11 percent chance of can't say so that's
real basics of what we're talking about
is you're going to infer that the next
person is going to follow these
statistics
uh so let's look at point estimation uh
it is a process of finding an
approximate value for a population's
parameter like mean
or average from random samples of the
population
let's take an example of testing
vaccines for covid19
vaccines and flu bugs all that it's a
pretty big thing of how do you test
these out and make sure they're going to
work on the populace
a group of people are chosen from the
population medical trials are performed
results are generalized for the whole
population
so here's our protected there's our
small group up here where we've selected
them we run medical trials on them and
then the results work for the population
nice diagram with the arrows going back
and forth and the very scary coveted
virus in the middle of one
and let's take a look at the
applications of inferential statistics
very central is what they call
hypotheses testing
and the confidence interval which go
with that and then as we get into
probability we get into our binomial
theorem our normal distribution in
central limit theorem
hypothesis testing hypothesis testing is
used to measure the plausibility of a
hypothesis
assumption by using sample data
now
when we talk about theorems
theory
hypothesis
keep in mind that if you are in a
philosophy class
theory
is the same as hypothesis where theorem
is a scientific uh statement that is
something that has been proven
although it is always up for debate
because in science we always want to
make sure things are up to debate so
hypothesis is the same as a
philosophical class calling a theory
where theory in science is not the same
theory in science says this has been
well proven gravity is a theory so if
you want to debate the theory of gravity
try jumping up and down if you want to
have a theory about why the economy is
collapsing in your area
that is a philosophical debate
very important i've heard people mix
those up and it is a pet peeve of mine
when we talk about hypotheses testing
the steps involved in hypotheses testing
is first we formulate a hypothesis
we figure out the right test to test our
hypothesis we execute the test and we
make a decision and so when you're
talking about hypothesis you're usually
trying to disprove it if you can't
disprove it
and it works for all the facts then you
might call that a theorem at some point
so in a use case let's consider an
example we have four students we're
given a task to clean a room every day
sounds like working with my kids they
decided to distribute the job of
cleaning the room among themselves they
did so by making four chits which has
their names on it and the name that gets
picked up has to do the cleaning for
that day
rob took the opportunity to make chits
and wrote everyone's name on it so
here's our four people nick rob emilia
emilia and summer
now rick emilia and summer are asking us
to decide whether rob has done some
mischief in preparing the chits i.e
whether rob has written his name on one
of the chit
for that we will find out the
probability of rob getting the cleaning
job on first day second day third day
and so on till 12 days
the probability of rob getting the job
decreases every day ie his turn never
comes up then definitely he has done
some mischief while making the chits
so the probability of rob not doing work
on day one is three out of four there's
a 0.75 chance that he didn't do work
two days three-fourths times three
fourths equals point five six
three days you have three-fourths
three-fourths three-fourths which equals
0.42
when you get to day 12 it's 0.032 which
is less than 0.05
remember this .05 that comes up a lot
when we're talking about
certain values when we're looking at
statistics
rob is cheating as he wasn't chosen for
12 consecutive days that's a very high
probability when
on day 12 he still hasn't gotten the job
cleaning the room
so we come up to our important important
terminologies
we have null hypothesis
a general statement that states that
there is no relationship between two
measured phenomena or no association
among the groups
alternative hypothesis
contrary to the null hypothesis it
states whenever something is happening a
new theory is preferred instead of an
old one and so the two hypotheses go
hand in hand
so your null this is always interesting
in and when talking about data science
and the math behind it
it's about proving that the things have
no correlation null hypothesis says
these two have zero relation to each
other where the alternative hypothesis
says hey we found a relation this is
what it is
we have p-value the p-value is a
probability of finding the observed or
more extreme results when the null
hypothesis of a study question is true
and the t-value it is simply the
calculated difference represented in
units of standard error the greater the
magnitude of t the greater the evidence
against the null hypothesis and you can
look at the t values being specific to
the test you're doing
where the p value is derived from your t
value and you're looking for what they
call the five percent or the 0.05
showing that it has a high correlation
so digging in deeper let's assume that a
new drug is developed with the goal of
lowering the blood pressure more than
the existing drug
and this is a good one because the null
value here isn't that you don't have any
drug the null value here is that it's
better than the existing drug the new
drug doesn't lower the blood pressure
more than the existing drug
now if we get that
that says our null hypothesis is correct
there is no correlation and the new drug
is not doing its job the alternative
hypothesis the new drug does
significantly lower the blood pressure
more than the existing drug
yay we got a new drug out there and
that's our alternative hypothesis or the
h1 or ha
and we look at the p-value results from
the evidence like medical trials showing
positive results which will reject the
null hypothesis
and again they're looking for
a 0.05 or 5 percent and the t value
comparing all the positive test results
and finding means of different samples
in order to test hypothesis so this is
specific to the test how what percentage
of increase did they have
and this leads us to the confidence
intervals
a confidence interval is a range of
values we are sure our true values of
observations lie in
let's say you asked a dog owner around
you and asked them how many cans of food
do you buy for your per year for your
dog
through calculations you got to know
that the on an average around 95 percent
of the people bought around 200 to 300
cans of food hence we can say that we
have a confidence interval of 2 300
where 95 of our values lie in that
spread data spread
uh and this the graph really helps a lot
so you can start seeing what you're
looking at here where you have the 95
percent you have your peak in this case
it's a normal distribution so you have a
nice bell curve equal on both sides it's
not asymmetrical and 95 of all the
values lie within a very small range and
then you have your outliers the 2.5
percent going each way
so we touched upon hypothesis uh we're
going to move into probability uh so you
have your hypothesis once you've
generated your hypothesis we want to
know the probability of something
occurring probability is a measure of
the likelihood of an event to occur any
event can be predicted with total
certainty
and can only be predicted as a
likelihood of its occurrence so any
event cannot be predicted with total
certainty can only be predicted as a
likelihood of its occurrence
uh score prediction how good you're
going to do in whatever
sport you're in weather prediction stock
prediction
if you've studied physics and chaos
theory even the location of the chair
you're sitting on has a probability that
it might move three feet over
granted that probability is one in like
uh uh i think we calculated as under one
in trillions upon trillions so it's
the better the probability the more
likely it's going to happen there are
some things that have such a low
probability
that we don't see them
so we talk about random variable a
random variable is a variable whose
possible values are numerical outcomes
of a random phenomena so
we have the coin tossed how many heads
will occur in the series of 20 coin
flips
probably you know the on average they're
10 but you really can't know because
it's very random
how many times a red ball is picked from
a bag of balls if there's equal number
of of red balls and blue balls and green
balls in there how many times the sum of
digits on two dice uh results are five
each
um
so you know there's how often you're
gonna roll two fives on your pair of
dice
so in a use case uh let's consider the
example of rolling two dice we have a
random variable outcome equals y you can
take values two three four five six
seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
so we have a random variable and a
combination of dice
and instead of looking at how many times
both dice for row five let's go ahead
and look at a total sum of five and you
have in as far as your random variables
you can have a one four equals five four
one two three three two
so four of those rolls can be four if
you look at all the different options
you have four of those random rolls can
be a five
and if we look at the total number
which happens to be 36 different options
uh you can see that we have four out of
36 chance every time you roll the dice
that you're going to roll a total of
five you can have an outcome of five
and uh we'll look a little deeper as to
what that means but you could think of
that at what point if someone never
rolls a five or they always roll a five
can you say hey that person's probably
cheating
we'll look a little closer at the math
behind that but let's just consider this
is one of the cases is rolling two dice
and gambling
there's also a binomial distribution is
the probability of getting success or
failure as an outcome in an experiment
or trial that is repeated multiple times
and the key is is by meaning two
binomial so passing or failing an exam
winning or losing a game and getting
either head or tails so if you ever see
binomial distribution it's based on a
true false kind of setup you win or lose
let's consider a use case
and let's consider the game of football
between two clubs
barcelona and dortmund the teams will
have to play a total of four matches and
we have to find out the chances of
barcelona winning the series
so we look at the total games and we're
looking at five different games or
matches
let's say that the winning chance for
barcelona is 75
or 0.75 that means that each game they
have a 75 chance that they're going to
win that game and losing chances are 25
or 0.25
clearly 0.75 plus 0.25 equals 1. so that
accounts for 100 of the game probability
for getting k wins in in matches is
calculated
and we we're talking like so if you have
five games and you want to know if i
play
how many wins in those five games should
i get what's a percentage on those and
the probability
for getting k wins and in matches is
calculated by p x equals k equals n c k
p to the k q to the n minus k
here p is the probability of success and
q is the probability of failure and so
we can do total games of n equals 5
where k equals 0 1 2 3 4 5.
p which is the chance of winning is 0.75
q the chance of losing equals 1 minus p
which equals 1 minus 0.075 which equals
0.25 the probability that barcelona will
lose all of the matches can then just
plug in the numbers
and we end up with a point 0
0
so very small chance they're going to
lose all their matches
and we can plug in the value for two
matches probability that barcelona will
win at least two matches
is
.0878 and of course we can go on to the
probability that barcelona will win
three matches the 0.26 and of course
four matches and so on and it's always
nice to take this information um and
let's find the accumulated discrete
probabilities for each of the outcomes
where barcelona has won three or more
matches x equals three x equals four x
equals five
and we end up with the p equals 0.264
plus 0.395 plus 237 which equals 0.89
in reality
the probability of barcelona winning the
series is much higher than 0.75
and it's always nice to
put out a nice graph so you can actually
see the number of wins to the
probability and how that pans out with
our binomial case
continuing in our important terminology
location the location of the center of
the graph depends on the mean value and
this is some very important things so
much of the data we look at and when you
start looking at probabilities almost
always has a normalized look like the
graph in the middle
but you do have left skewed where the
data is skewed off to the left and you
have more stuff happening off to the
left and you have right skewed data
and so when this comes up and these
probabilities come up where they're
skewed it's really important to take a
closer look at that
mostly you end up with a normalized set
of data but you've got to also be aware
that sometimes it's a skewed data
and then the height height of the slope
inversely depends upon the standard
deviation
so you can see down here the standard
deviation is really large it kind of
squishes it out and if the standard
deviation is small then most of your
data is going to hit right there in the
middle you can have a nice peak
and so being aware of this that you
might have a probability that fits
certain data but it has a lot of
outliers so you're if you have a really
high standard deviation
um if you're doing stock market analysis
this means your predictions are probably
not going to make you much money uh
where if you have a very small deviation
you might be right on target and set to
become a millionaire which leads us to
the z-score z-score tells you how far
from the mean a data point is it is
measured in terms of standard deviations
from the mean around 68 of the results
are found between one standard deviation
around 95 percent of the results are
found between two standard deviations
and you read the symbols of course they
love to throw some greek letters in
there we have mu minus two sigma
mu is just a quick way it's a kind of
funky u it just means the mean
uh and then the sigma is the standard
deviation and that's the o with the
little arrow off to the right or the
little
wagy tail going up the o with it with
the line on it so mu minus 2 sigma
is your
95 percent of the results are found
between two standard deviations
central limit theorem
this goes back to the skew if you
remember we were looking at the skew
values on this previous slide have left
skewed normalized and right skewed when
we're talking about it being skewed or
not skewed the distribution of the
sample means will be approximately
normally distributed evenly distributed
not skewed if you take large random
samples from the population with the
mean mu and the standard deviation sigma
with replacement
and you can see here of course we have
our
mu minus two sigma and the spread down
here the mean the median and the mode
and so when you're talking about very
large populations
these numbers should come together and
you shouldn't have a skewed value if you
do that's a flag that something's wrong
that's why this is so important to be
aware of what's going on with your data
where your samples are coming from
and the math behind it
and if we're going to do all this we've
got to jump into conditional probability
the conditional probability of an event
a is the probability that the event will
occur
given the knowledge that an event b has
already occurred and you'll see this as
bayes theorem b-a-y-e-s base
and this is red
i mean you have these funky looking
little
p
brackets a b
this is the probability of a being true
while b is already true and you have the
probability of b being true when a is
already true so p b of a
probability of a being true divided by
the probability of b being true
and we talk about bayes theorem which
occurred back in the 1800s when he
discovered this this is such an
important formula and it's really it's
not if you actually do the math you
could just kind of do
x y equals j k and then you divide them
out and you're going to see the same
math but it works with probabilities
which makes it really nice
and so if you have a set you might have
uh eight or nine different studies going
on
in different areas different people have
done the studies they brought them
together
if we look at today's covered virus the
virus spread
certainly the studies done in china
versus the studies the way they're done
in the u.s
that data is different in each of those
studies but if you can find a place
where it overlaps
where they're studying the same thing
together you can then compute the
changes that you need to make in one
study to make them equal
and this is also true if you have a
study of
one group and you want to find out more
about it so this formula is very
powerful and it really has to do with
the data collection part of the math and
data science and understanding where
your data is coming from and how you're
going to combine different studies in
different groups
and we're going to go into a use case
let's find out the chance of a person
getting lung disease due to smoking
and this is kind of interesting the way
they word this
let's say that according to medical
report provided by the hospital states
that around 10 percent of all patients
they treated suffered lung disease
so we have kind of a generic medical
report
they further found out
by a survey that 15 of the patients that
visit them smoke
so we have ten percent that are lung
disease and um fifteen percent of the
patients smoke and finally five percent
of the people continued smoke even when
they had lung disease not the brightest
choice
but you know it is an addiction so it
can be really difficult to kick and so
we can look at the probability of a
prior probability of 10 people having
lung disease
and then probability b probability that
a patient smokes is 15 percent
uh and the probability of b
um if b then a the probability of a
patient smokes even though they have
lung disease is five percent
and probability of a is b probability
that the patient will have lung disease
if they smoke and then when you put the
formulas together uh you get a nice
solution here you get the probability of
a b probability that the patient will
have lung disease if they smoke
and you can just plug the numbers right
in and we get a 3.33 percent chance
hence there is a 3.33 chance that a
person who smokes will get a lung
disease
so we're gonna pull up a little python
code i'm always my favorite roll up the
sleeves
keep in mind we're going to be doing
this um kind of like the back end way
so that you can see what's going on and
then later on we're going to create
we'll get into another demo which shows
you some of the tools are already
pre-built for this
let's start by creating a set so we're
going to create a set with curly braces
this means that our set has
only unique values so you have a list
uh you have your tuples which can never
change and then you have
in this case the the set so 4 7 you
can't create a four seven comma four
it'll delete the four outs it's only
unique values
and if you use dictionaries
quick reminder this should look familiar
because it is a dictionary we have a
value and that value is assigned to or
that key is assigned to a value
so you could have a key value set up as
a dictionary so it's like a dictionary
without the value it's just the keys and
they all have to be unique
and if we run this we have a
set of four seven
we can also take a list a regular
setup and i'm going to go ahead and just
throw in another number in here four
and run it
and you can see here if i take my list
one two three four four
and i convert it to a set and here it is
my set from list equals set my list
the result is one two three four so it
just deletes that last four right out of
there
and with the sets you can also go in
there and
print here is my set my set
uh three is in the set and then if you
do three in my set
that's going to be a logic function
and one in my set 6 is not in the set
and so forth if we run this
we get 3 is in the set true one is in
the set false because 357 is another one
six is in the set uh six is not in the
set so not in my set
you can also use this with the list we
could have just used three five seven
and it would have um the same response
on there is three and
usually you do if three is in but three
in my set is still works on just a
regular list
and we'll go ahead and do a little
iteration we're going to do kind of the
dice one remember um one two three four
five six and so we're going to bring in
the iteration tool and import product as
product
and i'll show you what that means in
just a second so we have our two dice we
have dice a and it's going to be a set
of values
they can only have one value for each
one that's why they put it in a set
and if you remember from range it is up
to seven so this is going to be one two
three four five six it will not include
the 7. and the same thing for our dice b
and then we're going to do is we're
going to create a list
which is the product
of a and b so what's a plus b
and if we go ahead and run this it'll
print that out and you'll see
in this case when they say product
because it's an iteration tool
we're talking about creating a tuple of
the two
so we've now created a tuple of all
possible outcomes of the dice where dice
a is one two three one to six and dice b
is one to six and you can see one to one
one to two one to three and so forth
you remember we had a slide on this
earlier where we talked about
the different all the different outcomes
of a dice
we can play around with this a little
bit uh we can do in dice equals two
dice faces one two three four five six
uh another way of doing what we did
before and then we can create an event
space where we have a set which is the
product of the dice faces
repeat equals indice and we'll go ahead
and just run this
and you can see here it just again puts
it through all the different possible
variables we can have
and then if we wanted to take the same
set on here and print them all out like
we had before
we can just go through for outcome and
event space outcome and equals
so the event space is creating
a sequence and as you can see here when
we print it out it stacks them versus
going through and putting them in a nice
line
and we'll go ahead and do something
let's go print since we have the end
printing with a comma that just means
it's just gonna
it's not gonna hit the return going down
to the next line
uh and we'll go ahead and do the length
of our event space uh that'll be an
important variable we're going to want
to know in a minute
and of course if i get carried away with
my typing of length uh we'll print it
twice and it'll give me an error
so we have 36 different possible
variations here
and we might want to calculate something
like
what about the multiple of 3 what if we
want to have
the probability of the multiple of 3 in
our setup
and so we can put together the code for
the outcome and event space of x y
equals outcome
if x plus y
remainder 3. so we're going to divide by
3 and look at the remainder and it
equals 0
then it's a favorable outcome we're
going to pop that outcome on the end
there
and we'll turn it into a set so the
favor outcome equals a set not necessary
because we know it's not going to be
repeating itself but just in case we'll
go ahead and do that
and if we want to print out the outcome
we can go ahead and see what that looks
like and you can see here these are all
multiples of 3 1 plus 2 is 3 5 plus 4 is
9 which divided by 3 is 3 and so forth
and just like we looked up the length of
the one before let's go ahead and print
the length
of our f outcome
so we can see what that looks like
there we go
and of course i did forget to add the
print in the middle because we're
looping through and putting an end on
the on the setup on there so we're going
to put the print in there and if i run
this you can see
we end up with 12. so we have 36 total
options
we have 12 that are multiple that add up
to a multiple of 3
and we can easily conv compute the
probability of this
by simply taking the length
of our favorable outcome over the length
of the event space
and if we print it out let me put that
in there
probability
last lines we just type it in we end up
with a 0.3333 chance
that's roughly a third
and we might want to make this look nice
so let's go ahead and put in another
line there the probability of getting
the sum which is a multiple of 3
is 0.3333
we can compute the same thing for five
dice
and if we do this for five dice and go
and run it uh you can see we just have a
huge amount of choices
so it just goes on and on down here and
we can look at
the
length of the event space
and we have over 7
76
choices that's a lot of choices
and if we want to ask the question like
we did above uh
what is the sum where the sum is a
multiple of five but not a multiple of
three
we can go through all of these different
options and then
you can see here
d1 d2 d3 d4 d5 equals the outcome
and if you add these all together and
the
division by five does not have a
remainder of zero
but the remainder is also of a division
by three is not equal to zero
so the multiple of five is equal to zero
but the multiple three is not
we can just depend that on here and then
we can look at that uh favorable outcome
we'll go ahead and set that and we'll
just take a look at this what's our
length
of our favorable outcome
it's always good to see what we're
working with and so we have 904 out of
776
and then of course we can just do a
simple division to get the probability
on here what's the probability that
we're going to roll
a multiple of 5 when you add them
together
but not a multiple of 3.
and so we're just going to divide those
two numbers and you can see here we get
point one one six two five five or
eleven point six two percent
and so you can really have a nice visual
that this is not really complicated math
right here on probabilities
it's just how many options do you have
and how many of those are you possibly
going to be able to come up with with
the solution you're looking for
and this leads us to a confusion matrix
a confusion matrix is a table which is
used to describe the performance of a
classification model on a set of test
data for which the true values are known
and so you'll see in the left we have
the predicted
and the actual
and we have a negative
false negative positive true positive
and then we have false positive and true
negative and you can think of this as
your predicted model what does that mean
that means if you divided your data and
you used two-third of this to create the
model
you might then test it against an actual
case for the last third to see how well
it comes out how many times was it
true positive versus
false positive you get a false positive
response
and you can imagine in medical
situations this is a pretty big deal you
don't want to give a false positive so
you might adjust your model accordingly
so you don't have a false positive say
with a covet virus test it'd be better
to have a false negative and they go
back and get retested than to have 30
percent false positives where then the
test is pretty much invalid
so in a use case like cancer prediction
let's consider an example where a cancer
prediction model is put to the test for
its accuracy and precision
actual result of a person's medical
report is compared with the prediction
made by the machine learning model
and so you can see here here's our
actual predicted uh whether they have
cancer or not you know cancer a big one
you don't want to have a
false positive i mean a false negative
in other words you don't want to have it
tell you that you don't have cancer when
you do so that would be something you'd
really be looking for in this particular
domain you don't want a false negative
and this is again you know you've
created a model you have hundreds of
people or thousands of pieces of data
that come in
there's a real famous case study where
they have the imagery and all the
measurements they take and there's about
36 different measurements they take
and then if you run the a basic model
you want to know just how accurate it is
how many negative results do you have
that are either telling people they have
cancer that don't or telling people that
don't have cancer that they do and then
we can take these numbers and we can
feed them into our accuracy our
precision and our recall
so accuracy precision and recall
accuracy metric to measure how
accurately the results are predicted
and this is your
total
true where you got the right results you
add them together the true positive the
two negative
over all the results so what percentage
of them were accurate versus what were
wrong
we talked about precision is a metric to
measure how many of the correctly
predicted cases are actually turned out
to be positive
so we have a precision on
true positive
again if you're talking about like uh
covet testing with the viruses uh you
really want this to be a high number you
want this true that to be the center
point where you might have the opposite
if you're dealing with a cancer where
you want no false negatives
so this is your metric on here precision
is your test positive
true positive plus
false positive
and then your recall how many of the
actual positive cases we were able to
predict quickly with our model
so test positive is the test positive
plus the
false negative on there and we'll want
to go ahead and do a demo on the naive
bayes classifier before i get too far
into a naive bayes classifier because
we're going to pull it from the sk learn
or the scikit
let's go ahead kind of an interesting
page here for classifiers when you go
into the sk learn kit there's a lot of
ways to do classification and i'll just
zoom up in here so you can see some of
the titles
there's everything from the nearest
neighbor linear
but we're going to be focusing on the
naive bayes over here
and this is just a sample data set that
they put together and you can see how
some of these have a very different
output
the naive bayes remember is set up as
probably the most simplified
calculator or set of predictions out
there
and so what we've been talking about
with the true false and stuff like that
where there's a
and then a belief that there is a
independent assumption between the
features where the features are very
assumed to have some kind of connection
then we can go ahead and use that for
the prediction and so that's what we're
using is a naive bayes classifier versus
many of the other classifiers that are
out there
for this we're going to use uh the
social network ads it's a little data
set on here
and let me go and just open that up
the file
here we go it has user id gender age
estimated salary
purchased
and so we have you can see the user id
mail 19
estimated salary 19 000
and purchased zero
so it's either going to make a purchase
or not
so look at that last one zero one we
should be thinking of binomials we
should be thinking of a simple naive
bayes classifier kind of setup
so if we close this out we're going to
go ahead and import our numpy as np
we're going to nice to have a good
visual of our data so we'll put in our
matplot library
here's our pandas our data frame
and then we're going to go ahead and
import the data set and the data set's
going to be we're going to read it from
the social network ads dot csv
then we're going to print the head just
so you can see it again
even though i showed you it in the file
and x equals the data set i location
two three values and y is going to be
the four uh column four let me just run
this it's a little easier to go over
that um you can see right here we're
going to be looking at uh zero one two
is age
and estimated salary so 2 3
and that's what i location just means
that we're
looking at the number versus a regular
location a regular location you'd
actually say age and estimated salary
and then column four is did they make a
purchase they purchased something
uh so those are the three columns we're
going to be looking at when we do this
and we've gone ahead and imported these
and
imported the data so now our data set is
all set with this information in it
and we'll need to go ahead and split the
data up uh so we need our from the
sklearn model selection we can import
train test split
this does a nice job we can set the
random state so randomly picks the data
and we're just going to take 25 percent
of it's going to go into the test our x
test and our y test and the 75 will go
to x train and y train
that way once we
create our model we can then have data
to see just how accurate or how well it
has performed with our prediction
the next step in pre-processing our data
is to go ahead and do feature scaling
now a lot of this to start to look
familiar if you've done a number of the
other modules and setup you should start
noticing that we
bring in our data we take a look at what
we're working with
we go ahead and split it up into
training and testing
in this case we're going to go ahead and
scale it scale it means we're putting it
between a value of minus one and one
uh or someplace in the middle ground
there
this way if you have any huge set you
don't have this huge
setup if we go back up to here where
salary the salary is
20 000 versus age 35.
well there's a good chance with a lot of
the back end math that 20 000 will skew
the results and the estimated salary
will have a higher impact in the age
instead of balancing them out and
letting the calculations weigh them
properly
and finally we get to actually create
our naive bayes model
and then we're going to go ahead and
import the gaussian naive bayes
and the gaussian is is the most basic
one that's what we're looking at now it
turns out though if you go to the sk
learn kit
they have a number of different ones you
can pull in there there's a
bernoulli i know i've never used that
one categorical
complement and here's our gaussian
so there's a number of different options
you can look at
gaussian when you come to the naive
bayes is the most commonly used
so we're talking about the naive bayes
that's usually what people are talking
about when they when they're pulling
this in
and one of the nice things about the
gaussian if you go to their website to
sk learn the naive bayes gaussian
there's a lot of cool features one of
them is you can do partial fit on here
that means if you have a huge amount of
data you don't have to process it all i
want you once you can batch it into the
gaussian nb model and there's many other
different things you can do with it as
far as fitting the data and how you
manipulate it
we're just doing the basics so we're
going to go ahead and create our
classifier we're going to equal the
gaussian in b
and then we're going to do a fit we're
going to fit our training data and our
training solution so x train y train
and we'll go ahead and run this and it's
going to tell us that it ran the code
right there
and now we have our trained classifier
model
so the next step is we need to go ahead
and run a prediction we're going to do
our y predict equals the
classifier.predict
x test
so here we fit the data and now we're
going to go ahead and predict
and now we get to our confusion matrix
so from
the sk learn matrix metrics you can
import your confusion matrix
just as saves you from doing all the
simple math that does it all for you
and then we'll go ahead and create our
confusion metrics with the y test and
the y predict so we have our actual
and we have our predicted value
and you can see from here this is the
chart we looked at here's predicted so
true positive false positive false
negative true negative
and if we go ahead and run this there we
have it 65 3 7 25.
and in this particular prediction we had
65 or predicted the truth as far as a
purchase they're going to make a
purchase and we guessed three wrong
and then we had 25 we predicted would
not purchase and seven of them did so
there's our our confusion matrix
at this point if you were with your
shareholders or a board meeting
you would start to hear some snoozing if
they were looking at the numbers and you
say hey here's my confusion
matrix
so let's go ahead and visualize the
results
we're going to pull from the matplot
library colors import listed color map
and this is actually my machine's going
to throw an error because
this is being
because of the way the setup is i have a
newer version on here than when they put
together the demo
and we need our x set and our y set
which is our x train and y train
and then we'll create our x1 x2
and we'll put that into a grid
and we set our x set minimum stop and
our x at max stop
and if you come all the way over here
we're going to step .01 this is going to
give us a nice line
is what that's doing and then we're
going to plot the contour
plot the x limit plot the y limit
and put the scatter plot in there let's
go ahead and run this
to be honest when i'm doing these graphs
there's so many different ways to do
that there's so many different ways to
put this code together
to show you what we're doing it's a lot
easier to pull up the graph and then go
back up and explain it
so the first thing we want to note here
when we're looking at the data
is this is the training set
and so we have those who didn't make a
purchase we've drawn a nice area for
that
that's defined by the naive bayes setup
and then we have those who did make a
purchase the green and you can see that
some of the green drops fall into the
red area and some of the red dots fall
into the green
so even our training set isn't going to
be a hundred percent uh we couldn't do
that
and so we're looking at our different
data coming down
uh we can kind of arrange our x1 x2 so
we have a nice plot going on and we're
going to create the
contour
that's that nice line that's drawn down
the middle on here with the red green
that's where that's what this is doing
right here with the reshape and notice
that we had to
do the dot t if you remember from numpy
if you did the numpy module
you end up with pairs you know x
x1 x2 x1 x2 next row and so forth you
have to flip it so it's all one row you
have all your x1s and all your x2s
so that's what we're kind of looking for
right here on this setup
uh and then the scatter plot is of
course
your scattered data across there we're
just going through all the points that
puts these nice little dots on to our
setup on here and we have our estimated
salary and our h and then of course the
dots are did they make a purchase or not
and just a quick note this is kind of
funny you can see up here where it says
x set y set equals x-train y-train which
seems kind of a little weird to do
this is because this is probably
originally a definition
so it was its own module that could be
called over and over again
and which is really a good way to do it
because the next thing we're going to
want to do is do the exact same thing
but we're going to visualize the test
set results
that way we can see what happened with
our test group our 25
and you can see down here we have the
test set uh and it
if you look at the two
graphs next to each other this one
obviously has um
75 percent of the data so it's going to
show a lot more
this is only 25 of the data you can see
that there's a number that are kind of
on the edge as to whether they could
guess by age and income they're going to
make a purchase or not
but that said it still is pretty clear
it's pretty good as far as how much the
estimate is and how good it does
now graphs are really effective
for showing people what's going on but
you also need to have the numbers and so
we're going to do from sklearn we're
going to import metrics
and then we're going to print our
metrics classification port from the y
test and the y predict
and you can see here we have precision
precision of zeros is 90 there's our
recall
0.96 we have an f1 score and a support
and we have our precision the recall on
getting it right
and then we can do our accuracy the
macro average and the weighted average
so you can see it it pulls in
pretty good as far as how accurate it is
you could say it's going to be about 90
percent who's going to guess correctly
um
that it that they're not going to
purchase and we had an 89 chance that
they are going to purchase
and then the other numbers as you get
down
have a little bit different meaning but
it's pretty straightforward on here
here's our accuracy
and here's our micro average and the
weighted average and everything else you
might need and if you forgot the exact
definition of accuracy it is the
true positive true negative over all of
the different setups
precision is your true positive overall
positives true and false
and recall is a true positive over true
positive plus false negative
and we can just real quick flip back
there
so you can see those numbers on here uh
here's our precision here's our recall
and here's our accuracy on this what's
in it for you we're going to go over
applications of deep learning what is
deep learning why is deep learning
important what are neural networks the
activation function in our neural
network the cost function that comes in
for processing our neural networks how
do neural networks work
deep learning platforms
and then we'll do introduction to
tensorflow and a use case implementation
using tensorflow so you can see how it
works and gets them hands-on so start
off with the applications of deep
learning deep learning helps us make
predictions about the rain earthquakes
tsunamis etc allowing us to take the
required precautions with deep learning
machines can comprehend speech and
provide the required output deep
learning enables the machine to
recognize people and objects in the
images fed to it and with deep learning
advertisers can leverage data to perform
real-time bidding and targeted display
advertising and these are just a small
sample of the myriad of different uses
for deep learning today so what is deep
learning deep learning is a subfield of
machine learning that deals with
algorithms inspired by the structure and
function of the brain and we look at
this we have the larger category which
is artificial intelligence very generic
comprehensive
ideal and in there we have machine
learning and then a sub category of
machine learning is deep learning so
when we talk about artificial
intelligence this is the ability of a
machine to imitate intelligent human
behavior so when we look at something
can it solve a problem the way humans do
can we take it to that next level so
it's just not repeating some kind of
simple output that we programmed it to
do can it actually start imitating human
intelligence and we look at machine
learning we have the application of ai
that allows a system to automatically
learn and improve from experience so
machine learning the most basic machine
learning is your linear regression model
you put a bunch of dots on the graph and
you draw a line through them and you
have a guess of what x and y are based
on
where what x is you can guess what y is
and finally we have our deep learning
application of machine learning that
uses complex algorithms and deep neural
nets to train a model why is deep
learning important it works with
unstructured data machine learning works
only with large sets of structured and
semi-structured data while deep learning
can work with both structured and
unstructured data handles complex
operations deep learning algorithms can
perform complex operations easily while
machine learning algorithms cannot
feature extraction machine learning
algorithms use labeled sample data to
extract patterns while deep learning
accepts large volumes of data as input
analyze the input to extract features
out of an object achieve best
performance performance of machine
learning algorithms decreases as the
amount of data increases so to maintain
the performance of the model we need
deep learning and this is always a
challenge of when do you go from machine
learning doing linear regression or
other regression models to deep learning
neural networks it really centers around
both
the complexity as it becomes more and
more complex or the problem becomes
harder to solve along with the amount of
data so both of those play a huge part
in deciding which would best serve your
purposes to predict what your data is
going to do and try to predict the
outcome so what are neural networks with
deep learning a machine can be trained
to identify various shapes so here we
have a square coming in you can see
we've broken it up into the pixels and
we want the label to come out square and
if we turn the square slightly sideways
it's still a square and we want to still
say it's a square with deep learning a
machine can be trained to identify
various shapes or the different patterns
of those shapes as they are in this case
being rotated but how is the machine
able to do this so we'll look at a nice
grid 28 by 28 784 pixels and we look at
that grade we look at each one of those
pixels as inputs so a neural network is
a system modeled on the human brain and
so we have all our inputs kind of like
your eyeball coming in there it has the
sensors in the back your different input
sensors which are your cones and rods so
each one of those is an input coming in
with information and it goes into a
neuron and then it sends out a pulse so
the data is fed as an input to the
neuron the neuron processes the
information provided as an input the
information is transferred over weighted
channels and this is very central to our
neural network each one of those pulses
coming in gets a different weight and
the output is the final value predicted
by the artificial neuron in this image
we're only looking at one neuron so
remember we're looking talk about a lot
of neurons working together and we'll
look at how those fit together in just a
moment we look at one neuron so let's
just take a look at that one neuron
let's dig a little deeper so we can get
some concepts in here so we can
understand the neural network so what
exactly happens within a neuron we have
an activation function so within each
neuron the following operations are
performed the product of each input and
the weight of the channel that's passed
over is found some of the weighted
products is computed this is called the
weighted sum and a bias unique to the
neuron is added to the weighted sum and
you can always look at that as if you
have an x y graph where's your y in
intercept you know the old euclidean
geometry x or y equals three x plus
five that's your plus five is that bias
is where does that come in and this is a
little bit more complicated because it's
not like three x it's more like 3x1 5x2
6x7 and usually you're dealing with
float numbers so it's not even it
doesn't even look like that it looks
like 0.001 times x1.13
times x2 and so on so the numbers get a
little confusing but the concept is very
straightforward we're going to multiply
the weight times the value coming in and
we're going to add that all together
plus the bias and the final sum is then
subjected to the particular function
known as the activation function and the
most simplest one is if it's greater
than zero it's one if it's less than
zero it's zero they usually use a lot of
different there's a lot of other
functions that are more reliable than
that one but that one gives you the most
basic understanding of what you're
looking at zero or one coming out in
most cases you actually have a value
coming out and in some cases we use like
a tangent wave so that there can be a
value between zero and one but it might
be it tends to shoot right up to one
rather quickly but you know those are
things you can fine tune in your neural
network as you start getting to the
solution let's keep into the generals
here and let's see what's the next step
we're going to look at the cost function
and this is so important in
understanding how the current neural
networks that we're working with are
able to learn things so we end up with a
cost value the cost value is the
difference between the neural net's
predicted output and the actual output
from a set of labeled training data the
least cost value is obtained by making
adjustments to the weights and biases
iteratively throughout the training
process and when you think about this
we're not just sending one set of
numbers through we're sending all kinds
of data in here so you might have a
hundred samples or a thousand samples
and each one of those samples comes in
and then we look at the cost for that
and we want to get that cost the minimal
the average minimal among all the
different samples so we want a general
answer on there you can see here we
denote the predicted output with a
little half triangle over it and then
the actual output is just a straight y
on this let's learn how neural networks
work let's dig in a little deeper in how
we program them how do neural networks
work exactly in this we're jumping from
a single node into a larger picture so
our neural network will be trained to
identify shapes and we'll start with the
square again 28 by 28 or 784 pixels and
this is kind of one of the standard
images we work with a lot of times our
shapes are images of 28 by 28 pixels
each pixel is fed as an input to the
neurons in the first layer so here we
have our input layer each one of those
we might flatten that out that's the
most easiest way to process that but not
the only way to process so we flatten it
out so it's just one long array and then
we have hidden layers that improve the
accuracy of the output and you can see
here we're not looking at just one
neuron we actually have a row two hidden
layers and each layer is a row of
neurons and data is passed on from layer
to layer over weighted channels each one
of those inputs is then weighted to each
of the next neurons in the next layer in
the hidden layer each neuron in the
first hidden layer takes a subset of the
inputs and processes it let's look into
what happens within the neurons so here
we have step one and we can see in here
where we have x1 times weight one x2
times weight two plus b1 that's that top
neuron up there and then we have the
next neuron down which is step two and
then in step two they denote the um with
the greek symbol phi and phi is the
activation function based on step one so
it might be if it's close to zero it's
zero if it's close to one it's one and
it might be a value in between it's very
common depending on what activation
function you use the results of the
activation function determine which
neurons will be activated in the
following layer so you can see here we
have b1 as we looked at with x1 and
weighted 1 x2 and weighted 2 and then
you would compute b2 the same way and b3
the same way and b4 and b5 and so on so
each neuron has an input from all the
input layers go into each of the hidden
layer neuron the first hidden layer the
result of the activation function
determines which neurons will be
activated in the following layer and
then that activation number goes off to
the next layer so we see here b11 b12
b13 and b14 and the weights coming in
from b1 so let's say b1 fires and it
goes into b11 usually you would see the
weights going all the way down so b2
would have their weights going into b1
and b2 would then go into b11 b1 b2 b3
and b4 and b5 would then go into b11 and
they would have their weights depending
on what came out it might just be zero
so there's nothing coming through or it
might be a value between zero and one
and so forth for b12 b13 b14 and b15 and
then we take those and they'll have the
way to test each one of those coming out
and they go into the final layer in this
case we have a neuron that represents a
square a neuron that represents a circle
and a neuron that represents a triangle
and just as before the information
reaching this layer is processed after
which a single neuron in the output
layer gets activated but our input was a
square what went wrong here remember we
started with the square what do we have
coming out it says circle well that's
going to be a problem because we don't
want it to tell us that squares are
circles well our network needs to be
trained first how do we train a network
the predicted output is compared against
the actual output by calculating the
cost function remember our cost function
at the end we take whatever we said it
was going to be and what it actually is
and we just subtract those two and the
most common way used to generate the
cost function is as follows is we're
going to take the actual value minus the
predicted value where we have y then you
have y with the half triangle over it is
the predicted and then y is the actual
value we subtract them we square that
value and then we divide it by two so
it's usually how they generate the cost
function the cost functions determines
the error in prediction and reports it
back to the neural network so we're
going to do some back propagation that's
what this is called back propagation
we're going back through the network the
other way and we're sending that error
back the other way the weights are
adjusted in order to reduce error the
network is trained with the new weights
and you can see here we have c equals
one half y minus y predicted or y actual
minus y predicted squared once again the
cost is determined and back propagation
is continued until the cost cannot be
reduced any further now keep in mind you
know if we have one picture of a square
and it goes through we actually do just
a little training we don't change it all
to match that first one otherwise you'll
have about what they call a bias so each
of those data goes back with our back
propagation and we'll send hundreds of
samples on there until we can get that
cost as a whole down as low as we can
get so that our average cost is very low
without it being biased towards one
specific figure and you can see here we
have our input layer hidden layer set up
on here similarly once we've trained it
for our square the network must also be
trained to identify circles and
triangles too so we need sets of all of
these we need lots of squares lots of
circles and lots of triangles the
weights are this further adjusted in
order to predict the three shapes with
the highest accuracy we can now rely on
our neural network to predict the input
shapes and you can see we have a
triangle coming in here and it goes
through here's our circle going through
and it's going to light up the circle
and so on for the square so before we
dive into some hands-on let's take a
look at some deep learning platforms the
primary programming language we're going
to look at four of these platforms and
we're going to start with torch the
primary programming language is lua with
an implementation in c2 torch's python
implementation is called pi torch and
this is interesting because python has
become one of the leads in data analysis
so you'll almost always see a pi torch
or
any one of these will have a python
equivalent and it's slowly spreading
throughout the languages so i'm sure
there's within torch it's also probably
got a java set up and definitely has a c
because its primary implementation is in
c and so we have cross cross is a python
framework for deep learning and usp is
reusability of code for the cpu and gpu
processing we have tensorflow tensorflow
is deep learning platform by google it
was developed in c plus and has its
implementation in python and just a
quick highlight keras and tensorflow
have slowly been working together so
there's a lot of things that you can
actually put across on top of tensorflow
and access tensorflow although there are
still some tools in tensorflow there
that keras doesn't fully access but it
is a great interface for doing that and
then there's the dl4j
is the first deep learning library
written for java and scala it is
integrated with hadoop and apache spark
and you remember apache spark is written
in scala that's one of the reasons that
dl4j came about is so that it would run
on the spark platform so let's take an
introduction to tensorflow google's
tensorflow is currently the most popular
deep learning library in the world it
has really once they open sourced it it
was just amazing how much it spread in
use and how many tools are linked into
tensorflow tensors are vectors or
matrices of n dimensions and you can see
here we have dimension five we have a
dimension four by five or five by four
as the case is five rows by four columns
here's one where it's three by three by
three and so this is kind of nice
because when you're processing pictures
there's certain things you wanna do
where you want the pixels to be next to
each other that's very important uh same
thing with your processing see a movie
you might want a three by three grid
coming in where you have the layers of
the frames coming in to be processed so
you can see how having different
dimensions is really helpful in
analyzing certain data structures and
this is what's so great about tensors is
you can of course flatten them out like
we did earlier or you can process them
based on their location in tensorflow
all computations performed involve
tensors so everything going through is
always looked at as tensors as a matrix
or matrixes of n dimension tensorflow
architecture is as follows
pre-processing data build a model train
and estimate the model and what we'll do
is we'll go ahead and dig into use case
imitation with tensorflow to do that i'm
actually going to go into
in this case of you using the anaconda
navigator and you can use either jupiter
lab or jupiter notebook most people are
very familiar with jupiter notebook it's
very commonly web-based the jupiter lab
is the next version of jupiter notebook
and it just lets you have multiple tabs
open when you're working on it and if
you're using anaconda you'll go under
environments and you'll want to make
sure that you have your tensorflow
installed and you can simply we'll do
this i have it installed uh but you
could do all the do all you can do a
search and draw for tensor and you can
see all the different tensors it's
actually installed in here version 1.1
3.1 if it wasn't you could check the box
and then run the install on there and
bring it right in but we'll go and start
up our jupiter lab which is going to
open up in this case i use google chrome
and in our jupyter lab or jupyter
notebook if you're in the notebook you
only have one tab and you won't have the
added options like there's a folder and
different things you can do in the lab
that you can't do in the notebook but
everything we're going to do you can
easily do in the notebook you'll start
up a new project deep learning is what
i'm going to call this and if you're not
familiar you can definitely we have some
tutorials out on the use of jupiter
notebook and how to run it and set it up
and things like that the most basic is
we put our code in here it has a nice
display a nice interface especially for
data science i can display all kinds of
things on this page and then you can
just run this page right here there's no
code in it so it's not going to show any
thing until i put some code in there and
of course you can cut your cells and
things like that so the first thing we
want to do is we want to import our
tools now if you haven't remember you
gotta install tensorflow and we'll also
use pandas pandas is a nice database
setup and that again is underneath your
environment and you can see here your
whatever you're working on i simply
learn setup where i've installed
tensorflow and pandas in here and i'll
simply go up here and run this not going
to see anything so we've just imported
those into our notebook that we're
working on so those are now available to
us and it helps to have some data to
work with we have here going to create a
path and a test path and we'll go ahead
and let's just highlight this whole path
and you can always post a note either
down below in the youtube video or you
can post a note on simplylearn.com and
ask for this path if you're not quite
picking it up but it is over here at the
uci edu on their setup and it's in their
archive so it's archive.ics.uci.edu
forward slash ml for machine learning
slash machine dash learning dash
databases slash adult that's quite a
mouthful and in this case we have adult
data and adult test well let's go and
just take a look at that let me just
paste that right in there to our browser
window and here's our adult data and if
i click on there it's going to come down
as a download i'm going to go ahead and
open it as a text in my notepad um and
the guys in the back were kind enough to
look up to find out what the actual
columns were in this uh coming across so
let me do and take that to pull that
information it doesn't matter whether i
put it before below because these are
just variables
but we can see here that we have age
work class final wgt i'm guessing that's
final we'll look that up in just a
second see what that matches in fact
let's pull that up and just put them
next to each other so we can kind of see
we got here so we have age we have our
working class state gov maybe final wage
77 5 16 education a bachelor's education
number 13 marital never married admin
clerical relationship not in family so
on and so on so it goes all the way
across here so we've pulled out this
information native country label etc
we'll go ahead and run this and so now
we've loaded all our different uh paths
and this path by the way this is the
same columns on here so i don't need to
create a separate columns on the adult
test and once we've run this we've set
those variables let's go ahead and pull
that data in and to do that we'll use
pandas and we'll create a df train a df
test uh each one's going to have our pd
for pandas dot read csv they'll have our
path we put in there our path test the
first one went ahead and skip initial
space true names columns there's our
columns in there index column equals
false there's no index column on the
second one if we went back into here and
we open up adult test let me just go
ahead and open that up pat you'll see
there's an actual row up here we want to
skip a one by three cross validator with
all the same data in it so we're looking
at the same data in there and here we're
going to go ahead and bring in our data
and then once you bring it in it's
always nice to see what kind of shape
your data is in and of course when we
talk about shape we're talking about how
many rows and columns not whether it's
been lifting weights we can see here we
have each one has 15 columns and that
goes with our columns right here if we
counter them there's going to be 15. and
the first data set has 32
561
rows where the second one has 16
281 rows and it's also good to see just
how the data came in so we'll use the
pandas d types we'll run that and you
can see here where h came in as an
integer integer 64. working class as an
object which makes sense
and then we have our
fnlwgt the education as objects or well
this is an integer integer object so on
all the way down and if we flash back to
the data we look at the last column it's
less than or equal to 50k and if we
scroll down enough we'll see it's also
greater than or equal to 50k so we'd
like to kind of give that its own
special setup on that label so on that
feature we're going to set the label
equal to
if it's less than or equal to 50k it's
going to be zero and if it's greater
than or equal to 50k it's going to be
one so it's one or the other that's
always an easy easy thing to read and
then we can take this and we go
dftrain.label equals label item for item
and df train label and this just loops
through all the labels there's a lot of
ways we can do this pandas this might be
actually kind of a slower way there's a
way to do just that setup and do the
logic within the
setup instead of doing a loop uh but for
this this thing it'll work fine we're
not dealing with a lot of data you know
it's a large data set but it's not that
big of a data set as data goes and we
also want to do it for our test data i
didn't really mention that we created
two date we're looking at two different
data sets one we're going to train the
data and then we're going to take it and
run the test data to see if it works so
we have our two different data sets and
we didn't catch it off the bat if you
were pulling up this you're going to
pull up one the this is the training set
and if we go back in here and open up
the test set let me just go back and do
that adult test one other thing that we
didn't notice that you want to pull up
is at the end there's a period so we're
pre-processing our data we want to make
sure that we include that period in
every line on the second set up so i go
back to my jupiter notebook i've got to
have a label t which is less than or
equal to 50k period or greater than
equal to 50k period for one otherwise
it's doing the exact same thing we're
going to change the df train label the
df test label to zero or one we'll just
run that we'll go ahead and print the df
train label dot value counts and the df
test label value counts this is always a
good idea because we want to know is
there any weird stuff going on there if
there's no value stuff like that this
will turn up on that setup and we can
see here we have zeros how many zeros
how many ones and so on on there just a
quick view of the data that we're going
through and if we go back up here go
ahead and print the train d types again
and we run that you could actually run
it up there and give you the new answer
because it's loaded this information uh
we now see it's an integer and if you go
back up here it was an object so that
makes life a little easier as far as
what we're doing with this now at this
point we're going to look at the data
and we can see we have a lot of numbers
and we have a lot of categories in here
uh so categories would be
united states mail never married versus
seven and we can also see that when we
looked at this we have our integers we
have our objects working class so the
next thing we want to do on there is we
want to go ahead and take that
where we have integers and the objects
and we want to bring that down here we
want to create those categories in a way
that the computer can see them and we'll
start with our continuous features like
age we can see age integer
fnlwgt is an integer capital gain is an
integer educational number there's our
educational numbers in integer and so on
uh so if we're going to have these as
continuous features where they're an
integer we also need to make a list of
the categorical features we want to work
with such as working class education
marital occupation relationship race sex
and native country and again these are
all objects uh so that makes sense and
when we flip back over to the data we
can see here we're actually looking at
united states if we continue down see if
i can find another one a lot of united
states on this particular one i was
getting worried there for a second that
we only had united states and it was a
very biased uh census which it probably
is for wherever it came from and of
course bachelor's associate vocational
some college uh so you can see this is
more categorical versus an actual number
uh so now we have our
categorical and we have our continuous
features and this is just the list of
these so let's go ahead and run that and
load that list in there so we can now
start manipulating our data with it now
we get our first line of tensor flow
code which is exciting and we're going
to create a variable continuous features
and what we're doing in here is we're
going to go into tf
feature columns so we have the feature
columns we're going to set those up
numeric columns k for k in continual
features so this is going to go in here
and says each one of these is a
continual feature and we're going to
feed that into the feature column not
very exciting on the output because
we're just creating this variable here
letting it know what columns are what
then we're going to create a uh
relationship uh set up so we have
continuous features and then we have a
relationship and again we're doing tf
but in this case we use feature column
so just like this one we're telling it
feature column and now we do categorical
column with vocabulary list
so it's one of the things we can do with
tensorflow and we're going to feed it
one we have relationship and so we're
just drilling down to the relationship
column and these are the options they
had so this is going to be the
vocabulary attached to this column and
we'll go ahead and run that so we load
up our relationship and then we're going
to do one more uh way of loading uh in
this one we're going to do categorical
features and so in categorical features
we're going to do tf feature column
here's our command we've already seen
before it's going to be categorical
column with hash bucket we're going to
create buckets in this case for k and
categorical features so it's going to
create a bucket for each one of these
categorical features and the bucket size
is 1 000. so we're looking at and we've
actually kind of repeated something
because relationship is also in the
bucket setup on there but we want to
show you three major ways of loading in
your different features one is our
features that we know where it's going
to be a number uh so our continuous
features then we can set it as a
relationship in this case we actually
created a vocabulary husband not in
family very clear vocabulary on there
and then we also are loading just
general categories into buckets you can
set different bucket settings in here we
went ahead and just went with a thousand
so pretty much everything since there's
not a huge number of categories each one
gets their own kind of bucket set up in
there and as far as the initial setup we
need to go ahead and create a model so
this is where it starts to come together
we've as far as the pre-setup we have
our tf we have an estimator we're gonna
do linear classifier on the estimator in
classes equals two so we know there's
only two classes we're looking at we
have ongoing train feature columns and
then we have our different we have
categorical features plus continuous
features so this basically creates our
model what data is going in and we'll go
ahead and run this and you can see here
that it gives us a little information
that we had our tensorflow using default
config you can change a lot of defaults
you can change as far as the model
directory
random seed saving summary checkpoints
there's all kinds of things you can go
in here and set up rewrite options keep
checkpoint mix etc at this point the
model hasn't done anything all we've
done is create the model uh so let's
just do a real quick rehash of what
we've done so far what we started off
with is we grab some data in this case
uh an adult an adult test we have a
training data set and a test data set
we set the columns up we took a very
short brief exploration of the data in
its shape as far as what we're working
with we changed our label around a
little bit so that the label makes a
little bit more sense of zero one
instead of for the machine it's easier
to spit out a zero or a one we can look
up here we double check to make sure we
how many zeros and ones we have double
check our data make sure it's integer
64. nothing weird's going on and then we
looked at three different ways that we
can kind of label the data as far as the
way we're going to read it we have our
continuous features and a categorical
features here's a relationship which is
one of them we went ahead and created
our model we did not put the
relationship in here which you can do
you can actually maybe take it out of
categorical and then have its own on
here instead of having categorical
features and continuous features and so
on so we've created our setup for our
model the next thing we need to do is we
need to go ahead and create a function
letting it know how to read the data
into our model how are we going to train
it and let's go ahead and create two
variables the first one is going to be
features this is just all the features
that are in there and then the second
one is going to be our label and this is
basically we're looking at all the
different information we can put into it
and then is that person based on that
information going to make less than or
greater than 50k that's what that comes
down to now the next part uh the
definition we're going to create has a
lot in it and we're going to feed this
definition into our model training so
there's a lot of stuff that goes on here
first we'll call it get input and
function def get input function we have
our data set number of epochs equals
none in batch equals 128 shuffled equals
true so we're running this and it's
going to return a tf estimator inputs
pandas input function and in this case
it's going to be x equals our pd data
frame k data set k values for k in
features y is pd series data set label
values batch size equals n batch number
of epochs equals number of epics shuffle
equals shuffle so in here we're passing
in uh the number of epochs we're not too
worried about we're going to just go
once through the data because there's a
lot of data in there we don't need to
rerun it epics is how many times do you
cover all the data and then how many
groups of data do you pull in and batch
at a time so we're only going to look at
128 do the reverse propagation like we
talked about uh and then it'll go to the
next batch and the next batch and the
next batch and it shuffles them so
shuffle means that we're randomly
picking where they're coming from uh
like again we're only doing we're not
too worried about the number of epics
for this particular model depending on
how much data you have and depending
what you're running depends on how many
epics you need to run and there's a lot
of rules on how many epics you need to
run one of them is if you're
training data and you're testing data
because you'll check your testing data
against your training data if your
testing data starts having a better
results in your training data that means
you're no longer fitting towards the
data but you're fitting to the answer so
it's kind of these little weird things
you start to on here and tensorflow is
really cool because it actually checks a
lot of that for you uh but we're just
going to set number of epics equal to
zero and then we have our data set going
in so we're creating our get function
how do we get the data into training our
model and we'll go ahead and run that so
now we have our data function and now it
knows where the data is coming from uh
so we need to go ahead and train it and
that simply would take our model we
created way up here that's where we take
the model there we've told it what
columns is going to pull in so it knows
what columns it's looking at know what
the definition was going to get the
information from so now we want to go
ahead and train it and here's our input
function equals in this case get input
function and here we tell it that our
data set is a df train number of epics
equals none which is already
automatically set up there in batch
equals 128 which is what we have up here
shuffle equals false and we're going to
do 1000 steps so we're actually going to
go through
128 batches but we're gonna do that a
thousand times and we'll go ahead and
run this and i just ran an update so
it's gonna give me some warnings because
of that update and then we're back here
and it's still going to construct
pipelines use tf data module not a big
problem we let it go ahead and run all
the way through one here and it takes it
just a moment there we go there's our
thousand coming out as you can see here
here's uh checkpoints for one thousand
ongoing training a thousand and one
global steps and this is just all the
reverse propagation going on that's what
we're doing here uh one of the things we
didn't cover is we do it in small
increments so it's not all done like one
error goes all the way back you'd only
do a part of that error and each one
sends back a little piece and say slowly
adjust your different weights going all
the way back and then if you're going to
train your model we want to know how it
did so we're going to do model evaluate
and our input function equals remember
our input function up here that we
created way up here we're going to take
this input function and instead of the
data set that's coming in we put in the
data set here for training where's our
training input train there we go df
underscore train
now we're going to go ahead and evaluate
and here it is a get input function test
so we're going to test the data out
number of epochs one we don't need to
rerun it more than once per batch 128
so on shuffle and steps a thousand so
we're going to go ahead and evaluate
this let's just see how good our test
data did
how good our model was programmed on our
training data and how it evaluates on
the test and we can see it going on down
here where it's got the evaluating graph
was finalized let me just highlight that
ongoing model checkpoint tensorflow
running local init evaluate 100 out of a
thousand and so on and once it gets to
the end we get a nice uh output here we
have an accuracy in this case of 0.79
with a baseline of 0.76 so now we've
created a model uh let's go ahead and
tweak it a little bit so we have our
accuracy up here what we're going to do
is we're going to look at age and let's
just go ahead and create a new square
value for age and the reason we want to
look into the square value of age is we
know that if you really look through the
data you'll find that as a young person
the age keeps increasing as you get
close to retirement it begins to
decrease so we square the value of age
and that's very data specific when we're
looking at data you'll find that any
kind of data that has that kind of like
uptick and down tick by squaring it or
square rooting it you can get some very
different results and so we're going to
go and square our age and this is kind
of it's interesting because at this
point even at the beginning of this
we're focused on deep learning and on
tensorflow but before i would begin even
looking at any of this i would have
probably run some kind of heat map or
some kind of evaluation in r or sk learn
in python to find out the correlation
between different features to see just
how well they correlate to each other
and there certainly are some wonderful
tools for that because sometimes you can
just mark off some features and other
features you bring in but for the deep
learning we can see how we can just dump
it all in there and let it sort it out
itself and we're going to just write a
quick little function here to take the
square variable in this case we have dft
dfte this is our training and your test
variable and the variable age coming in
and we just want to go ahead and create
a new under dft and the new is going to
be the variable name whatever we put in
there which will be age so let's load
this here's our functions now loaded and
certainly we could have just done that
as a line of code but you start to get
the feeling that when you build these
functions you might use that you can now
use this function if you had a number of
different features that had this kind of
quality to them and we have our dftrain
new so we're going to create a new
training and a new test and it's going
to equal the square variable dftrain or
dftest and the variable name is age
let's just go ahead and run that and so
now we have our new our df train new and
df test new and just like we did before
let's just double check the shape of our
data and make sure it all matches and
when we look at the output here really
what's important is that each one of
these has 16 features in it we want to
make sure we're not getting something
weird on there and our training set has
32
561 rows in it and this one has just
over 16 000 in there and everything's
pretty much the same except that in our
continuous features new we now have the
new column we put in there so we need to
change that and we have our continuous
features new down here which we're going
to load up with our tf feature column
numerical this would all look familiar
because we just did this and so we're
going to load that up with the new being
the new value in there let's go ahead
and run that and we'll create a model
that will call it model one and this is
the same that we did before except now
we have our continuous features new in
here so here's our new model in this
case model one instead of model and
we're gonna build that model right there
now we haven't trained it all we've done
is told it where to get the data and how
to get the data and what features are
coming in we haven't actually told it
everything on the features coming in
because we still need to also build our
full our get input function so where's
the input coming from so we built the
model with the features in it and now we
need to go ahead and create our get
input function this is the same as
before but you'll see
we now have it with the data set coming
in is going to be the same data set up
here and so if we scroll a little bit to
the right we should see the new and
there it is sure enough there's our new
on the right and so let's go ahead and
run that now we've defined our model we
defined where the information is coming
from and again you can go back and
review the first part because this is
identical that we did before except now
we have new as the column for the age
and we'll go ahead and do our model one
and let's go ahead and train it there's
our input function git input function
that we defined up here dftrain is going
to be the same and everything else is
going to be the same let's go ahead and
run that and it should go through here
and run the tensor info coming in and
it's going to go through in this case we
have steps 1000 shuffling so it's going
to go randomly 128 per batch
and then the epics is automatic we're
not worried about that today so now we
have a trained tensorflow model and with
our new model just like we did before we
want to go ahead and evaluate it so it's
the same setup we had before with our
same get input function with our df test
new in here coming in so there's our new
data coming in and this is really common
when you're doing these models you make
little tiny tweaks to see if you can
improve it one of the best articles i
read recently was you build your model
to fail you want a running model so you
actually have something to compare
against and then you continually tweak
it till you get a better accuracy now i
don't expect the accuracy necessarily to
get better on this uh because of the way
we partition the data we can see here we
now have an accuracy of 0.76 which is a
little bit over the baseline and it's
about what i would have expected it to
be kind of the same the reason is
because we split the data at the 50 the
people making over 50k and those making
less and so the age factor shouldn't be
a huge factor it would be if we were
looking at more discrete buckets like 40
to 50 50 to 60 60 to 70 when we create
buckets but in this i didn't really
expect it to go up that much in fact we
could probably run it a dozen times
which would be very bad data science and
we see we actually had a slightly better
one up here but our baseline accuracy
was 0.76 and we come down here we still
see uh here's our accuracy baseline
0.763 that didn't really change and you
know the accuracy didn't really go up
that much i could hit the run button a
few times i would probably upbeat the
one above it's not a big change but
that's all right that's how we learned
is how we go through and figure out
what's going to work with our data and
what's not what's going to improve the
quality of our data so we have a better
prediction and what's not and we can now
go ahead and utilize this model this is
where it gets exciting when you're
actually working with somebody or with
your clients and you come in and say
okay here's my predictions we're going
to take a create a list and we're going
to use model 1 and we're going to
predict and our input function is get
input function df test new again this
probably doesn't make too big of a
difference but we'll go ahead and stick
with the new data we created number of
epics 1 batch 128 so all this should
look pretty familiar but we're running
the prediction so we're going to load
all our predictions into the predictions
and let's go ahead and run that and
you'll see it go through the tensorflow
setup and so it's running done running
local ops and then let's just go ahead
and print the df test new ilocation zero
so row zero and we're going to look at
the predictions also for the same
location zero let's go ahead and run
that and we can see here that we have
age 25 work class private it has all the
information coming in for that
individual and then it comes down here
we go ahead and get our
prediction and in this particular
instance there's our label zero uh and
then we come down here and we see it
takes a little bit for the setup to look
up but there's our array which also
returns a zero and it has information
for us on there probabilities logistics
on here so you can see there's all kinds
of additional information you can pull
from this and likewise we could do it
for uh position three let me go and run
that and what's kind of nice about this
is you can now see here's label one and
here's our logistics output and again if
they kind of hunt for a little bit in
this particular setup but here's the
output array and there's our one and
they match label one one so we predicted
for the very first one location zero
that it's going to be a 0 on the label
it's going to make under 50 000 and the
individual in two working class private
whatever set up on here capital gain
capital f loss etc came up as one
meaning they're going to make over 50
000 so we covered a lot i mean this is
the basics and you can see as you dig
deeper when you look at some of this
code let me just go back up here we're
way back up here at the very top a
little too far overshot as we start
working in here we have uh one defining
your features and at this point we
didn't show this but i would probably
use either python or r to show a
relationship correlation because they
have some really easy packages in there
to pull that up so you can see what
features are really connected and how
they're connected uh and then we showed
you different features like we have ones
that are
integers and then we have ones like sex
that are objects you're zero one you're
male or female you're uh same thing with
race probably have just maybe 16
different races listed there ethnicities
things like that native country again
that's you don't have like infinite
number of native countries you just have
a handful so we look at this we have our
features we looked at that we have our
continuous features like age which is a
number or in this case an integer an
education number how many years and so
on along with your race your sex your
relationship which are just very
abbreviated uh categorical data uh so we
looked at that we went in there and we
showed you how to um where was it here
we go we go back up here uh so we create
our model the model has knows what
categories are coming in that's really
important and this is probably the one
of the more complicated parts of this is
our input function and this input
function is so important so i want to
just re-hash the input function for that
reason this lets us know how we're
pulling the data it lets us know
if we're going to go through all the
data 20 times
or we're going to let the or we're just
going to let tensorflow itself keep
going until the training model reaches a
point that point is based on uh with
what they call bias you can become
biased on your training data and so when
it hits a certain point where it becomes
overly biased to just that data then it
doesn't really work really good in the
outside world you start losing keep it
generic but as close as possible to the
right answer so generic answers for a
huge amount of data and then we have our
batch size
are we going to shuffle it which we did
and then also our estimator inputs uh so
you have your estimator function here
and then of course where the actual data
is coming from so you can see all this
is in that get input function that's
where a lot of the work comes in putting
this together and then we train our
model um that's pretty straightforward
once you have your input function and
all your setup training the model is
quick and then we go ahead and evaluate
and then we can go ahead and create a
predict and then you know look at our
predictions and how they work on
individuals so it's pretty it gives you
a whole roundabout setup on here and how
this is set up and how it's working
certainly there are um a lot more things
you can do with tensorflow this is the
basic tensorflow and it's always
developing so it's exciting this is
gonna be one of the most exciting fields
right now because it is really in an
infant stage and just exploding in the
market if getting your learning started
is half the battle what if you could do
that for free
visit skill up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
welcome to tensorflow 2.0 tutorial
what's in it for you we're going to
cover today deep learning frameworks
what is tensorflow features of
tensorflow tensorflow applications how
tensorflow works
tensorflow 1.0 versus 2.0 tensorflow 2.0
architecture and then we'll go over a
tensorflow demo where we roll up our
sleeves and dive right into the code
so let's start with deep learning
frameworks to start with this chart
doesn't even do the filled
justice because it's just exploded
these are just some of the major
frameworks out there there's a carrass
which happens to sit on tensorflow so
they're very integrated there's
tensorflow
pie torches out there caffe theano
dl4j
and chainer these are just a few of the
deep learning frameworks we're talking
about neural networks if you're just
starting out never seen a neural network
you can go into python in the
scikit and do the neural network in
there which is probably the most
simplest version i know but the most
robust version out there the most top of
the ladder as far as the technology
right now is tensorflow and that of
course is changing from day to day and
some of these
are
better for different purposes
so let's dive into tensorflow
let's see what is tensorflow what is
tensorflow tensorflow is a popular open
source library released in 2015 by
google brain team for building machine
learning and deep learning models
it is based on python programming
language and performs numerical
computations using data flow graphs to
build models so let's take a look at
some of the features of tensorflow it
works efficiently with multi-dimensional
arrays
if you've ever played with any of the
simpler packages of neural networks
you're going to find that you have to
pretty much flatten them and make sure
your your stuff is set in a flat model
tensorflow works really good so we're
talking pictures here where you have
x and y coordinates where the picture is
and then each pixel has three or four
different channels that's a very
complicated array a very
multi-dimensional array it provides
scalability of computation across
machines and large data sets
this is so new right now
and you might think that's a minor thing
but when python is operating on one
computer and it has a float value
and it truncates it differently on each
computer you don't get the same results
and so your training model might work on
one machine and then another it doesn't
this is one of the things that
tensorflow
addresses and does a very good job on
it supports fast debugging and model
building
this is why i love tensorflow
i can go in there and i can build a
model with different layers each layer
might have different properties
they have like the convolutional neural
network which you can then sit on top of
a regular neural network with reverse
propagation there's a lot of tools in
here and a lot of options and each layer
that it goes through can utilize those
different options and stack differently
and it has a large community and
provides tensorboard to visualize the
model tensorboard is pretty uh recent
but it's a really nice tool to have so
you when you're working with other
people or showing your
clients or the
shareholders in the company you can give
them a nice visual model so they know
what's going on what are they paying for
and let's take a glance at some of the
different uses or applications for
tensorflow when we talk about tensorflow
applications
clearly this is data analytics we're
getting into the data science i like to
use data science as probably a better
term because this is the programming
side
and it's really the sky is a limit
we can look at face detection language
translation fraud detection video
detection
there are so many different things out
there that tensorflow can be used for
when you think of neural networks
because tensorflow is a neural network
think of complicated chaotic data this
is very different than if you have a set
numbers like you're looking at the stock
market you can use this on the stock
market but if you're doing something
where the numbers are very clear
and not so chaotic as you have in a
picture then you're talking more about
linear regression models
and different regression models when
you're looking at that when you're
talking about these really complicated
data patterns
then you're talking neural networks in
tensorflow and if we're going to talk
about tensorflow we should talk about
what tensors are after all that is what
tensor
that's what this is named after so we
talk about tensors in tensorflow
tensorflow is derived from its core
component known as a tensor a tensor is
a vector or a matrix of n dimensions
that represent all types of data and you
can see here we have the scalar which is
just a single
number you have your vector which is two
numbers uh might be a number in a
direction you have a simple matrix and
then we get into the tensor i mentioned
how a picture is a very complicated
tensor because it has your x y
coordinates and then each one of those
pixels has three to four channels for
your different colors
and so each image coming in would be its
own tensor
and
in tensorflow tensors are defined by a
unit of dimensionality called as rank
and you can see here we have our
scalar which is a single number that has
a rank of zero because it has no real
dimensions to it other than it's just a
single point
and then you have your vector which
would be a single list of numbers
so that's a rank one
matrix would have rank two and then as
you can see right here as we get into
the full tensor it has a rank 3.
and so
the next step is to understand how a
tensorflow works
and if you haven't looked at
the basics of a neural network in
reverse propagation that is the basics
of tensorflow and then it goes through a
lot of different options and properties
that you can build into your different
tensors
so a tensorflow performs computations
with the help of data flow graphs it has
nodes that represent the operations in
your model and if you
look at this you should see a neural
network going on here we have our inputs
bc and d
and you might have x equals b plus c y
equals d minus 4
a equals x times y and then you have an
output
and so
even though this isn't a neural network
here it's just a simple set of
computations going across
you can see how the more complicated it
gets the more because it can actually
one of the tensors is a neural network
with reverse propagation
but it's not limited to that there's so
much more you can do with it and this
here is just a basic uh flow of
computations of the data going across
and you can see we can plug in the
numbers uh b equals four c equals three
d equals six and you get x equals four
plus three
so x equals seven y equals 6 minus 4 so
y equals 2 and finally a equals 7 times
2 or a equals 14. like i said this is a
very simplified version of how
tensorflow works each one of these
layers can get very complicated
but tensorflow does such a nice job that
you can spin different setups up very
easily and test them out so you can test
out these different models to see how
they work now tensorflow has gone
through two major stages
we had the original tensorflow release
of 1.0 and then they came out with the
2.0 version and the 2.0 addressed so
many things out there that the 1.0
really needed so we start talking about
tensorflow 1.0 versus 2.0 i guess you
would need to know this for
a legacy programming job if you're
pulling apart somebody else's code the
first thing is that tensorflow 2.0
supports eager execution by default it
allows you to build your models and run
them instantly and you can see here from
tensorflow 1 to tensorflow 2
we have
almost double the code to do the same
thing so if i want to do with tf.session
or tensorflow session as a session the
session run you have your variables your
session run you have your tables
initializer and then you do your model
fit
x train y train and then your validation
data your x value y value and your epics
and your batch size all that goes into
the fit
and you can see here where that was all
just compressed to make it run easier
you can just create a model and do a fit
on it
and you only have like that last set of
code on there so it's automatic that's
what they mean by the eager so if you
see the first part you're like what the
heck is all the session thing going on
that's tensorflow 1.0 and then when you
get into 2.0 it's just nice and clean
if you remember from the beginning i
said cross
on our list up there
and cross is the high level api in
tensorflow 2.0
cross is the official high level api of
tensorflow 2.0 it has incorporated cross
as tf.caras cross provides a number of
model building apis such as sequential
functional and subclassing so you can
choose the right level of abstraction
for your project and
we'll hopefully touch base a little bit
more on this sequential being the most
common uh form that is your your
layers are going from one side to the
other so everything's going in a
sequential order
functional
is where you can split the layer so you
might have your input coming in one side
it splits into two completely mod
different models and then they come back
together
and one of them might be doing
classification the other one might be
doing just linear regression kind of
stuff or a neural basic
reverse propagation neural network and
then those all come together into
another layer which is your
neural network reverse propagation setup
subclassing
is the most complicated as you're
building your own models and you can
subclass your own models into cross so
very powerful tools here this is all the
stuff that's been coming out currently
in the tensorflow cross setup a third
big change we're going to look at is it
in tensorflow 1.0
in order to use tf layers as variables
you would have to write tf variable
block so you'd have to pre-define that
in tensorflow 2 you just add your layers
in under the sequential and it
automatically defines them as long as
they're flat layers
of course this changes a little bit as a
more complicated
tensor you have coming in but all of
it's very easy to do and that's what 2.0
does a really good job of and here we
have
a little bit more on the scope of this
and you can see how tensorflow 1 asks
you to do
these different layers and values if you
look at the scope and the default name
you start looking at all the different
code in there to create the variable
scope that's not even necessary in
tensorf 2.0 so you'd have to do one
before you do do what you see the code
in 2.0
in 2.0 you just create your model it's a
sequential model and then you can add
all your layers in you don't have to
pre-create the
variable scope so if you ever see the
variable scope you know that came from
an older version and then we have the
last two which is our api cleanup and
the autograph
in the api cleanup tensorflow 1 you
could build models using tf gans tf app
tf contrib tf flags etc in tensorflow 2
a lot of apis have been removed and this
is just they just cleaned them up
because people weren't using them and
they've simplified them and that's your
tf app your tf flags your tf logging are
all gone
so there's those are three legacy
features that are not in 2.0 and then we
have our tf function and autograph
feature in the old version tensorflow 1
0 the python functions were limited and
could not be compiled or exported
re-imported
so you were continually having to redo
your code you couldn't very easily just
put a pointer to it and say hey let's
reuse this
in tensorflow 2 you can write a python
function using the tf function to mark
it for the jit compilation for the
python jit so that tensorflow runs it as
a single graph autograph feature of tf
function helps to write graph code using
natural python syntax
now we just threw in a new word in you
graph a graph is not a picture of a
person uh you'll hear graph x and some
other things
graph is what are all those lines that
are connecting different objects so if
you remember from before where we had
the different layers going through
sequentially each one of those white
lined arrows would be a graph x that's
where that computation is taken care of
and that's what they're talking about
and so if you had your own special code
or python way that you're sending that
information forward you can now put your
own function in there instead of using
whatever function they're using
in neural networks this would be your
activation function although it could be
almost anything out there depending on
what you're doing next let's go for
hierarchy and architecture and then
we'll cover three basic tools in
tensorflow before we roll up our sleeves
and dive into the example so let's just
take a quick look at tensorflow toolkits
in their hierarchy at the high level we
have our object oriented api so this is
what you're working with you have your
tf cross you have your estimators this
sits on top of your tf layers tf losses
tf metrics so you have your reusable
libraries for model building this is
really where tensorflow shines is
between the cross
running your estimators and then being
able to swap in different layers you can
your losses your metrics all of that is
so built into tensorflow makes it really
easy to use and then you can get down to
your low level tf api
you have extensive control over this you
can put your own formulas in there your
own procedures or models in there
you could have it split we talked about
that earlier so with the 2.0 you can now
have it split one direction we do a
linear regression model and then go to
the other where it does a
neural network and maybe each neural
network has a different activation set
on it and then it comes together into
another layer which is another neural
network so you can build these really
complicated models and at the low level
you can put in your own apis you can
move that stuff around and most recently
we have the tf code can run on multiple
platforms
and so you have your cpu
which is
basically like on the computer i'm
running on i have uh eight cores and 16
dedicated threads i hear they now have
one out there that has over 100 cores so
you have your cpu running and then you
have your gpu which is your graphics
card
and most recently they also include the
tpu setup which is specifically for
tensorflow models
neural network kind of setup
so now you can export the tf code and it
can run on all kinds of different
platforms for the most
diverse setup out there and moving on
from the hierarchy to the architecture
in the tensorflow 2.0 architecture we
have
you can see on the left this is usually
where you start out with and 80 percent
of your time in data science is spent
pre-processing data making sure it's
loaded correctly and everything looks
right
so the first level in tensorflow is
going to be your read and pre-processed
data your tf data feature columns
this is going to feed into your tf cross
or your pre-made estimators
and kind of you have your tensorflow hub
that sits on top of there so you can see
what's going on uh once you have all
that set up you have your distribution
strategy where are you gonna run it
you're gonna be running it on just a
regular cpu are you gonna be running it
uh with the gpu added in um like i have
a pretty high end graphics card so it
actually grabs that gpu processor and
uses it or do you have a specialized tpu
set up in there that you paid extra
money for
it could be if you're
in later on when you're distributing the
package you might need to run this on
some really high processors because
you're processing at a server level for
let's say net you might be processing
this at a
distribute you're distributing it not
the distribution strategy but you're
distributing it into a server where that
server might be analyzing thousands and
thousands of purchases done
every minute
and so you need that higher speed to
give them a
to give them a recommendation or a
suggestion so they can buy more stuff
off your website or maybe you're looking
for
data fraud analysis working with the
banks you want to be able to run this at
a high speed so that when you have
hundreds of people
sending their transactions in it says
hey this doesn't look right someone's
scamming this person and probably has
their credit card so when we're talking
about all those fun things we're talking
about saved model this is we were
talking about that earlier where it used
to be when you did one of these models
it wouldn't truncate the float numbers
the same and so a model going from one
you build the model on your
machine in the office and then you need
to distribute it and so we have our
tensorflow serving cloud on premium
that's what i was talking about if
you're like a banking or something like
that
now they have tensorflow lite so you can
actually run a tensorflow on an android
or an ios or raspberry pi a little
breakout board there in fact they just
came out with a new one that has a
built-in there's just a little mini tpu
with the camera on it so it can
pre-process a video so you can load your
tensorflow model on to that
talking about an affordable way to beta
test a new product you have the
tensorflow js which is for browser and
node server so you can get that out on
the browser for some simple computations
that don't require a lot of heavy
lifting but you want to distribute to a
lot of endpoints and now they also have
other language bindings so you can now
create your tensorflow backend save it
and have it accessed from c java go
c sharp rust r or from whatever package
you're working on so we kind of have an
overview of the architecture and what's
going on behind the scenes and in this
case what's going on as far as
distributing it let's go ahead and take
a look at three specific pieces of
tensorflow
and those are going to be constants
variables and sessions
so very basic things you need to know
and understand when you're working with
the tensorflow
setup
so constants in tensorflow in tensorflow
constants are created using the function
constant in other words they're going to
stay static the whole time whatever
you're working with the syntax for
constant
value d type 9 shape equals none name
constant verify shape equals false
that's kind of the syntax you're looking
at and we'll explore this with our hands
on a little more in depth
and you can see here we do z equals t f
dot constant 5.2 name equals x
d type is a float that means that we're
never going to change that 5.2 it's
going to be a constant value and then we
have our variables in tensorflow
variables in tensorflow are in memory
buffers that store tensors
and so we can declare a two by three
tensor populated by ones you could also
do constants this way by the way you can
create a an array of ones for your
constants i'm not sure why you'd do that
but you know you might need that for
some reason
in here we have v equals tf.variables
and then in tensorflow you have tf.ones
and you have the shape which is 2 3
which is then going to create a nice two
by three
array that's filled with ones and then
of course you can go in there and
they're variables so you can change them
it's a tensor so you have full control
over that and then you of course have
sessions in tensorflow a session in
tensorflow is used to run a
computational graph to evaluate the
nodes
and remember when we're talking a graph
or graph x we're talking about all that
information then goes through all those
arrows and whatever computations they
have that take it to the next node and
you can see down here where we have
import tensorflow as tf if we do x
equals a tf.constant of 10
we do y equals a tf constant of 2.0 or
20.0 and then you can do z equals
tf.variable
and it's a tf.ad x comma y
and then once you have that set up in
there you go ahead and knit your tf
global variables initializer with tf
session as session you can do a session
run and knit
and then you print the session run y
uh and so when you run this you're going
to end up with of course the 10 plus 20
is 30. and we'll be looking at this a
lot more closely as we actually roll up
our sleeves and put some code together
so let's go ahead and take a look at
that and for my coding today i'm going
to go ahead and go through anaconda and
then i'll use specifically the jupiter
notebook on there and of course this
code is going to work
whatever platform you choose whether
you're in a notebook
the jupiter lab which is just the
jupiter notebook but with tabs for
larger projects we're going to stick
with jupiter notebook
pycharm whatever it is you're gonna use
in here uh you have your spider and your
qt console for different programming
environments the thing to note um it's
kind of hard to see but i have my main
pi 3 6.
right now when i was writing this
tensorflow works in python version 3.6
if you have python version 37 or 38
you're probably going to get some errors
in there
might be that they've already updated it
and i don't know it now you have an
older version
but you want to make sure you're in
python version 3 6 in your environment
and of course in anaconda i can easily
set that environment up make sure you go
ahead and
pip in your
tensorflow or if you're in anaconda you
can do a conda install tensorflow to
make sure it's in your package
so let's just go ahead and dive in and
bring that up
this will open up a nice browser window
i just love the fact i can zoom in and
zoom out depending on what i'm working
on making it really easy to adjust
demo for the right size go under new and
let's go ahead and create a new python
and once we're in our new python window
this is going to leave it untitled
let's go ahead and import import
tensorflow as tf
at this point we'll go ahead and just
run it real quick
no errors yay no errors
i
i do that whenever i do my imports
because i unbearably will have opened up
a new environment and forgotten to
install tensorflow into that environment
uh or something along those lines so
it's always good to double check
uh and if we're gonna double check that
we also it's also good to know uh what
version we're working with and we can do
that simply by
using the version command in tensorflow
which you should know is is probably
intuitively the tf
dot underscore underscore version
underscore underscore
and
you know it always confuses me because
sometimes you do tf.version for one
thing you do tf dot underscore version
underscore for another thing
this is a double underscore in
tensorflow for pulling your version out
and it's good to know what you're
working with we're going to be working
in tensorflow version 2.1.0 and i did
tell you the the um we were going to dig
a little deeper into our constants and
you can do an array of constants and
we'll just create this nice array
a equals tf.constant
and we're just going to put the array
right in there 4 3 6 1.
we can run this and now that is what a
is equal to and if we want to just
double check that remember we're in
jupiter notebook where you can just put
the letter a
and it knows that that's going to be
print
otherwise you round you surround it in
print and you can see it's a tf tensor
it has the shape the type and the and
the array on here it's a two by two
array and just like we can create a
constant we can go and create a variable
and this is also going to be a two by
two array and if we go ahead and print
the v out we'll run that
and sure enough there's our tf variable
in here
then we can also let's just go back up
here and add this in here
i could create another tensor and we'll
make it a constant this time
and we're going to put that in over here
we'll have b tf constant
and if we go and print out uh v and b
i'm going to run that
and this is an interesting thing that
always that happens in here you'll see
right here when i print them both out
what happens it only prints the last one
unless you use print commands so
important to remember that in jupyter
notebooks we can easily fix that by go
ahead and print and surround v with
brackets and now we can see with the two
different variables we have
we have the three one five two which is
a variable
and this is just a flat
constant so it comes up as a tf tensor
shape 2 kind of tube and that's
interesting to note
that this label is a tf.tensor and this
is a tf variable
so that's how it's looking in the back
end when you're talking about the
difference between a variable and a
constant
the other thing i want you to notice is
in variable we capitalize the v and with
the constant we have a lowercase c
little things like that can lose you
when you're programming and you're
trying to find out hey why doesn't this
work uh so those are a couple of things
to note in here
and just like any other array in math
we can do like a concatenate or
concatenate the different values here
and you can see we can take a b
concatenated you just do a t f dot
concat
values and there's our a b axes on one
hopefully you're familiar with axes and
how that works when you're dealing with
matrixes and if we go ahead and print
this out
you'll see right here we end up with a
tensor so it's put it in as a constant
not as a variable
and you have your array 4 3 7 eight and
six one four five it's concatenated the
two together and again i wanna highlight
a couple things on this our axes equals
one this means we're doing the columns
um so if you had a longer array like
right now we have an array that is like
you know has a shape one whatever it is
two comma two
um axes
zero
is going to be your first one and axes
one is going to be your second one and
it translates as columns and rows if we
had a shape let me just put the word
shape here
um
so you know what i'm talking about it's
very clear and this is i'll tell you
what i spent a lot of time
looking at these shapes and trying to
figure out which direction i'm going in
and whether to flip it or whatever
so you can get lost in which way your
matrix is going which is column which is
rows are you dealing with the third axes
or the second axes
axis one you know zero 2 that's going to
be our columns and if you can do columns
then we also can do rows and that is
simply just changing the concatenate
we'll just grab this one here and copy
it we'll do the whole thing over
ctrl copy
ctrl v and changes from axis one
to axis zero and if we run that uh
you'll see that now we concatenate by
row as opposed to column
and you have four three six one seven
eight four seven so it just brings it
right down and turns it into rows versus
columns you can see the difference there
your output this really you want to look
at the output sometimes just to make
sure your eyes are looking at it
correctly and it's in the format i find
visually looking at it is almost more
important than
understanding what's going on because
conceptually your mind just just too
many dimensions sometimes
the second thing i want you to notice is
this says a numpy array so tensorflow is
utilizing numpy as part of their format
as far as python is concerned
and so you can treat you can treat this
output like a numpy array because it is
just that it's going to be a numpy array
another thing that comes up
more than you would think is filling
one of these with zeros or ones and so
you can see here we just create a tensor
tf.zeros
and we give it a shape we tell it what
kind of data type it is in this case
we're doing an integer and then if we
print out our tensor again we're in
jupiter so i just type out tensor and i
run this you can see i have a nice
array of the shape three comma four of
zeros one of the things i want to
highlight here is integer
32 if i go to the
tensorflow data types i want you to
notice how
we have float 16 float 32 float 64
complex if we scroll down you'll see the
integer down here 32 the reason for this
is that we want to control how many bits
are used in the precision
this is for exporting it to another
platform
so what would happen is i might run it
on this computer where python goes does
a float to indefinite however long it
wants to
and then we can take it but we want to
actually say hey we don't want that high
precision we want to be able to run this
on any computer
and so we need to control whether it's a
tf float 16 in this case we did an
integer 32
we could also do this as a float
so if i run this as a float 32
that means this has a 32 bit precision
you'll see zero point whatever and then
to go with uh zeros
we have ones if we're going from the
opposite side and so we can easily just
create a tensorflow with ones
and you might ask yourself why would i
want zeros and ones and your first
thought might be to initiate a new
tensor
usually we initiate a lot of this stuff
with random numbers because it does a
better job solving it if you start with
a uniform
set of ones or zeros you're dealing with
a lot of bias so be very careful about
starting a neural network
for one of your rows or something like
that with ones and zeros
on the other hand
i use this for masking you can do a lot
of work with masking you can also have
it might be that one tenser row is
masked
you know zero is is false one is true or
whatever you want to do it um
and so in that case you do want to use
the zeros and ones and there are cases
where you do want to initialize it with
all zeros or all ones and then swap in
different numbers as
the tensor learns so it's another form
of control
but in general
you see zeros and ones you usually are
talking about a mask over another array
and just like in numpy you can also
do reshapes so if we take our remember
this is shaped three comma four maybe we
want to swap that to four comma three
and if we print this out
you will see let me just go and do that
ctrl v
let me run that
and you'll see that the the order of
these is now switched instead of four
across now we have three across and four
down
and just for fun let's go back up here
where we did the ones
and i'm going to change the ones to
tf.random
uniform
and we'll go ahead and just take off
well we'll go and leave that i'm going
to run this
and you'll see now we have 0.0441
and this way you can actually see how
the reshape looks a lot different
0.041.15.71
and then instead of having this one it
rolls down here to the 0.14
and this is what i was talking about
sometimes you fill you a lot of times
you fill these with random numbers and
so this is the random dot uniform is one
of the ways to do that now i just talked
a little bit about this float 32 and all
these data types one of the things that
comes up of course is
recasting your data
so if we have a d type float32 we might
want to convert these to integers
because of the project we're working on
i know one of the projects i've worked
on
ended up wanting to do a lot of round
off so that it would take a dollar
amount or a float value and then have to
rent it off to a dollar amount so we
only wanted two decimal points
in which case you have a lot of
different options you can multiply by
100 and then round it off or whatever
you want to do there's a lot or then
converted to an integer was one way to
round it off
kind of
a cheap and dirty trick
so we can take this and we can take this
same
tensor and we'll go ahead and create a
as an integer and so we're going to take
this tensor we're going to tf.cast it
and if we print
tensor
and then we're going to go ahead and
print
our
tensor
let me just do a quick copy and paste
and when i'm actually programming i
usually type out a lot of my stuff just
to double check it
in doing a demo
copy and paste works fine but sometimes
be aware that copy and paste can copy
the wrong code over
personal choice depends on what i'm
working on
and you can see here we took
a float 32 4.6 4.2 and so on and it just
converts it right down to a integer
value
sorry integer 32 set up and
remember we talked about
a little bit about reshape
um as far as flipping it and i just did
four comma three on the reshape up here
and we talked about axes zero axis one
uh one of the things that is important
to be able to do is to take one of these
variables
we'll just take this last one tensor as
integer
and i want to go ahead and transpose it
and so i can do
we'll do a
equals tf.transpose
and we'll do our tensor integer in there
and then if i print the a out and we run
this
you'll see that's the same array but
we've flipped it so that our columns and
rows are flipped this is
the same as reshaping so when you
transpose you're just doing a reshape
what's nice about this is if you look at
the numbers the columns
when we went up here and we did the
reshape they kind of roll down to the
next row so you're not maintaining the
structure of your matrix so when we do a
reshape up here they're similar but
they're not quite the same and you can
actually go in here and there's settings
in the reshape that would allow you to
turn it into a transform
so we come down here it's all done for
you and so there are so many times you
have to transpose
your digits that this is important to
know that you can just do that you can
flip your rows and columns rather
quickly here and just like numpy you can
also do multiple your different math
functions we'll look at multiplication
and so we're going to take matrix
multiplication of tensors
we'll go ahead and create a as a
constant 5839
and we'll put in a vector v 4 comma 2.
and we could have done this where they
matched where this was a two by two
array
but instead
we're going to do just a two by one
array and the code for that is your
tf.mat
mole
so matrix multiplier and we have a times
v and if we go ahead and run this up
let's
make sure we print out our av on there
and if we go ahead and run this
you'll see that we end up with 36 by 30.
and if it's been a while since you've
seen the matrix math
this is
5 times 4 plus 8 times 2
3 times 4 plus 9 times 2
and that's where we get the 36 and 30.
now i know we're covering a lot really
quickly as far as the basic
functionality
so the matrix or your matrix multiplier
is a very commonly used back-end tool as
far as computing
different models or linear regression
stuff like that
one of the things
is to note is that just like in
numpy
you have all of your different math so
we have our tf math
and if we go in here we have
functions we have our cosines absolute
angle all of that's in here so all of
these
are available for you to use in the
tensorflow model and if we go back to
our example and let's go ahead and pull
oh let's do some multiplication that's
always good we'll stick with our
av
our
constant a and our vector v
and we'll go ahead and do some bit wise
multiplication and we'll create an av
which is a times b let's go and print
that out
and you can see coming across here
we have the four two and the five eight
three nine and it produces uh 20 32 618
and that's pretty straightforward if you
look at it you have four times
five is twenty four times eight is 32
that's where those numbers come from
we can also quickly create an identity
matrix
which is basically
your main values on the diagonal being
ones and zeros across the other side
let's go ahead and take a look and see
what that
looks like and we can do let's do this
so we're going to get the shape this is
a simple way very similar to your numpy
you can do a dot shape and it's going to
return a tuple in this case our rows and
columns and so we can do a quick
print
we'll do rows oops
and we'll do columns
and if we run this
you can see we have three rows uh two
columns
and then if we go ahead and create an
identity matrix
the scoops
the script for that
got a wrong button there the script for
that looks like this
where we have the number of rows equals
rows the number of columns equals
columns and d type is a 32 and then if
we go ahead and just print out our
identity
you can see we have a nice identity
column with our ones going across here
now clearly we're not going to go
through every math module
available but we do want to start
looking at this as a prediction model
and seeing how it functions
so we're going to move on to a more of a
direct setup we can actually see the
full tensorflow in use for that let's go
back and create a
new setup
and we'll go in here new python 3 module
there we go
bring this out so it takes up the whole
window because i like to do that
hopefully you made it through that first
part and you have a basic understanding
of tensorflow as far as being
a series of numpy arrays you got your
math equations and different things that
go into them
we're going to start building a full um
setup as far as the numpy so you can see
how uh kara sits on top of it and the
different aspects of how it works the
first thing we want to do is we're going
to go ahead and do a lot of imports
date times warning scipy scipy is your
math so the back end scientific math
warnings because whenever we do a lot of
this you have older versions newer
versions
and so sometimes when you get warnings
you want to go ahead and just suppress
them
we'll talk about that if it comes up on
this particular setup and of course date
time
pandas again is your data frame think
rows and columns we import it as pd
numpy is your numbers array which of
course tensorflow is integrated heavily
with
seaborn for our graphics and the seaborn
as sns is going to be set on top of our
matplot library which we import as mpl
and then of course we're going to import
our matplot library pi plot as plt and
right off the bat we're going to set
some graphic colors
patch force edge color equals true
the style we're going to use the 538
style you can look this all up there's
when you get into matplot library into
seaborne there are so many options in
here it's just kind of nice to make it
look pretty when we start the um
when we start up that way we don't have
to think about it later on
uh and then we're going to take we have
our
mplrc we're going to put a patch add
color dim gray line width again this is
all part of our graphics here in our
setup we'll go ahead and do an
interactive shell
node interactivity equals last
expression
here we are pd for pandas options
display max columns so we don't want to
display more than 50.
and then our map plot library is going
to be inline this is a jupiter notebook
thing the matplot library in line then
warnings we're going to filter our
warnings and we're just going to ignore
warnings that way when they come up we
don't have to worry about them
not really what you want to do when
you're working on a major project you
want to make sure you know those
warnings and then
filter them out and ignore them later on
and if we run this it's just going to be
loading all that into the background
so that's a little back end kind of
stuff then what we want to go ahead and
do is we want to go ahead and import
our specific packages
that we're going to be working with
which is under carrass now remember
cross kind of sits on tensorflow so when
we're importing cross and the sequential
model we are in effect importing
um tensorflow underneath of it uh we
just brought in the math probably should
have put that up above
and then we have our cross models we're
going to import sequential
now if you remember from our
slide there was three different options
let me just flip back over there so we
can have a quick uh recall on that and
so in carass
we have sequential functional and
subclassing so remember those three
different setups in here we talked about
earlier and if you remember from here we
have a sequential where it's going
one tensorflow layer at a time you go
kind of look at think of it as going
from left to right or top to bottom or
whatever direction it's going in but it
goes in one direction all the time where
functional can have a very complicated
graph of directions you can have the
data split into two separate tensors and
then it comes back together into another
tensor
all those kinds of things and then
subclassing is really the really
complicated one where now you're adding
your own subclasses into the tensor to
do external computations right in the
middle of like a huge flow of data
but we're going to stick with sequential
it's not a big jump to go from
sequential to functional
but we're running a sequential
tensorflow and that's what this first
import is here we want to bring in our
sequential
and then we have our layers and let's
talk a little bit about these layers
this is where cross and tensorflow
really are happening this is what makes
them so nice to work with is all these
layers are pre-built
so from cross we have layers import
dents
from cross layers import lstm
when we talk about these layers
cross has so many built-in layers you
can do your own layers
the dense layer is your standard neural
network
by default it uses relu for its
activation
and then the lstm is a long short term
memory layer since we're going to be
looking probably at sequential data
we want to go ahead and do the lstm and
if we go into
cross and we look at their layers this
is across website you can see as we
scroll down for the cross layers that
are built in
we can get down here and we can look at
let's see here we have our layer
activation our base layers
activation layer weight layer waste
there's a lot of stuff in here we had
the relu which is the basic activation
that was listed up here for layer
activations you can change those
and here we have our core layers and our
dense layers we have an input layer a
dense layer
and then we've added more customized one
with the long-term short-term memory
layer and of course you can even do your
own custom layers in cross there's a
whole functionality in there if you're
doing your own thing
what's really nice about this is it's
all built in even the convolutional
layers this is for processing graphics
there's a lot of cool things in here you
can do this is why cross is so popular
it's open source and you have all these
tools right at your fingertips so from
cross we're just going to import a
couple layers the dense layer
and the long short term memory layer
and then of course from
sk learn our scikit
we want to go ahead and do our min max
scalar standard scaler for pre editing
our
data and then metrics just so we can
take a look at the errors and compute
those let me go ahead and run this and
that just loads it up we're not
expecting anything from the output and
our file coming in is going to be air
quality.csv let's go ahead and take a
quick look at that this is in open
office it's just a standard you know mic
can do excel whatever you're using for
your spreadsheet and you can see here we
have a number of columns a number of
rows it actually goes down to like 8 000
the first thing we want to notice is
that the first row
is kind of just a random number put in
going down probably not something we're
going to work with
the second row
is bendung i'm guessing that's a
reference for the profile
if we scroll to the bottom which i'm not
going to do because it takes forever to
get back up they're all the same
the same thing with the status the
status is the same
we have a date so we have a sequential
order here
here is the jam which i'm going to guess
is the time stamp on there so we have a
date and time
we have our o3 co no2 reading so2 no co2
voc
and then some other numbers here pm1 pm
2.5 pm4 pm10
10 without actually
looking through the data i mean some of
this i can guess is like temperature
humidity i'm not sure what the pms are
but we have a whole slew of data here so
we're looking at air quality as far as
an area in a region and what's going on
with our date timestamps on there and so
code wise we're going to read this into
a panda's data frame so our data frame
df is a nice abbreviation commonly used
for data frames equals pd.read csv and
then our the path to it just happens to
be on my d drive
separated by spaces and so if we go
ahead and run this
we'll print out the head of our data and
again this looks very similar to what we
were just looking at
being in jupiter i can take this and go
the other way
make it real small so you can see all
the columns going across and we get a
full view of it
or we can bring it back up in size
that's pretty small on there overshot
but you can see it's the same data we
were just looking at we're looking at
the number we're looking at the profile
which is the ben dung
the
date we have a time stamp
our o3 count co and so forth on here
and this is just your basic
pandas printing out the top five rows we
could easily have done three rows
uh five rows ten whatever you want to
put in there by default that's five for
pandas now i talk about this all the
time so i know i've already said it at
least once or twice during this video
most of our work is in pre-formatting
data what are we looking at how do we
bring it together
so we want to go ahead and start with
our date time it's come in in two
columns
we have our date here and we have our
time
and we want to go ahead and combine that
and then we have this is just a simple
script in there that says combined date
time that's our formula we're building
our we're going to submit our
pandas data frame
and the tab name when we go ahead and do
this
that's all of our information that we
want to go ahead and create and then
goes for i in range df
shape 0.
so we're going to go through
the whole setup and we're going to list
tab append df location i and here is our
date going in there and then return the
numpy array list tab d types date time
64. that's all we're doing we're just
switching this to a date time stamp and
if we go ahead and do df date time
equals combined date time
and then i always like to uh print we'll
do df head
just we can see what that looks like
and so when we come out of this
we now have our setup on here and of
course it's added it on to the far right
here's our date time
you can see the formats changed
so there's our we've added in the date
time column and we've brought the date
over and we've taken this format here
and it's an actual variable with a 0 0 0
on here well that doesn't look good so
we need to also include the time part of
this we want to convert it into hourly
data
so let's go ahead and do that
to do that uh to finish combining our
date time let's go ahead and create a a
little
script here to combine the time in there
same thing we just did we're just
creating a numpy array returning a numpy
array and cr forcing this into a date
time format and we can actually spend
hours just going through
these conversions how do you
pull it from the panda's data frame how
do you set it up
so i'm kind of skipping through it a
little fast because i want to stay
focused on tensorflow and cross
keep in mind this is like 80 of your
coding when you're doing a lot of this
stuff is going to be reformatting these
things resetting them back up
uh so that it looks right on here and
you know it just takes time to to get
through all that but that is usually
what the companies are paying you for
that's what the big
bucks are for
and we want to go ahead and a couple
things going on here is we're going to
go ahead and do our date time we're
going to reorganize some of our setup in
here convert into hourly data we just
put a pause in there
now remember we can select from df are
different columns we're going to be
working with and you're going to see
that we actually dropped
a couple of the columns those ones i
showed you earlier they're just
repetitive data so there's nothing in
there that exciting
and then we want to go ahead and we'll
create a
second
data frame here let me just get rid of
the df head
and df2 is we're going to group by date
time and we're looking at the mean value
and then we'll print that out so you can
see what we're talking about
uh we have now reorganized this so we
put in date time 03 co so now this is in
the same order
as it was before and you'll see the date
time
now has our 0 0
same date 1 2 3 and so on so let's group
the data together so there's a lot more
manageable and in the format we want and
in the right sequential order
and if we go back to
there we go our air quality
you can see right here we're looking at
these columns going across we really
don't need since we're going to create
our own
date time column we can get rid of those
these are the different columns of
information we want and that should
reflect right here in the columns we
picked coming across so this is all the
same columns on there that's all we've
done is reformatted our data
grouped it together by date and then you
can see the different data coming out
set up on there and then as a data
scientist
first thing i want to do is get a
description what am i looking at uh and
so we can go ahead and do the df2
describe and this gives us our you know
describe gives us our basic data
analytics information we might be
looking for like what is the mean
standard deviation
uh minimum amount maximum amount we have
our first quarter second quarter and
third quarter
numbers also in there
so you can get a quick look at a glance
describing the data or descriptive
analysis and even though we have our
quantile information in here we're going
to dig a little deeper into that
we're going to calculate the quantile
for each variable
we're going to look at a number of
things for each variable and we'll see
right here q1 uh we can simply do the
quantile 0.25 percent
which should match um our 25 up here and
we'll be looking at the min the max
and we're just going to do this
basically we're breaking this down for
each uh different
variable in there
one of the things that's kind of fun to
do
we're going to look at that in just a
second let me get put the next piece of
code in here
clean out some of our
we're going to drop a couple thing our
last rows and first row because those
have
usually have a lot of null values and
the first row is just our titles so
that's important it's important to drop
those rows in here and so this right
here as we look at our different
quantiles
again it's it's the same you know we're
still looking at the 25
quantile here
we're going to do a little bit more with
this
so now that we've cleared off our first
and last rows we're going to go ahead
and go through
all of our columns and this way we can
look at each
column individually and so we'll
just create a q1 q3 min max min iqr max
iqr
and calculate the quantile of i of df2
we're basically doing
the math that they did up here but we're
splitting it apart that's all this is
and
this happens a lot because you might
want to look at individual if this was
my own project i would probably spend
days and days going through
what these different values mean
one of the biggest
data science
things we can look at that's important
is
use your use your common sense
you know if you're looking at this data
and it doesn't make sense and you go
back in there and you're like wait a
minute what the heck did i just do
at that point you probably should go
back and double check what you have
going on
now
we're looking at this and you can see
right here here's our attribute for our
o3 so we've broken it down
we have our q1 5.88 q3 10.37 if we go
back up here here's our 5.8 we've
rounded it off
10.37 is in there
so we've basically done the same math
just split it up we have our minimum and
our max iqr and that's computed let's
see where is it here we go
q1 minus 1.5 times iqr and the iqr is
your q3 minus q1 so that's the
difference between our two different
quarters and this is all
data science
as far as the hard math
we're really not we're actually trying
to focus on cross and tensorflow you
still got to go through all this stuff i
told you eighty percent of your
programming is going through and
understanding what the heck
happened here
what's going on what does this data mean
and so when we're looking in that we're
going to go ahead and say hey
we've computed these numbers and the
reason we've computed these numbers is
if you take the minimum value and it's
less than your minimum iqr
that means something's going wrong there
and they usually in this case is going
to show us an outlier
so we want to go ahead and find the
minimum value if it's less than the min
minimum iqr it's an outlier and if the
max value is greater than the
max iqr we have an outlier and that's
all this is doing low outliers found
minimum value high outlier is found
really important actually outliers are
almost everything in data sometimes
sometimes you do this project just to
find the outliers because you want to
know
uh crime detection what are we looking
for we're looking for the outliers what
doesn't fit a normal business deal and
then we'll go ahead and throw in um just
threw in a lot of code oh my goodness uh
so we have if your max is greater than
iqr print outlier is found what we want
to do is we want to start cleaning up
these outliers and so we want to convert
we'll do create a convert nand
x max iqr equals max
underscore iqr min iqr equals mini qr so
this is just saying this is the data
we're going to send that's all that is
in python and if x is greater than the
max iqr and x is less than the min iqr x
equals uh null we're going to set it to
null why because we want to clear
these outliers out of the data now again
if you're doing fraud detection you
would do the opposite you would be
cleaning everything else that's not in
that series so that you can look at just
the outlier and then we're going to
convert the nand hum again we have x
max iqr is 100
min iqr is men iqr
if x is greater than max iqr and x is
less than min iqr again we're going to
return a null value otherwise it's going
to remain the same value x x equals x
and you can see as we go through the
code if i equals
our hum
then we go ahead and do this
that's a column specific to humidity
that's your hum column
then we're going to go ahead and convert
do the
run a map on there and convert the non
h2m
uh you can see here it's this is just
cleanup uh we run we found out that
humidity probably has some weird values
in it uh we have our outliers
that's all this is
and so when we go ahead and finish this
and we take a look at our outliers
and we run this code here
we have a low outlier 2.04 we have a
high outlier
99.06
outliers have been interpolated
that means we've given them a new value
chances are these days when you're
looking at something like
these sensors coming in
they probably have a failed sensor in
there something went wrong
that's the kind of thing that you really
don't want to do your data analysis on
so that's what we're doing is we're
pulling that out and then
converting it over and setting it up
method linear
so we interpolate left
linear as it's going to fill that data
in
based on a linear regression model of
similar data
same thing with this up here with the um
df2y interpolate that's what we're doing
again this is all data prep
we're not actually talking about
tensorflow we're just trying to get all
our data
set up correctly so that when we run it
it's not going to cause problems or have
a huge bias
so we've dealt with outliers
specifically in humidity
and again this is one of these things
where when we start running
um we ran through this you can see down
here that we have our
outliers found
high low outliers um
migrated them in we also know there's
other issues going on with this data
how do we know that
some of it's just looking at the data
playing with it until you start
understanding what's going on let's take
the temp value
and we're going to go ahead and use a
logarithmic function on the temp value
and
it's interesting because it's like how
do you how do you heck do you even know
to use logarithmic on the temp value
that's domain specific
we're talking about being an expert in
air care i'm not an expert in air care
um you know it's not what i go look at i
don't look at air care data in fact this
is probably the first air care data set
up i've looked at but the experts come
in there and they come to you and say
hey in data science this is a
exponentially variable variable on here
so we need to go ahead and do
transform it
and use a logarithmic scale on that
so at that point that would be coming
from your
data here we go data science programmer
overview does a lot of stuff connecting
the database and connecting in with the
experts
data analytics a lot of times you're
talking about somebody who is a data
analysis might be all the way usually a
phd level
data science programming level
interfaces database manager that's going
to be the person who's your admin
working on it
so when we're looking at this we're
looking at something they've sent to me
and they said hey
domain air care
this needs to be this is a skew because
the data just goes up exponentially and
affects everything else and we'll go
ahead and take that data let me just go
ahead and run this
just for another quick look at it
we have our uh we'll do a distribution
df from the temp values and then from a
data set from the log temp so we can put
them side by side and we'll just go
ahead and do a quick histogram this is
kind of nice plot of figure figure size
here's our plt from matplot library
and then we'll just do a distribution
underscore df there's our data frames
this is nice because it just integrates
the histogram right into pandas love
pandas
and this is a chart you would send back
to your data analysis and say hey is
this what you wanted this is how the
data is converting on here as a data
science scientist the first thing i note
is we've gone from a 10
20 30 scales at 2.5 3.0 3.5 scale
and the data itself has kind of been
adjusted a little bit based on some kind
of a skew on there so let's jump into
we're getting a little closer to
actually doing our
cross on here
we'll go ahead and split our data up
and this of course is any good data
scientists
you want to have a training set and a
test set
and we'll go ahead and do the train size
we're going to use 0.75 percent of the
data make sure it's an integer we don't
want to take a slice as a float value
give you a nice error
and we'll have our train size of 75
percent and the test size is going to be
of course the train size minus the
length of the data set and then we can
simply do train comma test
here's our data set
which is going to be the train size the
test size uh and then if we go and print
this let me just go ahead and run this
we can see how these values
split it's a nice split of 1298 and then
433 points of value
they're going to be for our
setup on here and if you remember we're
specifically looking at the data set
where did we create that data set from
um that was from up here that's what we
called the
logarithmic
value of the temp
that's where the data set came from so
we're looking at just that column with
this train size and the test with the
train and test data set here and let's
go ahead and do uh convert an array of
values into a data set matrix we're
going to create a little um
set up in here we'll create our data set
our data set's going to come in we're
going to do a look back of one so we're
going to look back one piece of data
going backward
and we have our data x and our data y
for i and range length of data set look
back -1
this is creating let me just go ahead
and run this actually the best way to do
this
is to go ahead and create this data
and take a look at the shape of it let
me go ahead and just put that code in
here
so we're going to do a look back one
here's our train x our train y
and it's going to be adding the data on
there and then when we come up here
and we take a look at the shape
there we go
and we run this piece of code here
we look at the shape on this and we have
a new slightly different change on here
but we have a shape of x 1296 comma 1
shape of y train y test x text y
and so what we're looking at is that
the x comes in
and we're only having a single value at
out
uh we want to predict what the next one
is that's what this little piece of code
is here for what are we looking for well
we want to look back one that's the um
what we're going to train the data with
is yesterday's data yesterday says hey
the humidity was at
97 percent what should today's humidity
be at if it's 97 yesterday is it going
to go up or is it going to go down today
if 97 does it go up to 100 what's going
on there uh and so our we're looking
forward to the next piece of data which
says hey tomorrow's is going to you know
today's humidity is this this is what
tomorrow's humidity is going to be
that's all that is all that is is
stacking our data so that
our y is basically
x plus one or x could be y minus one
and then a couple of things to note is
our x data
we're only dealing with the one column
but you need to have it in a shape that
has it by the columns so you have the
two different numbers and since we're
doing just a single point of data
we have and you'll see with the train y
we don't need to have the extra shape on
here
now this is going to run into a problem
and the reason is is that we have what
they call a time step
and the time step is that long term
short term memory layer
so we're going to add another reshape on
here let me just go down here and put it
into the next cell
and so we want to reshape the input
array in the form of sample time step
features
we're only looking at one
feature and i mean this is one of those
things when you're playing with this
you're like why am i getting an error in
the numpy array why is this giving me
something weird going on uh so we're
going to do is we're going to add one
more uh level on here instead of being
12.991 we want to go one more
and when they put the code together in
the back you can see we kept the same
shape the 1299
we added the one dimension and then we
have our train x shape one
and this could have depends again on how
far back in the long short term memory
you want to go
that is what that piece of code is for
and that reshape is and you can see the
new shape is now one uh
1299 one one
versus the 1299 one and then the other
part of the shape 432 one one again this
is our tr our x in and of course our
test x and then our y is just a single
column because we're just doing one
output that we're looking for
so now we've done our 80 percent um you
know that's all the the
writing all the code reformatting our
data
um
bringing it in now we want to go ahead
and do the fun part which is we're going
to go ahead and create and fit
the lstm neural network uh and if we're
going to do that the first thing we need
is we're going to need to go ahead and
create a model and we'll do this
sequential model and if you remember
sequential means it just goes in order
that means we have if you have two
layers the layers go from layer one to
layer two or layer zero to layer one
this is different than functional
functional allows you to split the data
and run two completely separate models
and then bring them back together
we're doing just sequential on here and
then we decided to do the long short
term memory uh and we have our input
shape uh which it comes in again this is
what all this switching was we could
have easily made this one two three or
four going back as far as the end number
on there we just stuck to going back one
and it's always a good idea when you get
to this point where the heck
is this model coming from
what kind of models do we have available
and there's let me go and put the next
model in there uh because we're going to
do two models and the next model is
going to go ahead and we're going to do
dent so we have model equal sequential
and then we're going to add the lstm
model and then we're going to add a
dense model and if you remember from the
very top of our code
where we did the imports oops there we
go our cross
this is it right here here's our
importing a dense model and here's our
importing an lstm now just about every
tensorflow model uses dents
your dense model is your basic
forward propagation reverse propagation
error
or it does reverse propagation to
program the model
so any of your neural networks you've
already looked at that
luxon says here's the error and sends
the error backwards that's what this is
the long short term memory is a little
different
the real question that we want to look
at right now is where do you find these
models what kind of models do you have
available and so for that let's go to
the cross website
which is the cross dot io
if you go under api slash layers and i
always have to do a search
just search for cross api layers it'll
open up and you can see we have
your base layers right here class
trainable weights all kinds of stuff
like there your activation
so a lot of your layers you can switch
how it activates
relu which is like your smaller arrays
or if you're doing convolutional neural
networks the convolution usually uses a
relu
your sigmoid all the way up to soft max
soft plus all these different choices as
far as how those
are set up and what we want to do is we
want to go ahead and if you scroll down
here you'll see your core layers and
here is your dense layer uh so you have
an input object your dense layer your
activation layer embedding layer
this is your your kind of your one set
up on there that's most common
uh convolutional neural networks or
convolutional layers these are like for
doing uh image categorizing so trying to
find objects in a picture that kind of
thing
we have pooling layers so as you have
the layers come together um usually you
bring them down into
a single layer although you can still do
like global max pulling 3d and there is
just i mean this list just goes on and
on there's all kinds of different things
hidden in here as far as what you can do
and it changes you know you go in here
and you just have to do a search for
what you're looking for
and figure out what's going to work best
for you
as far as which project you're working
on
long short-term memory is a big one
because this is when we start talking
about text
uh what if someone says the what comes
after the uh the cat in the hat a little
kid's uh book there um it starts
programming it and so you really want to
know not only
what's going on but it's going to be
something that has a history the history
behind it tells you what the next one
coming up is
now once we've built all our different
you know we built our model we've added
our different layers we went in there
play with it remember if you're in
functional you can actually link these
layers together and they branch out and
come back together if you do a
the sub
setup then you can create your own
different model you can embed a model in
there that might be coming linear
regression you can embed a linear
regression model
as part of your functional split and
then have that come back together with
other things
so we're going to go ahead and compile
your model this brings everything
together we're going to put in what the
loss is which we'll use the mean squared
error
and we'll go ahead and use the atom
optimizer clearly there's a lot of
choices on here depending on what you're
doing and just like any of these
different prediction models if you've
been doing any uh
scikit from python uh you'll recognize
that we have to then fit the model
uh so what are we doing in here we're
gonna send in our train x our train y
uh we're gonna decide how many epochs
we're going to run it through 500 is
probably a lot for this i'm guessing
it'd probably be about two or three
hundred probably do just fine
our batch size
so how many different uh when you
process it this is the math behind it
if you're in data analytics
you might try to know what this number
is as a data scientist where i haven't
had the phd level math that says this is
why you want to use this particular
batch size you kind of play with this
number a little bit
you can dig deeper into the math
see how it affects the results depending
on what you're doing
and there's a number of other settings
on here we did verbose 2. i'd have to
actually look that up to tell you what
verbose means i think that's actually
the default on there if i remember
correctly
there's a lot of different settings when
you go to fit it
the big ones are your epic and your
batch size those are what we're looking
for
and so we're going to go ahead and run
this
and this is going to take a few minutes
to run because it's going through
500 times
through all the data so if you have a
huge data set this is the point where
you're kind of wondering oh my gosh is
this going to finish tomorrow
if i'm running this on a single machine
and i have a tera terabyte of data
going into it
if this is my personal computer and i'm
running a terabyte of data into this um
you know this is running rather quickly
through all 500 iterations uh but yeah a
terabyte of data we're talking something
closer to days week
um you know even with a a
3.5 gigahertz machine in in eight cores
it's still going to take a long time to
go through a full terabyte of data
and then we want to start looking at
putting it into some other framework
like spark or something that will print
the process on there more across
multiple
processors and multiple computers
and if we scroll all the way down to the
bottom you're going to see here's our
square mean error of 0.0088
if we scroll way up you'll see it kind
of oscillates between 0.088 and 08.0089
it's right around two
250 where you start seeing that
oscillation where it's really not going
anywhere so we really didn't need to go
through a full 500 epics
uh you know if you're retraining this
stuff over and over again it's kind of
good to know where that
error zone is so you don't have to do
all the extra processing of course if
you're going to build a model
we want to go ahead and run a prediction
on it
so let's go ahead and make our
prediction remember we have our training
test set
and our test set or that
we have the
train x and the train y for training it
or train predict and then we have our
test x and our test y going in there
so we can test to see how good it did
and we come in here we have
you'll see right here we go ahead and do
our train predict equals
model predict train x
and test predict model predict test x
why would we want to run the prediction
on train x well it's not a hundred
percent on its prediction we know it has
a certain amount of error and we want to
compare the error we have on what we
programmed it with with the error we get
when we run it on new data that's never
seen the model's never seen before and
one of the things we can do we go ahead
and invert the predictions
this helps us
level it off a little bit more
get rid of some of our bias we have
train predict equals and np
exponential m1 the train predict
and then train y equals the exponential
m1 for train y and then we do the again
that with train test predict and test y
um
again reformatting the data so that we
can it all matches and then we want to
go ahead and calculate the root mean
square error
so we have our train score uh which is
your math square root times the mean
square root error train
y and train predict and again we're just
this is just feeding the data through so
we can compare it and the same thing
with the test
and let's take a look at that because
really
the code makes sense if you're going
through it line by line you can see
we're doing but the answer really helps
to zoom in
so we have a train score which is 2.40
of our root mean square error
and we have a test score of 3.16 of the
root mean square error
if these were reversed if our test score
is better than our training score
then we've over trained something's
really wrong at that point you got to go
back and figure out what you did wrong
because you should never have a better
result on your test data than you do
when you're training data and that's why
we put them both through that's why we
look at the error for both the training
and the testing
when you're going out and quoting you're
publishing this you're saying hey how
good is my model it's the test score
that you're showing people this is what
it did on my test data that the model
had never seen before this is how good
my model is and a lot of times you
actually want to put together like a
little formal code
where we actually want to print that out
and if we print that out you can see
down here
um test prediction standard deviation of
data set 3.16 is less than 4.40
i'd have to go back
and we're
up here if you remember we did the
square means error this is standard
deviation that's why these numbers are
different
it's saying the same thing that we just
talked about
uh
3.16 is less than 4.40 model is good
enough we're saying hey this is this
model is valid we have a valid model
here so we can go ahead and go with that
uh and along with
putting a formal print out of there
we want to go ahead and plot what's
going on
and this we just want to pretty graft
here so that people can see what's going
on when i walk into a meeting and i'm
dealing with a number of people
they really don't want these numbers
they don't want to say hey what's i mean
standard deviation unless you know what
statistics are
you might be dealing with a number of
different departments head of cells
might not work with standard deviation
or have any idea what that really means
number wise and so at this point we
really want to put it in a graph so we
have something to display and with
displaying you remember that we're
looking at the data
today going into it and what's going to
happen tomorrow
so let's take a quick look at this we're
going to go ahead and shift the train
predictions for plotting we have our
train predict plot
np empty like data set train predict
plot
set it up with null values
you know it's just kind of it's kind of
a weird thing where we're creating the
the data groups as we like them
and then putting the data in there is
what's going on here so we have our
train predict plot
which is going to be our look back our
length
plus look back
we're just is gonna equal train uh
train predict so we're creating this
basically we're taking this and we're
dumping the train predict into it so now
we have our nice train predict plot
and then we have the shift test
predictions for the plotting we're going
to continue more of that oops looks like
i put it in here double no it's just uh
yeah they put it in here double
didn't mean to do that
we really only need to do it once oh
here we go
this is where the problem was is because
this is the test predict
so we have our training prediction we're
doing the shift on here and then the
test predict we're going to look at that
same thing we're just creating those two
data sets
test
predict plot length prediction set up on
there
and then we're going to go through the
plotting the original data set and the
predictions so we have a time axis
always nice to have your time set on
there
set that to the time array
time axes lap
all this is setting up the time variable
for the bottom and then we have a lot of
stuff going on here as far as setting up
our figure
let's go ahead and run that and then
we'll break it down
we have on here
our main plot we have two different
plots going on here
the ispu going up and the data and the
ispu here with all these different
settings on it
and so we look at this we have our ax1
that's the main plot i mean our ax
that's the main plot and we have our ax1
which is the secondary plot over here so
we're doing a figure plt
or plt.figure
and we're going to dump those two graphs
on there um and so we take
and if you
go through the code piece by piece
which we're not going to do we're going
to do the um the
data set here
exponential reverse exponential so it
looks correctly we're going to label it
the original data set
we're going to plot the train predict
plot that's what we just created
we're going to make that orange and
we'll label it train prediction
uh test predicts plot we're going to
make that red and label it test
prediction and so forth
set our ticks up this actually just put
ticks time axis gets its ticks
the little little marks they're going
along the axes that kind of thing and
let's take a look and see what these
graphs look like
and these are just kind of fun you know
when you show up into a meeting and this
is the final output you say hey this is
what we're looking at
here's our original data in blue
here's our training prediction
you can see that it trains pretty close
to what the data is up there
i would also probably put a
like a little little time stamp and do
just right before and right after where
we go from train to test prediction
and you can see with the test prediction
the data comes in in red
and then you can also see what the
original data set look like behind it
and how it differs
and then we can just isolate that here
on the right that's all this is
is just the
test prediction on the right
and it's you know there's you'll see
with the original data set there's a lot
of peaks were missing and a lot of lows
were missing but as far as the actual
test prediction it's pretty does pretty
good it's pretty right on you can get a
good idea what to expect for your ispu
and so from this we would probably
publish it and say hey this is um
what you expect and this is our area of
this is a range of error that's the kind
of thing i put out
on a daily basis maybe we predict the
cells are going to be this or maybe a
weekly
so you kind of get a nice kind of
flatten the
data coming out and you say hey this is
what we're looking at the big takeaway
from this is that we're working with
let me go back up here oops oh too far
there we go
is this model here this is what this is
all about we worked through all of those
pieces um all the tensorflows and that
is to build this sequential model and
we're only putting in the two layers
this can get pretty complicated if you
get too complicated it never
it it never verges into a usable model
so if you have like 30 different layers
in here there's a good chance you might
crash it kind of thing
so don't go too haywire on that and that
you kind of learn as you go again it's
domain knowledge
and also starting to understand all
these different layers and what they
mean
the data
analytics behind those layers
is something that your data analysis
professional will come in and say this
is what we want to try
but i tell you as a data scientist
a lot of these basic setups are common
and i don't know how many times
working with somebody and they're like
oh my gosh if i only did a tangent h
instead of a relu activation
i worked for two weeks to figure that
out well as a data science i can run it
through the model in you know five
minutes instead of spending two weeks
doing the the math behind it
so that's one of the advantages of data
scientist is we do it from programming
side and a data analytics is going to
look for it how does it work in math
and this is really the core right here
of tensorflow and cross is being able to
build your data model quickly and
efficiently and of course uh with any
data science putting out a pretty graph
so that your shareholders again we want
to take and
reduce the information down to something
people can look at and say oh that's
what's going on they can see stuff
what's going on as far as the dates and
the change in the ispu
hello guys welcome to yet another video
by simply learn i am keef tana and today
we shall be talking about the top 10
artificial intelligence technologies
before getting into the video here's a
gentle reminder to subscribe to our
channel and hit the bell icon so that
you wouldn't miss any update from us
so
without further ado let's quickly jump
into the topic
in the list we have
natural language generation smart
devices
virtual agents speech recognition
augmented reality machine learning
robotic process automation
decision management
deep learning and
finally image recognition
please note that the list is in no
particular order
natural language generation
communicating or conveying the
information efficiently and
transparently is very much crucial in
communication
to say the right words in the right
sequence to convey the message clearly
humans often find it tricky and when it
comes to machines it's trickier
natural language generation is a
discipline of artificial intelligence
and is a trendy technology that converts
the structured data into a native
language
the machines are programmed in such a
way that the algorithms convert the data
into a desirable format for the users
this technology is widely used in
customer service report generation and
summarizing business intelligence
insights
some of the sample vendors are a tvo
automated insights sas
cambridge semantics digital reasoning
narrative science
etc
on the list next we have smart devices
with every passing day smart devices are
becoming more popular and more trendy
technologies that people were using once
upon a time are now remodeled and
modified as smart devices
they can be used in almost every
industry to improve efficiency and
optimize the operations
smart devices are everyday objects made
intelligent with advanced computations
which include artificial intelligence
and machine learning
they are electronic gadgets that are
able to connect share and interact with
its users and other smart devices
some of the smart devices are
smart watches smart glasses smart phones
smart speakers
etc
virtual agents
they are computer generated intelligence
that provides online customer assistance
they can effectively communicate with
humans
in most of the web and mobile
applications we see chatbots as customer
service agents who interact with us
answering our queries
in simple
virtual agents are a manifestation of a
technology which aims to create an
effective but digital impersonation of
humans
agents can make reservations
book an appointment
place an order and can even avail
product information
some of the best examples of virtual
agents are google assistant and amazon
alexa
and the companies that provide virtual
agents are microsoft google amazon and
assist ai
next we have speech recognition
speech recognition is yet another
sub-discipline of artificial
intelligence which is used to convert
human speech into a comprehensive and
useful format for computer applications
to process
it can be said as a bridge between
computer interactions and humans
it's presently used on interactive voice
response systems and mobile applications
some of the companies offering speech
recognition services are nuanced
communications open text nice and varied
systems
augmented reality
yet another trendy technology in the
field of artificial intelligence
augmented reality is an enhanced version
of the real physical world that is
achieved using sound digital visual
elements and other sensory stimuli
delivered via technology
augmented reality uses the existing
environment and adds information to it
to make a new artificial environment it
alters the perception of the real world
environment
augmented reality is making its way into
several retail stores that make makeup
selection and furnishing much more fun
and interactive
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skill up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
machine learning
machine learning is an application and
an important branch of artificial
intelligence which refers to machines
being able to learn by themselves
without being explicitly programmed
it enables systems to learn and improve
from experience automatically
machine learning platforms are becoming
more and more popular with the help of
algorithms
apis
big data and applications and training
tools
enterprises are heavily investing in
machine learning to reap its benefits
for the various domains
machine learning is widely used for
categorization
and prediction
some of the sample vendors are
amazon
fractal analytics
google
microsoft etc robotic process automation
configuring a robot to interpret
communicate and analyze data is robotic
process automation
it uses scripts and other methods to
automate the human actions which in turn
supports efficient business processes
robotic process automation is widely
used in those areas where the physical
presence of a human is dangerous
feels like warfare mining etc is where
it's currently being used
we need to remember that artificial
intelligence is not meant to replace
humans but instead it is to complement
their abilities and reinforce the human
talent
companies that are focusing on robotic
process automation are pika systems
automation anywhere blue prism etc next
on the list we have decision management
decision management is yet another
technology in artificial intelligence
that helps companies make valid
decisions by providing up-to-date and
relevant information and performing
analytic functions
artificial intelligence when combined
with decision management helps translate
customer data into predictive models of
key trends
it also helps in making quick decisions
avoidance of risks and in the automation
of the process
decision management is widely used in
the healthcare sector financial sector
insurance sector
e-commerce and many more
some of the companies that provide this
service are informatica advanced systems
concepts pica systems
mana
etc
deep learning
deep learning is a branch of artificial
intelligence that mimics the workings of
the human brain in processing data
this data is used for a variety of
purposes like recognizing speech
detecting objects translating languages
and making decisions
deep learning uses hierarchical level of
artificial neural networks for carrying
out the process of machine learning
which is used across several industries
for various applications
some of the sample vendors are deep
instinct fluid ai
math works saffron technology
etc
at last we have image recognition
image recognition is the process of
detecting an object or feature in a
digital image or video
it can be used to analyze clients and
their opinions verify users based on
their faces detect license plates and
diagnose diseases the present-day image
recognition is comparable to human
visual perception
many social media platforms like
facebook use this technology to enhance
image search and aid visually impaired
users clarify gums and sense time
provide this technology thank you all
for watching this full course video
tutorial on artificial intelligence i
hope you liked it if you have any
questions then please feel free to put
them in the comment section our team
will help you solve your queries
thank you for watching and keep learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here